WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING WE ARE
QUITE A BIT SHY OF A QUORUM SO
WOULD ASK AT ANY MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE THAT
ARE IN THE BUILDING TO PLEASE
COME TO THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SO
YOU CAN PARTICIPATE IN OUR
HEARING THIS MORNING. A WELCOME
TO THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING OUR ONE AND ONLY
HEARING WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS
AHEAD OF US FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL OF THE STAFF THAT
HAVE MADE OUR RETURN OF CAPITAL
TO HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE- DUE TO
THE CURRENT STATE HOME ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEEN HERE IN THE
HEARING CHAMBER THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ONLY
HAD ARE ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. TODAY IN ROOM- WE'RE
HAVING TO PHYSICALLY DISTANT.
IN PERSON HEARING. IN THIS
SPACE WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
THIRTY MEMBERS. A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
THE SIX FEET SPACING. THERE ARE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE- FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY IN THE HEARING. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
I'LL LOOK FOR YOU AND I'LL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I
WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE
DONE TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITOL.
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
TODAY'S AGENDA WILL BE TAKEN UP
IN THE ORDER LISTED ON THE
AGENDA AND IN THE DAILY FILE IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER OF THE
AUTHOR REGARDLESS OF COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP. SO IF YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE YOUR
BILL WILL COME UP. IN ORDER IN
THAT ORDER. AND AS SUCH ARE
FIRST MEMBERS HERE. AND SHE'S A
COMMITTEE MEMBER SO- IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE ALSO. WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES AND MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE WITNESSES. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES. WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN IN THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
SO I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT AGAIN
BUT IT WILL ALSO- FIND THIS ON
OUR WAY I COMMITTEE WEBSITE THE
DAILY FILE AND ALSO ON YOUR TV
SCREEN IF YOU'RE WATCHING BUT I
REPEAT IT ONE MORE TIME. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN PLEASE TEN TO A PLAN TO DO
SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A MAIN
WITNESS IF YOU ARE MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST
A BILL YOU ARE MADE ON A LIVE
LINE YOU WILL BE ASKED NEED TO
MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE SEVEN AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. I WOULD
JUST SAY ALSO IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN. ITS NOTE YOU DON'T NEED TO
ASK CAN YOU HEAR ME. IF WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU WE WILL LET YOU
KNOW. SO PLEASE- WE HAVE A LOT
OF BILLS TODAY SO TRUST ME
WE'LL HEAR YOU AND IF WE CAN'T
WILL WILL LAST A MODERATOR TO.
FIND A WAY SO THAT WE CAN.
MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL ASK A
QUESTION OR PROVIDE COMMENT.
YOU NEED TO RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONE. SO STAFF CAN
ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO
PLEASE STAND UP AND FACE THE
MICROPHONE WAS SPEAKING TO
ENSURE YOUR VOICE IS AUDIBLE
AND RECORDED. AS CHAIR OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE I CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT HEALTHCARE POLICY AND
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THEIR FORM REQUESTING THAT ALL
MEMBERS BOTH OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND AUTHORS WERE FACE COVERINGS
FOR THE DURATION OF THE
HEARING. WE DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO ONE I GLADLY PROVIDE HIM FOR
YOU I GOT A PACKAGE OF IN HERE.
VERSE WILL NOT BE RECOGNIZED IF
THEY ARE NOT FOLLOWING THE
GUIDANCE OF LEADERSHIP. AND
WEARING A FACE COVERING IN THE
CHAMBERS TODAY. AND EVERYONE
WILL NEED TO. ESPECIALLY BE
ESPECIALLY STRICT ON THE TIME
LIMITS TODAY. WE'LL HEAR FROM
UP TO TWO WITNESSES FOR THREE
MINUTES EACH FOR EACH SIDE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WILL BE
LIMITED TO THEIR NAME.
ORGANIZATION IF THEY REPRESENT
ONE AND THE POSITION ON THE
BILL. WE DO HAVE A ROBUST
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE DON'T HAVE
THIRTY SIX BILLS ON THE
CONSECUTIVE WITH THAT WOULD BE
NICE- BUT IT IS PRETTY LARGE-
THE FOLLOWING BILLS RUN CONSENT
ANY MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE MAY
REMOVE A BILL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NUMBER ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY CHIU
WITH AMENDMENTS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY NINE
CRISTINA GARCIA. ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY TWENTY FIVE MR
GIPSON. ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY. MR GRAYSON.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR MR HOLDEN.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN. AB THIRTY
TO FORTY TWO MISS IRWIN WITH
AMENDMENTS. NUMBER NINETEEN AB
TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE MISTER
MAYES. NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FIVE MISS
QUIRK SILVA WITH AMENDMENTS.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX MISS
RAYOS. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR MR
RIVAS. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
MISTER SOUTH WITH AMENDMENTS.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY SIX MISS WALDRON.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO AB
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WOULD. AND
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN WOULD.
THE MODERATOR WILL ONLY RESPOND
WHEN THE CHAIR SPEAKS TO THEM
SO PLEASE PROMPT THEM DIRECTLY
SO THEY CAN CALL Q. Q. UP THE
CAR- THAT'S THAT'S THOSE ARE
NOT FOR TALKING POINTS JUST FOR
ME. I'M SORRY. ALL RIGHT I'LL
PASS ON THAT PAGE. HAPPY BUT
TOO MUCH IN FRONT OF ME HERE
SO. OKAY WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
OUR FIRST BILL. AND BEAR WITH
US AS WE SLOGGED THROUGH THIS-
IT IS- A LITTLE BIT
CHALLENGING- AND A LITTLE BIT
CLUMSY BUT I THINK ONCE WE GET
GOING WILL GET THE HANG OF
EVERYTHING SOUTH. OF FIRST BILL
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FOUR. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR CREATES THE PROJECT ECHO
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH GRANT
PROGRAMS. TO BRIDGE GAPS IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN ANYWHERE
ACCESS IS LIMITED TO CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH SPECIALTY CARE.
PROJECT ECHO IS A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED TELLEMENT THREE
MODEL FOR COLLABORATION AND
EDUCATION THE MOVES KNOWLEDGE
INSTEAD OF PEOPLE. OVER ONE
YEAR OF ONGOING TELL ECHO
CLINICS HOSTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL THIS
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS AND SCHOOL
BASED PROFESSIONALS WITH THE
EXPERTISE THEY NEED TO REACH
OUT RECOGNIZE AND ADDRESS
COMPLEX MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
HAVE ALL LIFETIME CASES OF
MENTAL HEALTH BEGIN BY AGE
FOURTEEN. AND WE HAVE ALL HEARD
OUR CALIFORNIA SURGEON GENERAL
SPEAK ABOUT THE LONG TERM
IMPACTS OF EXPOSURE TO IT
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
KNOWN AS ASUS. IT IS NO SECRET.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM FOR SERVING
CHILDREN STRUGGLING WITH
DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS IS
INSUFFICIENT. MANY PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS SCHOOL BASED
PROFESSIONALS AND EDUCATORS SEE
THESE KIDS REGULARLY BUT LACKS
THE SPECIALIZED KNOWLEDGE TO
RESPOND TO THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN WITH UNDIAGNOSED
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS OR WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCE TOXIC STRESS OR
TRAUMA. THE CURRENT VIRUS
PANDEMIC IS ONLY EXPECTS
EXPECTED TO EXASPERATED THIS
ALREADY CRITICAL SITUATION. AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR
LEVERAGES OUR EXISTING WORK
FORCE TO PREPARE HEALTH AND
SCHOOL PRACTITIONERS TO SUPPORT
THE EMOTIONAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN AS THE
STATE EMERGES FROM THE COLBERT
NINETEEN DISASTER. WITH A
REASONABLE INVESTMENT NOW AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR WELL
LIMóN A BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
EXPENDITURES FOR THE TREATMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH. AND ASUS
LINKED CONDITIONS LATER IN LIFE.
THE SAVE OUR SPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN LIGHT OF ECONOMIC
OF THE ECONOMIC RECESSION WE
ARE FACING. I ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. I HAVE TO WITNESS IS
HERE WITH ME IN SUPPORT. MAYOR
MARTIN FROM THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN THE
REMOTE VIDEO ROOM AND DOCTOR
SIT STEVEN ELSE TIME FROM THE-LIST SUCH LUCILLE PACKARD
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AT STANFORD
AND YOU WILL BE ADDRESSING IS
BY PHONE THANK YOU BEFORE WE
TAKE YOUR WITNESSES I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
ASK OUR SECRETARY TO TAKE. ROOT
AND WE'LL HEAR YOUR WITNESSES
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE WHAT YEAR WOULD HERE
MAYES MAYES HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE BIGELOW
BIGELOW CRESCENT BONTA WANT TO
HEAR BURKE. RADIO THREE OH HERE
FLORA FLORA HERE LIMóN.
HERE RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM- MATT-
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOUR FIRST
WITNESS- MERE MORTON- IN THE
WITNESS- VIDEO ROOM I GUESS IS
WHAT WE'RE CALLING THERE SO
YEAH PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS AMIR MORTON HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL SAYS EACH
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR. OUR
GOAL OF THIS MEASURE IS TO
QUICKLY AND COST EFFECTIVELY.
INCREASE THE CAPACITY OF OUR
SCHOOLS SCHOOL BASED
PROFESSIONALS AND PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS THAT WE KNOW WILL
AFFECT CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS
COMING OUT OF THE COOK AT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE PROJECT
ECHO MODEL IS THE PERFECT WAY
TO MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT OF THE
X. ARE HOSPITAL'S EXPERTISE IN
PEDIATRIC AND ADOLESCENT
SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
AND THIS MODEL WILL ALSO.
MAXIMIZE AND RELY AND LEVERAGE
THEIR EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AND
PRIMARY CARE THAT WORKS ACROSS
THE STATE. THEY ARE READY TO
STAND THESE PROJECTS OF QUICKLY
AND TO DO SO ACROSS COUNTY
LINES WE ARE ALSO WORKING WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION MAKE SURE THAT ANY
PARTICIPANTS IN THESE PROJECTS
GO PROJECTS KNOW WHERE TO
PREFERRED CHILDREN. LESSEN BUT
THEY NEED MORE SERVICES THAT
CAN BE PROVIDED. IN A PRIMARY
CARE OR EDUCATIONAL SETTING-
DRIVE VOTE AND I WILL RESERVE
THE REST OF MY TIME FOR DOCTOR
OUT OF SIGHT THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE NEXT
WITNESS SUBLEASE ON THE PHONE.
MR MODERATOR URBAN MODEL. HAD
EVEN HEARD A BOISE TO. DO WE
HAVE A GENDER FOR MODERN AT
THIS POINT. YES THIS IS RICH
I'M YOUR AUDIO MODERATOR MISTER
MY THANK YOU. PLEASE CONNECT
MIST- DR ALICE ALICE I'M. YOUR
LINE IS CARE YES MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE- COMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING THIS IS DOCTOR
STEVE THAT'LL TIME I'M A
CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF
PSYCHIATRY AT STANFORD RIGHT TO
RACK THIS STANFORD PSYCHIATRY
CENTER FOR YOU MENTAL HEALTH
AND WELL BEING. I'M ALSO
CONDITION OF LISA PACKARD
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. BEFORE
COMING TO STANFORD SIX YEARS
AGO I WOULD TO PSYCHIATRIC
MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE STATE
OF NEW MEXICO. AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTERFOR RURAL
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF NEW MEXICO
HEALTH SCIENCES CENTER. WHILE
THERE I LED THE TEAM THAT RAN
THE FIRST PROJECT ECHO PROGRAM
FOR CHILD PSYCHIATRY IN THE
NATION. FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING
SCHOOLS ACROSS NEW MEXICO AND
PRIMARY CARE CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE. PROJECT ECHO BEGAN AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF NEW MEXICO
WAS THE WAY TO SUPPORT WORLD
PROVIDERS TREATING COMPLEX
PATIENTS WITH HEPATITIS C. AND
IS MOVED TO BECOME AN
INTERNATIONAL PHENOMENON WITH
THE MODEL IMPLEMENTED ACROSS
THE WORLD. AND ACROSS MULTIPLE
DIAGNOSES THE PROJECT AT THE
MODEL THAT SEEN INTERNATIONALLY
AS A COST EFFECTIVE. EVIDENCE
BASED SYSTEM FOR PROVIDING
CRITICAL SUPPORT ACROSS WIDE
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS AND IS NOW
IN USE THE CROP TO BE A MEDICAL
SYSTEM NATIONALLY. MULTIPLE
OTHER U. S. HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
AND NOW ACROSS INDIA AND
AFRICA. THE MODEL IS BASED ON
MULTIPLE SITES CONNECTING
SIMULTANEOUSLY BE A VIDEO FOR
MULTI SITE CAGE CONSULTATION ON
THE FOCUS CLINICAL AND
DIAGNOSTIC SET OF ISSUES. ON A
REGULAR BASIS WITH THE GOAL OF
PROVIDING CONSULTATION FROM A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF
EXPERTS TO BOTH SUPPORT
PROVIDERS IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PATIENT CARE WHILE LSO
BUILDING THE CAPACITY OF THE
SYSTEM PROVIDERS. TO IMPROVE
THEIR SKILLS IN TREATING
PATIENTS WITH THESE POLITICAL
ISSUES. BY PARTICIPATING IN
REGULAR CASE PRESENTE SIMPSON
DISCUSSION. PROVIDERS BUILD
THEIR CONFIDENCE THE CAPACITY
TO TREAT PATIENTS WITH. MORE
COMPLICATIONS. BY PRESENTING
QUE TO THE THEY JUST. TEAM
THESE. ALSO LEARN HOW TO.
HANDLE MORE COMPLEX- OTHER
ISSUES THAT THEY NIGHT LATE
WERE RIGHTS FOR THEM AS WELL.
AND BILL THAT ONGOING CAPACITY.
AS YOU KNOW BEFORE THE CODED
PANDEMIC WE ALREADY HAVE A
STATE CRISIS IN ON RECOGNIZED
IN UNTREATED MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES OF OUR STUDENTS. NOW
WITH KOBE NINETEEN WE HAVE MORE
CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS ISOLATED
AT HOME AT RISK FOR ABUSE AND
GRIEVING THE LOSS OF CONTACT
WITH SCHOOLS AND FRIENDS
GRADUATION AND THERE'S AN
EXPECTATION THAT THE SECOND
WAVE THE PANDEMIC WILL BE THE
MENTAL HEALTH WAY. IN THE FORM
OF INCREASING RATES OF
DEPRESSION ANXIETY DROPPED OUT
TO THE SIDE AND SUBSTANCE USE.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR
WILL RAPIDLY ALLOWED FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
ACCESS EXPERTISE IN TOWN
ADOLESCENT MENTAL HEALTH.
DUTIES MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAMS
AND WILL PROVIDE CONSISTENT AND
URGENTLY NEEDED EXPERTISE TO
SUPPORT SCHOOLS. WILL HELP
PROVIDERS COMMITTEE MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND OTHERS.
TARGETING THIS IS COOL TO ALLOW.
AS THE FOCUS ON THE TOOTH WHERE
CHILDREN ARE WHAT BRINGS.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE FOR
THIS EFFORT THROUGH THE USE OF
THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS WHICH
ALREADY HAVE REGIONAL
COLLABORATION AND COMPLEX
RELATIONSHIPS IN A POSITIVE
WAY. WITH OUR- COUNTY AND OTHER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE THE TIME TO
BUILD THE JET THIRTEEN NOW.
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS CAN
RAPIDLY PUT THESE TEAMS
TOGETHER WITH ITS REGIONAL
PARTNERS AND PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT QUICK TIP REALLY
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY. WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY CREATED
NEW AND CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
STATEWIDE TO ADDRESS THE
PREVIOUS NEEDED IS ONLY BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE KOBE
NINETEEN CRISIS. INTERVENTION
WILL ALLOW US TO BRING
ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT EXPERTISE COURT CARTER
ADOLESCENT ACROSS THE STATE.
WELL IMPROVING THE
SOPHISTICATION AND CAPACITY OF
OUR SCHOOL HEALTH. AND PRIMARY
CARE WORK FORCE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR STATES USE.
THIS PROGRAM SEEMS A WORTHY
INVESTMENT TO MAKE IN THIS
CRITICAL TIME PERIOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- IN
THE WITNSS VIEWING ROOM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE- MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. THE
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN ON THE
PHONE LINES TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
IT ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU A LINE NUMBER AND
FURTHER INSTRUCTIONS. IF YOU'RE
USING A SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE
PICK UP THE HANDSET BEFORE
PRESSING THE NUMBERS. SEVERAL
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME WE WILL
START WITH LINE NUMBER FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY FOUR YEAR ONE IS
OPEN. JUST YOUR NAME IN ORDER.
GOOD MORNING. SORRY HI GOOD
MORNING YOU DON'T HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IMPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOUR NEXT DEADLINE
SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IN ALLENTOWN
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATES THEN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
MEMBERS SIXTY SIX SIX SIX ZERO
ONE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DOCTOR CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA
HEALTH ADVOCATE ADVOCATING FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS LEARN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY NINE SEVEN NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KELLY HERE ON BEHALF OF OTHER
HEALTH REPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY SIX SEVEN SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. IT WILL BE WITH YOU
CAN MEMBERS JEFF KING RAN OF
THE JUDGES PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY
ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MANY OF ONE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
TWO EIGHTY SIX TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI HELLO YES I APPLE WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WITH
AMENDMENTS WERE ALSO MOVING TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE OF THE
UPSET OF THE COMMUNITY I'M A
CONSUMER PERSON WITH A
DISABILITY- WITH A TRIBULATION
THAT UP TO SERVICES ARE
COMPLIANT AND HIT A ACCESSIBLE
WITH ITS ABILITY I AM AS PART.
Q. LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OUR CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THAT HAS
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE IF YOU
STILL WISH TO SEE VOICE SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. OKAY IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO ONE ELSE IN Q. AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE GREAT
THANK YOU SIR AS ARE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. IN OUR
WITNESS ROOM. SEEING NONE IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL ON THE PHONE ON THE PHONE
MISTER MODERATOR. PHONE LINES
IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE'S
NO ONE COMING UP AT THIS TIME
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IS SECULAR CURRY WHICH I
CLOSE YES I SIMPLY ASK YOUR AYE
BURNING BUT I HAVE AGREED TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
SUGGESTED REQUEST BY THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WE DO HAVE A
MOTION I DID FROM MY MISTER
BIGELOW I DID NOT IS THERE A
SECOND. SECOND BY MISTER MAYES-
I LAST MADAM SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS- TO
PREPARATIONS. AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY FOUR DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOOD HI MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW BONTA
BURKE CARILLO. FLORA LIMóN
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN RAMOS.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON.
CORREO I. IT HAS STAND BOAT
BILL PASSES BILLS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
SAT ON THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS AGUILAR COURTESY
CHAPTER. MISTER MAYES MOVES TO
CONSENTED JENDA A SECOND BY
MISTER BIGELOW- IT INCLUDES A
WHOLE BUNCH OF BILLS- WHICH I
MENTIONED EARLIER- ANYBODY
OBJECT TO ANYTHING ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SCENE NO ONE
LAST MISS THE SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WOULD I WOULD
I MAYES MAYES AYE OF YOUR
CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I'D
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA I BURKE. RIO CORREO I
FLORA FLORA I LIVE ON MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO WALDRON. AND THAT HAS
TEN VOTES THAT IS OUT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS THAT ON I
AM GOING TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT OUT SO STAFFS AND
MEMBERS WHO MIGHT BE LISTENING
WHEN WE FINISH THE HEARING ALL
BILLS ON CALL OR OF THE FOR
ADDITIONAL VOTES WE WILL GO
THROUGH THEM ONE TIME AND ONE
TIME ONLY SO IT IS YOUR DUTY TO
BE IN THE CHAMBER MAKE SURE THE
WHO VOTED KNIVES I AM I AM I AM
VERY SERIOUS WE TYPICALLY WILL.
DO THIS MULTIPLE TIMES WILL BE
ONE SHOT AT THE ONE BITE AT THE
APPLE TODAY AND SO I HOPE THAT
WE- COULD CONTINUE TO SEE OUR
MEMBERS ARRIVE AND- PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARINGS WITH THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO
DOCTOR RANDY YOU HAVE. A PLEASE.
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY
EIGHTY THREE EXPANDS ACCESS TO
CARE BY ALLOWING MEDICARE
CERTIFIED AMBULATORY SURGICAL
CENTERS BETTER KNOWN AS A SEIZE
TO PERFORM SELECTIVE
PERCUTANEOUS CORONARY
INTERVENTION PCI PROCEDURES.
SUCH AS ANGIOPLASTY IS
UNSTINTING AND CARDIAC
CATHETERIZATION PROCEDURES.
EXPANDING THE CERTIFIED SPECIAL
CARDIAC PROCEDURES IN A FEES
WILL REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS
OVERALL WITHOUT COMPROMISING
SAFETY. AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY PERFORMING THESE
PROCEDURES IN WELL OVER HALF
THE COUNTRY FOR YEARS. SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND PCI PROCEDURES HAVE
BEEN PERFORMED IN A SEIZE WITH
A COMPLICATION RATE WELL UNDER
1% HOWEVER BECAUSE OF AN
OUTDATED STATUTE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF ONLY ELEVEN STATE THAT
EXPLICITLY LIMIT THE SIZE OF
SERVICE WHERE THESE CARDIOLOGY
PURPLE SERVICES CAN BE
PERFORMED. CALIFORNIA'S
RESTRICTION ON THE SUCH
PROCEDURES IS OUT OF STEP WITH
OTHER STATES AND IS OUT DATED.
THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES RECOGNIZE THE
BENEFITS OF PERFORMING SEVERAL
LOW RISK CARDIAC PROCEDURES
SAFELY AND EFFICIENTLY IN AN
ASP SEVEN. AB THIRTY EIGHTY
THREE WILL AUTHORIZE MEDICARE
CERTIFIED AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO PERFORM ELECTIVE
CARDIOLOGY PROCEDURES. WITHOUT
THIS STATUTORY UPDATE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AND PATIENTS
ENROLLED IN COMMERCIAL HEALTH
INSURANCE ARE NOT ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF INCREASED ACCESS
TO CARE OPTIONS. AND THE
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS
QUALITY OF CARE AND CONVENIENCE
WHICH WOULD OTHERWISE BE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS STRAINED
THE ENTIRE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND HAS EXACERBATED MANY ISSUES
AROUND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THAT WERE ALREADY
PRESENT. AB THIRTY EIGHTY THREE
PROVIDES ANOTHER OPTION FOR LOW
RISK PATIENTS TO RECEIVE CARE.
AB THIRTY EIGHT EIGHTY THREE
PRIORITIZE HEALTHCARE ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY AND PATIENT
SAFETY. THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
GREATER ACCESS TO THESE
SPECIFIED ELECTIVES CARDIAC
PROCEDURES WHILE REDUCING
OVERALL HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
DEMAND ON SERVICES. I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF PROPOSING AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL WHICH WILL FURTHER
ENSURE PATIENT SAFETY BY
REQUIRING THAT AFC'S COMPLY
WITH THIS GUY RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR PATIENT CARE. MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE I AM HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
THE SPONSORS TO PROTECT
PATIENT. AND EXPAND ACCESS TO
HELP. TESTIFYING VIA PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY EIGHTY
THREE. OUR PRICE DOUGHERTY FROM
THE CALIFORNIA AMBULATORY
SURGICAL CENTERS. AND THE
FOREIGN SHELL FROM THE SURGICAL
CARE AFFILIATES. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR- WILL HAVE THE
MODERATOR GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
PHONE LINES THIS FOR THE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ALWAYS
NEXT LINE IN THE MAIN ARE OPEN
MR DOUGHERTY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ARE BREAK DOUGHERTY WITH KATIE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA INVENTORY SURGERY
ASSOCIATION ANSWER THE BABY
THIRTY EIGHTY THREE. AS DR
ARAMBULA MENTIONED THIS BILL
ALLOWS MANDATORY SURGERY CENTER
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS NANCY
THAT IS CERTIFIED BY THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES ALSO KNOWN AS
A MASS. REFORM DIAGNOSTIC
INTERVENTIONAL CARDIOLOGY
PROCEDURES SUCH AS BY
INJECTIONS DETECTOR TYRAEL
BLOCKAGES AND THERAPEUTIC
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS DANGER
PLASTIC AND STANDING UPON
APPROVAL OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IT
CONSISTENT WITH JOINT
GUIDELINES PUBLISHED BY THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY.
THE SOCIETY FOR CARDIOVASCULAR
ANGIOGRAPHY AND INTERVENTIONS.
AND THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION. EACH JOY OUT OF MY
THE DRESS ISSUES A PATIENTS.
STAFFING EQUIPMENT NEEDS AND
VARIOUS OTHER SAFETY CRITERIA.
FURTHERMORE THE THEIR SEATS
WILL BE REQUIRED TO REPORT
QUALITY OUTCOMES THE NATIONAL
CARDIO VASCULAR REGISTRIES AND
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF STATEWIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. THESE PROCEDURES
ARE PREVENTATIVE IN NATURE LOW
RISK LIFESAVING AND ALREADY
BEING DONE IN A IF YOU TO CROSS
THE COUNTRY. RARELY DO WE FIND
OURSELVES BEHIND OCCUR WHEN IT
COMES TO MEDICARE POLICY
OFTENTIMES IN CALIFORNIA ENTER
INNOVATIVE AND FORWARD THINKING
MIND SET THAT PUSHES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TAKE
ACTION. DATA FROM THE NATIONAL
VASCULAR DATA REGISTRY REVEAL
THAT MAJOR COMPLICATIONS AFTER
THESE INTERVENTIONAL CARDIOLOGY
PROCEDURES ARE RARE AND
EXCEEDINGLY SO THE ELECTIVE AND
NON EMERGENT PROCEDURES
AUTHORIZED UNDER AB THIRTY
EIGHTY THREE. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT AS TV
CALIFORNIA ARE REGULATED UNDER
A COMPREHENSIVE SET OF NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS
OVERSEEN BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. STATE LICENSURE
CRITERIA ADMINISTERED BY GED PH
AND THE NATIONAL MEDICARE
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS ALSO
REVIEWED ADMINISTERED AND
ENFORCED BY C. PH. AS THESE ARE
ROUTINELY AND SAFELY PERFORMING
PROCEDURES THAT DON'T REQUIRE
PATIENT TO STAY IN THAT
FACILITY FROM LONGER THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS SUCH AS TOTAL
HIP REPLACEMENT TOTAL JOINT
REPLACEMENT AND SPINE SURGERY.
CALIFORNIA AGENCIES ARE
PROVIDING YOU SERVICES AT A
MUCH LOWER COST TO THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVE IMPATIENCE SITES OF
SERVICE. FOR EXAMPLE UC
BERKELEY RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT EVERY PROCEDURE PERFORMED
AND NANCY SAVE THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM 40% AND SAVE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES 5260% IN THEIR
COPAYMENTS. SPECIFIC
SYMMETRICAL THE PAGE MILLION
ACOSTA. FOR THE PROGRAM AND
FIVE MILLION AND PATIENT CO PAY
COST SAVINGS IT JUST 5% OF
THESE CARDIOLOGY PROCEDURES
SHIFTED THE A FC SETTING. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT NOT EVERYONE
FEELS THE SAME WAY EVER AS
STRONGLY AS WE DO ABOUT AB
THIRTY EIGHTY THREE. WE HAVE
NOT HAD THE BENEFIT OF BEING
ABLE TO WALK YOUR CONCERNS WITH
A OPPOSITION ABOUT THIS
APPROACH THERE ARE MORE THAN
WILLING AND LOOKING FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO- HOPEFUL
WE CAN REACH A RESOLUTION
THAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
CALIFORNIANS. IN NEED OF CARE.
THE COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS HAS
SHUT DOWN ALL LIKE TO
PROCEDURES AND HAS DIVERTED
MUCH OF OUR RESOURCES. ONLY NOW
ARE WE STARTING TO RE OPEN OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM TO
ACCOMMODATE COLLECTIVE NON
EMERGENT AND PREVENTATIVE
SERVICE. WE ARE ALREADY
WITNESSING IMMENSE PENT UP
DEMAND FOR OUR SERVICES AND
EXISTING CARDIAC
CATHETERIZATION LABORATORY.
WILL HAVE EXTREME DIFFICULTY.
IN MEETING THIS DEMAND. EVEN
BEFORE KOBE NINE. CARDIOLOGY
PHYSICIAN A CALL WORK. ABOUT
THE ACT TO CARE FOR THESE LAW.
TREATMENT THE PAST. BERNIE HAS
BECOME A NATIONAL LEADER IN
EXPANDING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
ALMOST ALL RESIDENTS. BUT
ACCESS TO GET TO THAT CARE AND
THE COST OF PROVIDING IT
REMAINS A MONUMENTAL CHALLENGE.
THE COVERT NINETEEN HAS TAUGHT
US ANYTHING. IT'S THAT WE
SHOULD WAIT UNTIL THERE'S A
HEALTHCARE CRISIS TO ENSURE.
THAT OUR CAPACITY TO MEET
PATIENT NEEDS IS SUFFICIENT.
WHAT'S GOING ALL OF US TALK A
LOT ABOUT WANTING AND NEEDING
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE
WHILE ALSO DELIVERING ACOSTA
SAVINGS. WHILE ALSO
CONCURRENTLY MAINTAINING A HIGH
LEVEL QUALITY CARE THAT
PATIENTS SIR. THIS BILL STRIKE
THAT BALANCE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND FOR ALL
THE REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR ARE VOTE AND MAYBE THIRTY
EIGHTY THREE. BUT WE HAVE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
AND I WOULD ASK PLEASE AS
WITNESSES TO STICK TO OUR THREE
MINUTES- I DON'T WANT TO
PENALIZE OF A FURTHER FEATURE
WITNESS BUT WE WILL BE STRICTLY
LIMITING ALL TESTIMONY TO SIX
MINUTES SO IF THE FIRST WITNESS
GOES OVER. THE SECOND WITNESS
SUFFERS SO- I WON'T DO THAT TO
THIS NEXT WITNESS BUT I PLEASE
ASK YOU THIS IS A DIFFICULT
FORMAT IN WHICH TO WORK AND SO
PLEASE. PLEASE TAKE A THREE
MINUTE OTHERWISE I WILL I WILL
INTERRUPT AND WE WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT WITNESS SO. YOUR
SECOND WITNESS AND YOU WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES BUT YOU WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES ONLY SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY HEARING THAT'S
IMPORTANT BILL FOR US TODAY MY
NAME IS ORANGE SHOW- I'VE-
CALIFORNIA WOULD HURRY SO.
SURGERY ASSOCIATION OR CASA
BOARD MEMBER AND I ALSO TO
SERVICE A- GROUP VICE
PRESIDENT. FOR SURGICAL CARE
AFFILIATES. OVERSEEING
CALIFORNIA AND I'LL BE BRIEF
TODAY- WITHOUT THE AID WHERE
NATIONAL AGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMPANY. WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY SURGERY CENTER CITY IN
THE NATION AND FORTY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ALSO HAVE
THESE CARDIO VASCULAR AGENCIES
ACROSS THE NATION IN A PRIOR
JOB. I ALSO OVERSIGHT AND-
CARDIOLOGY CENTERS IN THE
NATION WHERE WE PARTNERED WITH
PHYSICIANS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
AND- BUILDING AND MANAGING THE
SURGERY CENTERS WITH GREAT
OUTCOMES. WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS AB THIRTY EIGHTY THREE WILL
LOWER THE COST OF HEALTH CARE
FOR PATIENTS. WITH GOVERNMENT
PAYERS FOR PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURANCE. WHILE BITING HIGH
QUALITY AND CLINICAL OUTCOMES.
WE WILL ALSO ACHIEVE INCREASED
PATIENT SATISFACTION INCREASED
PHYSICIAN SATISFACTION AND
INCREASED ACCESS FOR ALL
PATIENT GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE
ALIKE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ON BEHALF OF
CASA AND SCA I HUMBLY URGE YOUR
AYE BOTH FOR AT THIRTY EIGHTY
THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE IN OUR WITNESS
ROOM. SEEING AND HEARING NO ONE
WILL ASK OUR MODERATOR TO OPEN
THE DOOR THE CALL LINE FOR
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JUST
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN AS
A REMINDER IT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF IN THE
QUEUE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE. WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY NINE ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TEN MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF CARDIOLOGY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WHAT A LINE
NINETY TWO NINE TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HEALING GRACE OF THE DAM
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THOSE ARE THE ONLY TWO
LINES IN Q. AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVING ON TO
OPPOSITION THERE ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM.
YES OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING CARE MEMBERS NOT
WAS A ON BEHALF OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS OF SCA
YOU CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO EAT THIRTY THREE.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
PRIMARILY IN ITS CURRENTLY IN
ITS CURRENT FORM FOR FOUR
REASONS- FIRST THE RISK TO
PATIENTS DUE TO THE LACK OF-
PATIENT CARE REQUIREMENTS AND
AGENCIES. SECOND THE UNKNOWN
CONSEQUENCES TO THE NEW FEDERAL
SAFETY REGULATIONS THIRD THE
LACK OF EVIDENCE OF ACCESS TO
CARE IF SHE'S BEEN FOR CARDIAC
CATHETERIZATION PROCEDURES
PARTICULARLY IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS AND
FOURTH CONCERNS ABOUT PATIENT
REFERRALS AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
FINANCIAL SELF ME. DEALING
AMONG PHYSICIANS. CARDIAC AFTER
IS THE EVEN DIED WANTS TO CARRY
WITH THEM SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
COMPLICATIONS INCLUDING STROKE
HEART ATTACK UNCONTROLLABLY
LEADING AND KIDNEY FAILURE MANY
OF THESE COMPLICATIONS CAN SHOW
UP AFTER THE PROCEDURE WHILE
THE PATIENT IS STILL RECOVERING
WHEN THE PHYSICIAN IS NO LONGER
ON SITE. PATIENT SAFETY MUST BE
THE PRIMARY CONCERN WHEN
CONSIDERING ALLOWING THESE-
CENTERS TO PERFORM PROCEDURES
THERE TYPICALLY DONE IN
HOSPITALS HOSPITALS HAVE THEIR
PER- PERSONALITY PLACE TO REACT
QUICKLY DURING AN EMERGENCY- IN
CASE THE PATIENT IS IN NEED.
THE CENTERS OF MEDICAID AND
MEDICARE SERVICE APPROVED THESE
PROCEDURES THAT SURGICAL
CENTERS DESPITE SIMILARLY
STRONG AND THAT JACKSON'S FROM
ADVOCATES. ABOUT THE RISKS- TO
PATIENTS DURING THE PROCEDURES
AND DURING THE RECOVERY CMS
NOTED DURING THE- ISSUANCE OF
REGULATIONS THAT MAJORITY OF
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES MAY NOT
BE SUITABLE CANDIDATES TO
RECEIVE THESE PROCEDURES AND A
S. C. SAT. HOWEVER AS CMS
MOVIES REGULATIONS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALSO DRAMATICALLY
LOOSEN SAFETY REQUIREMENTS FOR
ASC INCLUDING LOSING THAT
LOOSENING THE REQUIREMENTS THE
AFC REVIEW THEIR HERDS THE
PREPAREDNESS PLAN EVERY YEAR.
AND ALSO REMOVING THE
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICAL THREE
REQUIREMENTS FOR EACH PATIENT.
THESE ARE JUST THE SORT OF SAFE
GUARDS- TO HELP KEEP PATIENTS
SAFE WHEN COMPLICATIONS ARISE
AND- SOMETHING WE WOULD
STRONGLY CONSIDER AT IMPORTANT
CLUES IN THE BILL- IMPORTANTLY
WE ALSO SHARE THE WALL WE ALSO
SHIP ALL OF IMPROVING ACCESS
CARE. YES AN ANSWER HE- HAVING.
THIS NONSTICK PROCEDURES OUT OF
THE CRISIS IF I TO THESE
PROCEDURES THE SENATE PROBLEM
PLEASE THE DAY THAT SHOW THE
LENGTH OF DELAY WITH ARE HAVING
ACCESSING CARE. LAST WE HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE AND
WORRY ABOUT THE OF FINANCIAL
pSELF YOU. FOR OWN VAST OF
SEASON POWER. AND PHYSICIAN
WHILE THE PHYSICIAN IS REQUIRED
TO DISCLOSE THIS FINANCIAL
RELATIONSHIP TO PATIENTS. WE
WORRY THAT THESE DISCLOSURES
ARE OFTEN NOT ADEQUATE TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENT IS THAT THE
PATIENT IS GIVEN CARE ON A
GREAT SET. IN SUMMARY OUR
CONCERNS ARE BASED ON PATIENT
SAFETY LOCK EVIDENCE OF ACCESS
TO CARE AND LASTLY HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS ARE
GETTING CARE AND THE
APPROPRIATE SETTING. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND IT
STOPS CONCERNS WITH ACCESS TO
CARE AND- THEY'RE OFFERING
WILLINGNESS TO WORK ON THESE
ISSUES TOGETHER. ON PROPER WE
MUST TEENY THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE VOTE NO ON E. THIRTY
EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU AND
WITH ME TODAY IS JOHN ALLEN
FROM SEIU U. S. W. IS HERE TO
HELP WITH ANY TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SO NO FORMAL
TESTIMONY NO FORMAL TEST MONEY
FOR MISS ALLEN JUST JUST
QUESTION. CORRECT OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN
THE WITNESS ROOM. SEEN HEARING
NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION AND WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE YOUR VOICE HEARD PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE ONE IN Q. AT
THE MOMENT LINE NINETY ONE NINE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YOUR JACKSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION-
WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL
AND ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE
STANDS AND OTHER PROCEDURES.
ARE VERY AND IT'S DANGEROUS TO
NAME A POSITION PLEASE. JUST
YOUR NAME AND POSITION PLEASE.
THANK GOVERNOR THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE. NO
FURTHER ON THE PHONE LINE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS I'M I'M THAT NEGLECTED
TO DO THAT BEFORE MY APOLOGIES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE. MR
BONTA. THE THANK YOU DR ROBBIE
THE FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
JUST WANTED TO SEE IF YOU WOULD
BE WILLING TO CONSIDER OF CAN
FORKING WITH OPPOSITION GOING
FORWARD AND MAYBE ALSO
ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF PATIENT
CARE AND SAFETY WHEN IT COMES
TO- CARDIAC CATHETERIZATION IS.
PETER CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION SIMPLY DUE TO THE
TIME LINES IN THE NATURE OF
THIS PANDEMIC IF WE- HAD TO
LIMIT SOME OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND WILL WANT TO
MAKE SURE. BUT I WILL SAY.
THERE ARE. FORTY HER THIRTY
NINE OTHER STATES THAT ARE
ALREADY DOING AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PATIENTS OVER THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS HAVE SHOWN THE
SAFETY OF THIS PROCEDURE. THAT
I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS RAP. AND
WOOD TO SIMPLY COUNT THAT THE
CHAIR AND I HAVE BOTH SEEN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO FOR CERTAIN
PROCEDURES AND SOME OF OUR-
WORLD COMMUNITIES AND DO
STRONGLY BELIEVE THIS BILL
HELPS US TO COUNTER THAT. HOPE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS CAN BE
FRUITFUL PHONE FOR. ANY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. SEE NINE WHICH
I TO CLOSE DOCTOR ARAMBULA I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TONIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL-
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY
MISTER BIGELOW MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTY
EIGHTY THREE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD FIVE. WOOD I MAYES. MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE BURKE. BURKE HI
CARILLO RADIO I FLORA FLORA I
LIMóN NAME ONE I MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS
RAMOS I REALLY DID HE GET.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON AYE. BILL IS OUT
THIRTEEN VOTES THIRTEEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS IF YOU OF THE
COMMITTEE IF YOU YOU YOU. I
WILL GIVE YOU THE OPTION TO
CHOOSE THE ONE IF YOU HAVE A
BILL AND YOU WANT TO PRESENT IT
FROM YOUR DESK YOU MEAN YOU CAN
CERTAINLY CAN DO THAT- OTHER
OTHER IF YOU'RE NOT A MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE TO THAT YOU GOT
TO GO BACK THERE. BUT BUT SO
YOU IF YOU LIKE TO MISTER BONTA
EUROPE NEXT IF YOU LIKE PRISON
FROM THERE YOU CAN'T. GO IN THE
BACK WHATEVER YOUR PLEASURE. MR
BONTA YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT FROM MY
DESK AS WELL AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK IN ASSISTANCE FROM
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF ON THIS
BILL. AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTEEN
WOULD ESTABLISH A THREE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM TO OFFER
MEDICALLY SUPPORTIVE FOOD ALSO
KNOWN AS FOOD AS MEDICINE AS A
MEDICAL COVERED BENEFIT IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES HAVE SPECIFIED
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. BOB THERE'S
REALLY GOOD DATA ON THE
OUTCOMES OF THIS APPROACH ALSO
PROVIDES SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
CARE SAVINGS AND HELP ADDRESS
UNDERLYING HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES WHICH ARE SO
IMPORTANT DURING COVER NINETEEN
OF THE NEW OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL RESPECT THE AFTER I FELT
THANK YOU. I HAVE WITH ME- IN
SUPPORT ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WILL CHAN AND
DOCTOR STEPHEN CHAN FROM ALL IN
ALAMEDA THEY SHOULD BE ON THE
LINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THESE
ARE ON THE PHONE SO REMEMBER
THREE MINUTES- THREE MINUTES
EACH IF YOU GO PAST THAT YOU'RE
TAKEN FROM YOUR TAKEN FROM YOUR
COKE. CO WORKER WITNESS SO
PLEASE GO AHEAD OF MET MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE.
THE MORNING CHAIRMAN WOULD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THIS IS
ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERVISOR WILL
THE CHAN- CHAIR OF OUR REPORTS
HEALTH COMMITTEE. AND SPONSOR
OF EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE EIGHT-
I ALSO SPENT SIX YEARS IN THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING TWO YEARS
AS CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES YOU
FACE- ON THE ONE HAND THAT THE
PANDEMIC ON THE OTHER HAND. A
RECESSION. EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE
EIGHT IS A TOOL TO STRENGTHEN
MEMBERS ARE BLACK BROWN AND
EIGHTY I COMMUNITY. AS WE
CONFRONT HOGAN NINETEEN. THE
BILL AS AMENDED CREATE THE COST
EFFECTIVE CAL BENEFITS THE WILL
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. PARTICULARLY
THOSE FROM THE AREA HEALTH
DISPARITIES UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. AND IT WOULD SAVE LIVES
UNDER THE CURRENT PANDEMIC.
NATALIE MEDICALLY SUPPORTED
FOOD IS AN INTERVENTION KNOWN
TO REDUCE THE REVERSE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS LIKE HYPERTENSION
DIABETES AND HEART DISEASE
INCLUDING GET AND STAGES OF
TREATMENT. AB THREE ONE ONE
EIGHT ADDITIONALLY ALLOWED FOR
EARLY PREVENTION AND EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT OF CHRONIC DISEASES
IN AT RISK POPULATION. TO
AVOID. ILLNESS AND DEATH. THIS
IS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
ACCORDING TO THE CDC NEARLY 90%
OF THOSE POSSIBLE I'D WHO DIED
FROM KOBE NINETEEN HAVE AN
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITION
GRANT SOUTH VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES DIAGNOSED ONE. OF
THE TECHNICIAN LISTED WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FOOD PRESCRIPTION
HEALTHY FOOD BOXES OR HEALTHY
FOOD BELCHER'S FOR NUTRIENT
RICH FRUIT VEGETABLES AND WHOLE
GRAINS TARGETED AT THE ADDITION.
IN PAIRED WITH BEHAVIORAL
SUPPORT THE RESULT OF AN
ABSOLUTE DRAMATIC THE DOCTOR
CAN THE NEXT WHAT DOES NEXT
WITNESS WILL EXPLAIN. THIS IS A
NET THEY'RE NECESSARY FOR
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES. UNDERLYING
CONDITION DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
ESPECIALLY COPE WITH ASIAN. IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WERE EIGHTY
THREE ONE ONE EIGHT BUT
ESTABLISH A THREE YEAR PILOT.
HEALTH DISPARITIES ALREADY
APPARENT HALF OF NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE DIABETES AND
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICAN.
THE ENTIRE PROPORTIONS THE DIET
RELATED FINING. WHEN IT COMES
TO COPE IN NINETEEN LATINO AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE TWICE AS
LIKELY TO BE INSPECTED AND HAVE
HIGHER DEATH RATES WITH OTHER
GROUPS ALAMEDA COUNTY AFRICAN
AMERICANS MAKE UP 10% OF THE
POPULATION BUT 21% OF COCA
TOPIC A SOLICITATION FOR
LATINOS IS 22% OF THE
POPULATION AND 35% PACE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS PROGRAM
GO STATEWIDE AFTER THE PILOT.
IF WE SUBSTANTIALLY ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
WE WILL BUILD AN ALAMEDA COUNTY
AND A CALIFORNIA RESILIENT BUT
HEALTH YOUR RESIDENT. LESS
LIKELY TO BE HOSPITALIZED.
APPLICATION OR DIE FROM CHRONIC
DISEASE OR COPING NINETEEN FOR
THESE REASONS. I REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY THREE ONE
ONE EIGHT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
DOCTOR CHEN. THANK YOU VERY YOU
MY NAME IS STEVEN. AND I AM THE
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF ALL IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WHERE A. B. THE
FOOD IS MEDICINE PROGRAM I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE ONE
ONE EIGHT. FOR TWELVE IT A
LANDMARK STUDY ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED THAT AN UNHEALTHY
DIET. IS THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH IN OUR COUNTRY. THE
PASSING TOBACCO USE HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE AND OBESITY. CAUSING
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DEATHS PER YEAR. INDEED OUR
FOOD IS KILLING TOO MANY OF US.
WITH HOPE IT. WE KNOW THAT THE
VIRUS STRIKES AT PATIENTS WITH
UNDERLYING DIED RESPONSE OF
CHRONIC DISEASES LIE DIABETES.
HYPERTENSION COUPLE THIS WITH
INCREASING FOOD INSECURITY AND
WORSENING DIED AND THEIR
PERFECT STORM. FOR FURTHER
DEATH AND SUFFERING ESPECIALLY
AMONGST COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
ONE WAY TO MEET THE MOMENT IS
TO USE MEDICALLY SUPPORTED
FOODS TO PREVENT AND TREAT. AND
REVERSE CHRONIC DISEASE WHICH
WILL KEEPOUR PATIENTS
HEALTHIER AND OUT OF HOSPITALS.
LET ME ASSURE STORY THE PATIENT
STORIES HIGHLIGHT HOW THIS
WORKS AND ONLY COUNTY IS BASED
ON OUR EXPERIENCE. MR AT. THE
FIFTY SIX YEAR OLD MEXICAN
AMERICAN MAN WITH HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE DIABETES. AND WHO WAS
MORE BUT WE WILL BE. MEETING AT
A WEIGHT THAT ONE HUNDRED POUND
OVER HIS IDEAL BODY WEIGHT.
FORTUNATELY HIS DOCTOR
PRESCRIBED A MEDICALLY SUPPORT
OF FEET. ON SITE TO PHARMACY
WHICH IS A FARM STAND IN THE
MIDDLE THE CLINIC WAITING WITH.
IN WITH A PHARMACY F. A. R. M.
AC WHY BECAUSE THE FOOD IS
SOURCED FROM LOCAL FARMS THE
PROVIDE REGENERATED WE GROWN
FOODS. MEANING PESTICIDE FREE
SEASONAL IF A PATH TO THAT IS
GOOD FOR HUMAN HEALTH AND SOIL
HEALTH. MR ACT ALSO RECEIVE
NUTRITION APRIL KING. AMPLIFY
THE AFFECTED THE MATHEMATICALLY.
SUPPORT OF FOOD. BY THE END OF
HIS TREATMENT DISTRACT INCREASE
FRIEDMAN. INTO FROM THREE TO
FIVE. PER DAY. THIS IS NOTABLE
BECAUSE AN INCREASE IN ONE
SERVING OF DAY OF THIS FOOD
VEGETABLE WITH THE THIRTY
THOUSAND LIVES IN THE U. S. IS
SCALE NATIONALLY. HIS BLOOD
PRESSURE DROPPED SIXTEEN POINT.
FOR REFERENCE AT TEN POINT
ELEVATION IN BLOOD PRESSURE
THIS ISSUE WITH TWICE THE DISK
THE RISK OF DEATH FROM A HEART
ATTACK OR STROKE. IS DIABETES
REVERSED FROM FOR THE CONTROL
TO PRE DIABETIC RANGES HE WENT
FROM A SEDENTARY LIFESTYLE TO
EXERCISING FOUR POINT FIVE
HOURS PER WEEK ANY LOST SIXTY
POUNDS THE STORY OF MISTER X.
HIGHLIGHT HOW MEDICALLY
SUPPORTED FOOD. PLUS
NUTRITIONAL BE ABLE COACHING
CAN BRING ABOUT A WHOLE PERSON
CHANGE IN ADDITION I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT. THAT OUR MODEL GOOD
BEYOND JUST MISTER X. WE'VE
ALREADY BEEN ABLE TO SHOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A 77% REDUCTION IN
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS.
A SIXTEEN POINT REDUCTION IN
BLOOD PRESSURE IN FORTY THREE
PRODUCTION RECRUIT 2043%
REDUCTION IN DEPRESSION SCORES.
IN SUMMARY BY MAKING MEDICALLY
SUPPORTED- THEY COVER BENEFIT
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WE FLAT
NICKEL BAKER. ANY OTHER
SYSTEMIC CURVES OF CHRONIC
DISEASE FOOD INSECURITY
STRUCTURAL RACISM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON. EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
BUY OF THE WAY. IS THERE ANY IN
THE WITNESS VIEWING THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON THIS. SEE NO
ONE MISTER MODERATOR YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION ONLY. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE SPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINES YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN IT'S ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINE ONE
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO BENJAMIN CHAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND TEN ONE ONE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CHAIR MEMBERS TEN
MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY EIGHT TO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KELLY
BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER SIXTY THREE SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK LAURIE
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS THAT YES I'M
CALLING COUNTY I AM A MEDICAL
RECEPTION AND ON BEHALF OF THE
ONES FOR PEOPLE DISABILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA I ASPEN AYE VOTE
THINK THE- THANK YOU. THANK
HAVE ONE LOW COMER THAT IS JUST
QUEUING UP RIGHT NOW PLEASE. IS
A MOMENT TO GO GET THE MIDDLE
LINE UP. COURSE. IT APPEARS
PERHAPS A WHICH ON THEIR-
QUEUING UP SO YOU MAY PROCEED
OKAY THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION. IN THE WITNESS
ROOM. SIR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
IN OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATOR.
JOHN THE PHONE LINE AND WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE ONE IN OKAY THEY
REMEMBER THEMSELVES SOME QUEUE.
NO OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER. DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE MISTER
BONTA WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION MISTER KAREN
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR BONTA THE BILL DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AS
A MOTION BY MISTER MAYES A
SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHTY THREE ONE ONE
EIGHT MOTION IS DUE.
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MAYES. ARE THE ARTERY
AGUIAR-CURRY I'D BIGELOW. BONTA
BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I TO RIO
RIO I FLORA FLORA I LIMóN LIVE
ON I MCCARTY. NAZARIAN NAZARIAN
I RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON.
TEN VOTES BILLS OUT BILLS OUT
WILL WITH THE ROLL OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON- THE C.
WOULD MOVE ON TO A AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION AND- ON THE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB THIRTY EIGHTY
THREE THE AUTHOR DID ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS- SO THAT WAS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SOME MISS
CARILLO HAVE YOUR NEXT A. B.
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX. HELLO
OKAY GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX A
CRITICAL BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
CRITICAL BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AGAINST FOOD
CONTAMINATION FROM READY TO EAT
DELIVERY SERVICES BY
ESTABLISHING PRINCIPLES
SAFEGUARD THE IMPORTANCE OF AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX WHICH
MY OFFICE HAD BEGUN WORKING
BEFORE. THE NINETEEN OUTBREAK
IS HEIGHTENED EVEN MORE IN
LIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC AND THE
NEW REALITIES. WEARING FACE
MASKS SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
SHELTERING IN PLACE. AS WE HAVE
ALL SEEN AT HOME DELIVERIES
HAVE SKYROCKETED AS OUR
RESTAURANTS WERE FORCED TO SHUT
DOWN AND THE PUBLIC WAS ORDERED
TO SHELTER IN PLACE AND MANDATE
WHICH IN MY DISTRICT OF LOS
ANGELES IT'S NOT EXPECTED TO BE
IN EFFECT UNTIL JULY. LUCKILY
FOR DELIVERIES HAVE BEEN HAVE
ENABLED MANY RESTAURANTS TO
REMAIN OPEN FOR BUSINESS DURING
THIS DIFFICULT TIME THERE IS
LITTLE QUESTION THAT COBRA
NINETEEN AND OTHER VIRUSES CAN
BE SPREAD THROUGH FOOD AND THE
HANDLING OF FOOD PACKAGING.
UNFORTUNATELY SANITATION
STANDARDS DO NOT EXIST FOR UP
DELIVERY DRIVERS MANY OF WHOM
HAVE COME ON BOARD DURING A
TIME OF SKYROCKETED-UNEMPLOYMENT AT A TIME LIKE
THIS IT IS THE TREMENDOUS ALL
THAT FOOD DELIVERY SERVICES ARE
CONDUCTED IN A SAFE MANNER. AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE BASIC PROTECTIONS
AGAINST FOOD CONTAMINATION BY
ESTABLISHING PRINCIPLES
SAFEGUARDS INCLUDING BASIC FOOD
HANDLER TRAINING FOR ALL
DRIVERS TO ENSURE BASIC FOOD
SAFETY PROTECTIONS WITH AN
INFLUX OF FOOD WHAT THE NEW
INFLUX OF NEW DELIVERY DRIVERS
AND A LACK OF SAFETY PROTOCOLS
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT.
IDENTIFICATION AVAILABLE FIRST
A PERSON'S RECEIVING
TRANSPORTING AND DELIVERING THE
FOOD IN ORDER TO ALLOW HEALTH
OFFICIALS TO TRACE BACK ANY
COMPLAINTS OR VIOLATIONS.
SAMPER EVIDENT CLOSER A FOOD
CONTAINER OF THAT WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE TAPE LABELS OR STAPLES.
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY AND COST
RECOVERY FOR LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. WELL I RECOGNIZE THIS
BILL MAY NOT GUARANTEE 1100%
SAFETY COMPLIANCE WITH THE
PROPOSED MINIMUM STATE STANDARD
AND AB THIRTY THREE THREE
THIRTY SIX WILL CERTAINLY
ENHANCE FOOD SAFETY ACROSS THE
STATE WHICH IS PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL AT THIS TIME. I
RECOGNIZE THE MANY FOOD
DELIVERY APPS HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN THE STEPS TO ENSURE
PUBLIC HEALTH AS A RESPONSE TO
PULL THE NINETEEN. FOR EXAMPLE
WILL BREED HAS SHARE TIPS WITH
RESTAURANT OWNERS AND DELIVERY
DRIVERS ON SOCIAL DISTANCING
NORMS WELL THEY WORK TO PROVIDE
SANITATION PRODUCTS TO ITS
DRIVER'S. DOOR DASH HAS ALSO
IMPLEMENTED HAS ALSO PROVIDED
MILLIONS OF FACEMASK TO THEIR
DRIVERS AND HAS DISTRIBUTED HAD
BEEN A TIES AND GLOVES WE'LL
MAKE A COPY SELECT IT'S THE
FAULT. OUR INTENT IS TO BILL ON
THE- NOT BY FOR THEM. AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX SIX TO ENSURE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. NOT
TO CLOSE DOWN OR MAKE IT
BUSINESS ON REASONABLY HARD FOR
THESE PLATFORMS OR OTHER READY
TO EAT DELIVERY. DELIVERY READY
TO EAT FOOD. WE SIMPLY NEED
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE STATE.
AND A TIME OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY DETRIMENT.
THOUGH THE OPPOSITION LETTERS
DOES NOT KNOW OF THIS EFFORT MY
OFFICE AND OUR SPONSORS HAVE
ENGAGED IN ONGOING OPPOSITION
AN ONGOING CONVERSATION WITH
THE OPPOSITION. SEEKING TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK. ON
WORKABLE PROVISIONS TO ENSURE
THAT DRIVERS HAVE THE MOST
BASIC KNOWLEDGE OF FOOD SAFETY.
PROVIDING TESTABLE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OUR MATSON REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND JUSTIN ALONG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO ON THE PHONE.
MR MODERATING MAY OPEN THOSE
LINES ARE LONGER. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR. YES MORNING MOST
CHARACTER HELLO I'M HERE WITH
THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND THANK
YOU AND YOUR STOCK VERY MUCH
WE'RE WORKING WITH THAT. I
BELIEVE THE AUTHOR HAS PROVIDE
UP TO SENDING OVER THE YEARS
THAT THEY'LL BE COMPLETELY
CONQUERED THAT THIS IS INTENDED
TO BUILD ON NUMBER READY GOOD
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BUT
THERE IS AN IMPERATIVE TO HAVE
A MINIMUM STATEWIDE GADGETS AND
EIGHT EACH STRANGELY ACT YOU
HAVE. A CAPACITY TO BE TRACED
BACK TO PROBLEMS OCCUR- THE
FULL CO THE THIS WAS AN ISSUE
85% OF THE POLLED PUBLIC WANTED
TO SEE CAMPAIGN EVIDENCE BAG
AND UP 228% OF DRIVERS ADMITTED
CALVING SPECTRUM THE FOOD AND
THE DRINKS THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY DELIVERING IT HAVE
BEEN THE END REMAINS OF FOOD
SAFETY ISSUE COVERT MAKES IT
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT. I WANT TO
CUT TO THE CHASE HERE BECAUSE
AS THE AUTHOR SO ACCURATELY
STATED WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH MOST OF THE
ACT THANK ACT BASED GROUPS A
PLATFORM THAT THEY CALLED
INCLUDING IS TO CART. AND WE
HAVE HOPE COULD WITH THEM THAT
WE HAVE TO ISSUES. TO ADDRESS.
I ALL AT THE ALTAR HAS ALSO
ALLUDED. AN ASP. WE COMMIT
FORTY TO WORKING ON THE THREE
HOUR STAND ISSUES AND I AM VERY
KHôNG TO THAT WE CAN IT THEM.
TO THE SET. OF THOSE THAT THE
WORKS WITH. VERY SIMPLY WE CAN
FIND A WAY OF PROVIDE THAT IN.
THAT'S CURRENTLY AVAILABLE IN
THE WHO'D HAVE A **** WITH
ACTUALLY AT. REQUIRING THE CARD
ITSELF. WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS FOR
COMMERCIAL DELIVERY VEHICLES.
ARE NOT APPLICABLE TO PASSAGE
OF VEHICLES BUT WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO INSIST. THAT THE
VEHICLES ARE. LEADING UP TO THE
BILL AND FINALLY THIS IS A
INTENDED TO GROW STORES THEY
JUST AND ELSE. WE WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE AN AMENDMENT WE MOVE
FORWARD TO CLARIFY THAT THE
MINIMALIST DELIVERY OF READY TO
EAT FOODS ALONG WITH GROCERY IS
NOT INTENDED TO BE COVERED WITH
THIS BILL. BUT THERE'S AN
URGENCY BECAUSE IT IS AFTER THE
FIGHT THE NEED FOR THIS WEEK
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THIS WE
CAN LOOK TO WORK WITH ANYONE
WITH CONCERNS AND WE THANK
YOU'LL STOP VERY MUCH. HE FALL
IN THAT THEY HAVE THE SAID THE
TO PRINT THE PATH HEALTH DURING
THIS THIS TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. ON THE PHONE MORNING
AIR MATT MATT THAT THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU- YES WE
ARE SUPPORT OF THE BILL OF VERY
FEW INDUSTRIES- IS REGULATING
THAT THE RESTAURANT COMMUNITY-
AND IN LARGE PART PORTION OF
THAT. GOVERNING LAW THAT'S ON
THE BOOKS TO DAME THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH. SO NOBODY'S BETTER
TRAINED IN CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT FOOD SERVICE TEAM
MEMBERS WHEN IT COMES TO DAY
FOOD HANDLING PREPARATION AND
SERVICE TO THE CONSUMING
PUBLIC. THE FOOD A PLANE IS
NUMBER ONE CONCERN OF ANY
RESTAURANT OPERATOR AND AT THAT
TO SAFETY AND THE TRAINING AND
PROTOCOLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
PLACE. TO GIVE RESTAURANTS AND
GET THE CONFIDENCE TO RETURN
ONCE RESTAURANT. WITHOUT THAT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH COULD BE
COMPROMISED AND ONE WOULD
LIKELY DAMAGE THE RESTAURANT
REPUTATION WHICH OF COURSE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS THE CUSTOMER
BASE AND THE EMPLOYEE. SO FOR
FOOD SAFETY IT'S A NO BRAINER
FOR US THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT AND AS MISTER MALONE
DATED. AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CARILLO THIS DISCUSSION TOOK
PLACE LONG BEFORE CO COULD
NINETEEN AND WILL CONTINUE
AFTER CODE NINETEEN. ANY OF YOU
MEMBERS CAN. BEING LARGE.
WHETHER THEIR SUPPLIERS ARE
PURVEY THAT THE OF A RESTAURANT
LOADING FOOD AND- AND TO BUY
INTO THE RESTAURANT.
RESTAURANTS ARE REGULATED FROM
THE TIME THAT FOOD ENTERS THE
BACKDOOR. THOSE THROUGH THE
RESTAURANT TERMS OF FOOD
PREPARATION IN TERMS OF COOKING
AND EVERY STEP OF THE WAY IN
THE KITCHEN AND THE DINING
ROOM. AND OUT THE DOOR FOR TAKE
OUT ORDERS FOR GAP. BUT IT IS
NOT TRUE FOR THE DELIVERY
ASPECT THAT TAKES PLACE ONCE A
FOOD ORDER LEAVES THE FRONT
DOOR OF A RESTAURANT. THE LAST
FEW MILES BEFORE CONSUMER GET
THEIR FOOD ISN'T SUBJECT TO THE
SAME HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS THAT YOU HAVE WITHIN
THE RESTAURANT FOR FOOD
HANDLERS. NOT THE VEHICLE THE
FOODS BEING TRANSPORTED IN OR
THE INDIVIDUAL TRANSPORTING THE
FRUIT. SO THIS REALLY LOOK TO
GETTING SOME BASIC FOOD SAFETY
KNOWLEDGE IN THAT AND- IN FACT
MUCH OF THE TRAINING IN THE
FOOD SERVICE. THAT REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN LAW ARE
GOOD PRODUCT OF THIS HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND YOUR GOOD WORK
MISTER CHAIR THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND JUST
LAST YEAR- ANOTHER BILL BY THE
MOON. THE BACK OF BAUER-KAHAN
LOOKS TO EXTEND SOME OF THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS DECEMBER
K. SO AGAIN THE BILL SIMPLY
EXTENT THAT COULD WORK A PLANE
JUST TO THE DELIVERY OF PORTION
OF FOOD SERVICE THAT INCLUDES
OUR OWN FOOD DELIVERY WITHIN
RESTAURANTS AS WELL A THIRD
PARTIES- AND SO. THE TRAINING
THINK POSTED IT PORTABLE
BELONGED TO THE EMPLOYEE IT'S
AFFORDABLE AND IT'S WIDELY
ACCESSIBLE ON THE INTERNET- THE
RESTAURANT CAN DO ALL THEY CAN
IN THE RESTAURANT TO MANAGE
FOOD SAFETY- AND THEN YOU KNOW
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
CONTINUES BECAUSE IT'S FRANKLY
ALARMING THAT THERE'S NO
REGULATION. ONE LEAVES THE
CUSTODY OF THE RESTAURANT AND
THEN END UP IN THE HANDS OF A
GET. THE DISCUSSION STARTED
LAST FALL IN LA COUNTY WITH
SUPERVISORS LOOKING INTO DOING
A LOCAL WORKING ON THIS EXACT
SAME IDEA- MISTER. MALONE IN
THE NUMBER OF THE- PROFESSIONAL
UP THE PART REP. AND OTHERS.
COME AND- DECISION WAS LARGELY
FROM THE HELP PUBLIC- OFFICIALS
THAT DOING THIS ON A REGION BY
REGION BASIS DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND THEREFORE IT SHOULD
BE LIMITED TO GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARIES AND WE SHOULD LOOK
FEELING AT THE STATE LEVEL SO
THAT THOSE LAST FEW UNREGULATED
MILES. I HAVE SOME BASIC LEVEL
TO HELP THE STATE TO STANDARDS
APPLY TO THEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- OTHER ANY WITH
ANY OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM. SCENE
NINE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT MISTER
MODERATOR ME OPEN THE LINES ARE
JUST YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
PLEASE. IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT ON
THE AUDIO HOTLINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO MAKE YOUR
VOICE HEARD BOOK ONLINE NUMBER
NINETY FOUR THAT NINE FOUR. GO
AHEAD YOU'RE LIKE IT'S OPEN.
YOUNGER LEGAL IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE
WITH A AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AB ORDER LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE TWO ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NO MORE ON THE AUDIO PHONE
LINES VERY GOOD THANK YOU-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE
HAVE TO ON THE PHONE. THE OPN
THOSE WILL OPEN THOSE LINES
WHEN WHENEVER. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CORPS IN
JENSEN ATTACK THAT DAY IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY THREE
THIRTY THREE SEC THINKING AND
CUSTOMER TRACK WITH A TOP
PRIORITY FOR TECH THAT MEMBER
COMPANIES AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORED RECOGNITION OF EFFORT
COMPANIES HAVE ALREADY TAKEN.
RIGHT BATES EIGHTEEN MEASURES.
FOR THE THROUGH DATE REX THE
JOHN PUBLIC WHEN THE WITH THAT
TYPE DELIVERY. AND COMPANIES
ALL EMPLOY IDEA MY DURING THE
OVERNIGHT THE INFECTED CON WITH
DELIVERY AND PROVIDE GUY IN THE
DRIVERS IF THEY- TO STATE THEY
AND DURING PACKED AND ANYTIME.
IMPACTED BY THAT THEY'LL HAVE
ALSO BEEN BEING JUST PROVIDING
AN ESSENTIAL. DURING THE-
BECAUSE THEY HAVE HELPED ENSURE
CAL HAVE ACCESS TO GROCERIES
AND YELLED FROM LOCAL
RESTAURANTS. ALTHOUGH WE HAD A
GOOD INITIAL CONVERSATION WITH
ONE OF THE BILL AND DO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH THAT. WAGE I DO WANT
SHARE WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
BILL AND RAN AND BELIEVE THAT
IT WOULD ELIMINATE THE USE OF
PERSONAL VEHICLE FOR BILL
DELIVERY. ENERGY NEW BARRIERS
THAT FOR THE TYPE OF WORK AND-
TO DELIVER COMPANY AND DRY. TO
MEANT FOR MANY. AND RETAILERS
AB THREE THREE THREE SIX ONE
APPLY TO- DELIVERY COMPANIES
AND DRIVERS- WHO DELIVER READY
TO EAT FOOD ANY GOOD FACILITY
IN CALIFORNIA AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN. I APPRECIATE THE-
COMMENTS. ARE OUT I. GROCERY
FROM THE BELL AND YEAH
CURRENTLY IN THE BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD IMPACT.
RADIATE THROUGH DELAY FROM
GROCERY STORES. WHICH WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE I DO
KNOW WHEN YOU A GREAT ABOUT
WHEN CONSUMER. ORDERS EIGHT
DELIVERY FROM STORE THERE ARE
WE IN ORDER A MAKE BACK THE
CONTENT READY AT REPACKAGE THE
AND NOT THE VERY. AND THE
CONTACT BUT THIS WOULD ALSO AND-
READY TO EAT WE WERE DOING FROM
ANY OTHER FOOD FACILITY IN HOW
THE BILL WOULD. DELIVERY DRIVER
TO BE INCLUDING AND CAR WHICH
WE BELIEVE BE A BARRIER TO
ENTRY FOR CALIFORNIANS
LEARNING. A LOOKING TO EARN
EXTRA MONEY THE PROCESS OF
GETTING A FOOD HANDLER CARD IS
ABOUT A TWO HOUR PROCESS. AND
REQUIRED PACKING A FORTY
QUESTION TEST FOCUS ON HOW WE
SHOULD BE PREPARED AND SERVED
IN A RESTAURANT. OR THE KITCHEN
DELI AND THE GROCERY STORE THE
INTENT OF THE FOOD HANDLER CAR
HAS ALWAYS BEEN FOR WORKERS AT
RESTAURANTS. AND OTHER
ESTABLISHMENTS WHERE FOOD
ACTUALLY. BEING WHICH IS NOT
THE CASE FOR DRIVERS TO ARE
ACTING HALF AND THE YEAH. AND
SIMPLY BECAUSE AND- FOOD TO
DELAY OPPORTUNITIES ARE LOW TEN
OPS TURN MONEY ESPECIALLY
DURING TIME AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE DEATH HER TO. HAD THE BILL
DRIVER COULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
ROADBLOCK FOR MANY IN. LOOK
BECAUSE AND WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERN ABOUT THE PER. AND BELL
AND ACROSS RECKLESS REALLY TO
CATCH. HIM AND BUT I BELIEVE
MISTER POWER WITH THE AT THE
REGIONAL BE COVERING THOSE.
DAHLE AND THERE AND THINK YOU
MISTER FOR THE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ONE OF THE BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PRINT WILL FADE
GARDEN- THAT WE ARE THE IMPACT
OF THE CELL- WOULD BE YEAH I'M
NOT. MAKING IT ROADBLOCK TO
THIS TYPE OF DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU NAY
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ROBERT
CALLAGHAN WITH THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION ALSO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AB THREE THREE THREE
SIX OF BLACK TECH OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MISSTEPS AND
ADD A FEW ADDITIONAL PROVIDE US.
CAN CONCERN ABOUT FIRST AB
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX WOULD
ELIMINATE THE USE OF PERSONAL
VEHICLES FOR FOOD DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS BECAUSE THE
DON'T PRINT WHICH SUBJECT THIRD
PARTY FOOD DELIVERY TO A
REQUIREMENT TO KEEP HOLDING
AREA OF THE VEHICLE BE
CONSTRUCTED IN A SMOOTH THE
WASHABLE IMPERVIOUS MATERIAL
CAPABLE OF WITHSTANDING
FREQUENT CLEANING- TO COMPLY
DELIVERY DRIVERS WOULD LIKELY
NEED COMMERCIAL BANDS OR
TRAILERS NOT THEIR PERSONAL
VEHICLES. AT THIS WHAT IT
REASONABLY ELIMINATE THE DRIVER
USER PERSONAL VEHICLE- WE
BELIEVE THIS WOULD COMPLETELY
DISRUPT THIRD PARTY TO
DELIVERY- AT A TIME FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE RELY ON IT
MORE THAN EVER AB AND WOULD
ALSO ELIMINATE WHAT SPORTING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO RELY ON THESE
PLATFORMS TO PAY BILLS PROVIDE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. THE OTHER
PROVISION I WANTED TO FLAG WAS
THERE ARE THE BILL REQUIRES YOU
TO BE MAKING A SPECIFIC
TEMPERATURE TECH FROM TAMPA.
CURRENT THE SECOND SEPHORA WERE
FOR MANY BACK A BRA OF FOOD AND
WHEN TRANSIT FOODS AND DISK SO
AND READ OKAY DELIVERY DO
ENGAGE IN ANY TO PROD AND IT'S
REAL TO ASK DELIVERY DRIVERS TO
COMPLY THE REGULAR THAT MAP BUT
IT'S NOT FOR ME TO ACTUALLY
REACH. IT SEEMS THE BILL
MISAPPLIED TO REQUIREMENTS TO
PROCESS WHICH BASICALLY MAKES
IT CAN START CUSTOMER TAKING
GROCERIES OR PREFERRED PREPARED
FOOD HOME AND SO THEY'RE NOT
ONLY THAT BUT NECESSARY- BUT
WORKABLE AS WELL SO FOR THESE
REASONS ARE WORKERS SB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX- BUT- WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK. AFTER THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY OTHER ENOUGH.
THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM. SEE
NO ONE MISTER MODERATE YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF JUST THEIR NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE. YES IF
YOU'RE ON THE AUDIO PHONE LINES
IN WHICH TO VOICE OPPOSITION IN
A PRESS ONE MAN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE ON THE AUDIO PHONE
LINES AT THIS TIME. I TAKE THAT
BACK BECAUSE OF ONE THAT JUST
CUED UP. ONE MOMENT PLEASE OKAY.
DAVID AF WITHDRAWN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK SO YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. SCENE
NINE WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE MISS
KOREA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE-
THE COMMENTS BOTH IN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WANTED TO CLARIFY A
FEW THINGS. THE FOR DELIVERY
DRIVERS USING THE APPS WILL
STILL BE ABLE TO USE THEIR
VEHICLES WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE IS THAT. IF YOU ARE
HANDLING ANY TYPE OF READY TO
EAT FOOD THAT YOUR VEHICLE IS
SIMPLY CLEAN. SO IF YOU HAVE A
PART TIME JOB SOMEWHERE ELSE
MAYBE YOU ARE A MECHANIC AND
MAYBE YOU HAVE YOUR TOOLS IN
YOUR CAR. THEN THE SUGGESTION
IS. YOU SHOULDN'T PUT FOOD
THAT'S READY TO EAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE DELIVERED TO
WELCOME A CALIFORNIA CONSUMER.
NEXT TO YOUR DIRTY TOOLS THESE
ARE BASIC HEALTH STANDARDS THAT
RESTAURANTS HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER. THE WEEK WE HOLD SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SMALL
RESTAURANTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AT COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
STANDARDS. THAN WE DO THE
PEOPLE TO DELIVER THE FOOD THAT
WE ARE ALL CONSUMING. I USE THE
APPS I'VE USED THEM IN THE PAST
I ALSO GO DOWN TO THE
RESTAURANTS AND DURING FULL OF
IT HAVE BEEN SUPPORTED SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS MY DISTRICT.
THAT ARE DOING DELIVERY
SERVICES AT CURBSIDE. ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A STANDARD. STATEWIDE FOR
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. IN
ADDITIONAL BE. FOOD SAFETY
HANDLER TEST THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS SAYING IS
BURDENSOME IT'S EIGHT DOLLARS
AND IS AVAILABLE IN A VARIETY
OF DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND IT
TAKES TWO HOURS TO COMPLETE.
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND I
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO CREATE
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE FEASIBLE
THAT CREATES AN UNDERSTANDING
FOR DRIVERS THAT DELIVER READY
TO EAT FOOD TO UNDERSTAND
BASIC. FOOD SAFETY. IN THE
VEHICLES AS THEY DELIVER FOOD
TO FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE.
DURING A GLOBAL PANDEMIC WE
WERE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION.
THE FOR COAL IT. WAS EVEN AT
THE LEVEL THAT WE'RE SEEING
TODAY. IN FACT. FOOD DELIVERY
SERVICES ARE ONLY GOING TO
INCREASE BY 4% FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS NPR SURVEYED SAID
THAT 28% OF DRIVERS. ADMITTED
THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN A BITE OUT
OF THE FOOD OF THE FOODS THAT
THEY DELIVER. TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS IF YOU'VE ORDERED A
BURGER AND SOME FRIES AND HALF
YOUR FRIES ARE GONE. IT'S
PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
CONSUMED BY THE PERSON
DELIVERING IT WOULDN'T IT BE
GREAT IF YOU'RE BAD ACTUALLY
WITH THE OLD. AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BUY YOUR FOOD BEING
CONTAMINATED THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. IN
ADDITION THE SAME SERVICE SAID
THAT 85% OF CUSTOMERS OF
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS WOULD LIKE
TO SEE. THEIR FOOD BE CLOSED
EITHER BY TAPE BY STAPLES OR
WHATEVER IS NECESSARY. SO THIS
IS A BILL THAT ENSURES PUBLIC
SAFETY PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE SET
A STANDARD. PROCESS CALIFORNIA.
NOW NEED MORE. AND IS THE OF
GOVERNMENT TRY TO CATCH UP
YEARS FROM NOW. WHY DON'T WE DO
IT NOW IN TANDEM WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IBOOK THANK. THANK
YOU MISS CARILLO- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. AND SECOND. OKAY MOTION
BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ A SECOND BY
MISS- MISS THE MON THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS I
WILL NOTE THAT WE DID HEAR THAT
THE PROPONENTS WERE WILLING TO
ACCEPT AN AMENDMENT BUT THAT
ISN'T IN OUR COMMITTEE SO WE
JUST ASK THAT THE OFFER
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION IN THAT REGARD- WITH
THAT THE MOTION IS PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MAYES. MAYES NO AGUILAR CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA I BURKE.
CORREO CARILLO I FLORA. FLORA
NO. LEMOND LIMóN I MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RAMOS. RAMOS NOT
VOTING RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON NOW.
VOTE IS FIVE FOR BILL IS ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL MOVE ON THEN TO THE NEXT
BILL MR CHOW. AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY WITH BRING
HEALTH INFORMATION COLLECTED BY
FDA APPROVED APPS USE AT THE
DIRECTION OF A POSITION TO BE
UNDER THE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAL PRIVACY
LAW. THE FDA HAS RECENTLY
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS BY
WHICH SHOWED DIGITAL HEALTH
PRODUCTS OR APPROVED. GIVING
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS NEW WAYS
TO GET USEFUL INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR PATIENTS. FOR EXAMPLE
SEVERAL FORMS OF DIGITAL PILLS
ALL ALREADY IN USE. THESE PILLS
COMBINED INJECTABLE MICROCHIP
SENSORS WITH PHARMACEUTICALS
AND COMMUNICATE WITH THE PATCH
THAT COLLECTS INFORMATION AND
SINCE IT. TO AN OUT SIMILAR TO
A FIFTY. THIS PRODUCT CAN
RECORD THE TIME IN QUANTITY THE
DRUG IS TAKEN THE PHYSICAL
STATE OF THE PERSON HIS BODY
TEMPERATURE ACTIVITY LEVEL AND
HEART RATE. BUT FOR DATA TO BE
CONSIDERED MEDICAL INFORMATION
ON THE CURRENT LAW HE NEEDS TO
BE GENERATED BY A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER. IN THIS CASE SINCE
THE INFORMATION IS GENERATED BY
DIGITAL HEALTHSOUTH SUCH AS THE
DIGITAL SKILLS WERE IT IS
COLLECTED OUTSIDE OF A MEDICAL
FACILITY AND ALSO AT THE
PATIENT LEVEL. IT WILL NOT BE
CAPTURE UNDER THE EXISTING
DEFINITION. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TROUBLING GIVEN
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
SPREAD. HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS ARE LOOKING TO
EXPLORE WAYS TO ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS INCLUDING GREATER USE OF
DIGITAL HEALTH PRODUCTS TO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
PATIENTS. RAISING SIGNIFICANT
PATIENT PRIVACY CONCERNS.
ALREADY THE INVASIVE USE OF
IDENTIFIABLE GEO LOCATION
INFORMATION BY THE GOVERNMENT
HAS BEEN CONSIDERED SUGGESTING
THAT. APPROPRIATE GUARD RAILS
THE NECESSARY TO PROTECT
PRIVATELY COLLECTED INFORMATION
WITH AN EXPECTATION OF PRIVACY
TO PROTECT AGAINST OVER REACH.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF PAPER PROVISIONS
BEING SUSPENDED TO OF PERMITS
SHARING OF HEALTH INFORMATION.
FOLLOWING THIS CRISIS THERE IS
ALSO LIKELY TO BE SIGNIFICANT
DEMAND FOR DIGITAL HEALTH
SYSTEM INFORMATION FOR
RETROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS AND
RESEARCH. FOR EXAMPLE A HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANY COULD USE
DIGITAL HEALTH INFORMATION
PURCHASE FROM ADDITIONAL HEALTH
FEEDBACK SYSTEM OPERATOR TO
INFER INDIVIDUALS WHO
CONTRACTED COVERT NINETEEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
SEPARATES FOR PREMIUMS BASED ON
THIS INFORMATION. AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY WILL BRING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND THE
INFORMATION THEY COLLECT UNDER
C. M. I. A. I PREVENT PROVIDING
THAT ANY BUSINESS THAT OFFERS
SUCH AN OUT. OR DEVICE TO A
CONSUMER SHALL BE DEEMED A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT SENSITIVE HEALTH
DATA GENERATED BY THESE DIGITAL
TALES IS TREATED WITH THE SAME
CARE AS DATA THAT IS GENERATED
IN THE TRADITIONAL MEDICAL
SETTING. AND THAT INFORMATION
WON'T BE SURE WITHOUT PATIENTS
WRITTEN CONSENT. WONDERFUL
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IS REBEKAH OPENS
UP GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK WE
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU MUCH MISTER
CHARLIE HAVE WITNESS AND. HELLO
MY NAME IS WORK ACT AND SALAS
AND I REPRESENT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL SOCIAL WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE DEGREE FROM AN
ACCREDITED SOCIAL WORK PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
AND WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR INTRODUCING THEMSELVES
WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT PERSONAL
HEALTH INFORMATION. WHAT WILL
HAPPEN. AND COLLECTED SPECIFIED
PRODUCT IS SUBJECT TO THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION ACT. BEAR BY
INSURING PATIENT PRIVACY
PROTECTION WHILE STILL ALLOWING
FOR THE SHARING OF HEALTH
INFORMATION FOR THE DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT OF PATIENTS. MANY
OF OUR LIKE A CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS REPENTED OF MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS. PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY IS THE
POTENTIAL FOR OPEN AND HONEST
COMMUNICATION AND CLIENT NOT BE
CONFIDENT THAT THEIR
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED.
ACTING PERSONAL AND- IS NOT THE-
AS THING FOR WITH YOU ME AND
PRIDE EACH IN. THIS INFORMATION
INCLUDES INTIMATE DETAILS.
BEHAVIOR PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP
AND FINANCIAL INFORMATION THAT
WE MAY NAY WE MAY NOT WANT TO
SHARE WITH OTHERS WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS PRIVATE IN ORDER
TO PREVENT POTENTIAL HARM. MATT
AND DISCRIMINATION FOR THESE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR I FELT ON
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE FOR
TESTIMONY HAVE ONE I JUST HAD
THE ONE WITNESS LISTED IS THAT
CORRECT MR CHOW OKAY. THAN
ANYONE ELSE- IN WITH ANYBODY IN
THE QUEUE- ON THE PHONE MISTER
MODERATOR. IT'S ONE NINE ZERO
TO PUT YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE.
WE HAVE ONE THAT IS JUST YOU TO
PLEASE WHILE MOMENT. AND THAT
THAT WILL BE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION ONLY. OKAY WE HAVE
THAT ONE IT'S LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO ONE THREE TWO
YEAR OPEN. MORNING HONEY OF
CONSUMER REPORT SUPPORT AS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. ANYONE THAT
IS THE ONLY ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME OKAY IS THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION- TO TESTIFY IN
THE- VIEWING ROOM. IF NOT IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE YOU MAY OPEN THE
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU WHICH ONE AND ZERO
FOR THE PHONE LINES WE DO OF
ONE IT'S FROM LINE NINETY TWO
THAT'S NINE TWO. OKAY ONE
MOMENT. NINETY TWO YEAR NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SORRY
ABOUT THAT THAT GOOD MORNING
FEEL THE GRAVES OF THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION-
PRESHEAF APPRECIATE THE-
AUTHORS- CONCERNS HERE AND
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES- RIGHT NOW WITH LEADERS
ADEQUATE FEDERAL REGULATIONS
SPACE- SERVICE TO ROUTE THE
ENTIRE DIGITAL HELD SPACE.
BAFTAS ACTUALLY RECENTLY
LAUNCHED A DIGITAL HELL
INNOVATION ACTION PLAN TO
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF THAT BE A
REGULATIONS OF THE SPACE
INCLUDING FOR PRIVACY AND
SECURITY- SO WERE WERE HELPFUL
TO SEE THAT NO FOUR AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL THEY'RE VERY
SERIOUS TAKING YOUR CHECK. ON A
DRESS IN THE OPERA THE PLATE.
BUT ALL THAT SAID WE'VE BEEN A
VERY FOR TO AWESOME BECAUSE-
WITH THE OP STOP AT THE NEON
LAST TWO YEARS BILL BUT A
FREAKING PINE ENGINE BEEN.
OCCURRED WITH. AND WITH ALL
THAT THIS RISK. OPPOSE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE MR
MODERATE LEFT. YEAH YES ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANY HERE WITH
CALIFORNIA LIFELINE TO
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ADELINE EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SB EIGHT YOU MAY FEEL
FREE TO SPEAK YOU MAYBE HAVE
SELF MUTED. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHAEL MANN I AM A MENTAL
HEALTH CONSUMER. THIS IS
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT I THINK THE
AFTER STRENGTHENING THE
PROJECTION OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND GOING BEYOND
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT US
THANK A CALIFORNIA FOR
PROTECTING ELECTION. THANK YOU.
SO I WE HAVE ONE MORE THAT IS
JUST CUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
OKAY. Q. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR ONE THREE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CHECK YOUR LINE
FOR ME WE'RE HEARING AUDIO.
HEARING NO RESPONSE RELEASING
THAT LINE THAT WAS THE LAST ONE
IN Q. OKAY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. SEEING NONE OF WHICH I
CLOSE MISTER JOHN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO THE QUICK-
NOTE ON THE OF. POINT THAT WAS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION ALL
REGARDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOING ITS WORK AT.
THE FOCUS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ESSENTIALLY TO
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS AND
THERE'S LESS EMPHASIS ON THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS SO THERE'S
ROOM FOR US TO OUR WORK IN THIS
SPACE AS WELL. AND ALSO IN THE
PRIVACY ARENA THE LANDSCAPE HAS
CHANGED SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
THE CPA LAST YEAR NOW CONSUMERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO OPT OUT. WELL%
AND HAVE YOUR INFORMATION
DELETED SO I HAVEN'T SENT OUT I
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND TO FINE
TUNE THIS BILL AS WE GO FORWARD
WITHOUT THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOREVER. THANK YOU MISTER CHOW.
IS THERE A MOTION TO HEAR
MOTION FROM ANYONE. I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER AMONG THE
SECOND BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED. AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY TWO FAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD. WOULD I
MAYES OUR GEAR CURRY AGA CURRY
I'D BIGELOW. NUMBER BIGELOW NOT
VOTING BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE.
CORREO CARILLO I FLORA. FLORA
NOT VOTING. LEMOND. LIMóN I
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO WALDRON. WALDRON NOT
VOTING. SEVEN ZERO BILL IS ON
CALL. LEAVE THE CALL THE LONG
COPPERY MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MOVING ON NOW TO
MISS EGGMAN SEGMENT HAS TWO
BILLS BEFORE US WILL START WITH
A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MA'AM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS- SO BEFORE WE
WENT INTO THE PANDEMIC. WE
ALREADY HAD AN EPIC. WE HAVE AN
EPIDEMIC I THINK OF UNTREATED
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. AS WELL
AS AS IT RELATES TO
HOMELESSNESS ON OUR STREETS- SO
THE TWO BILLS BEFOR YOUR DAY
DEAL WITH THE ISSUES AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH. ONE WITH
OUTPATIENT AND THEN ONE WITH IN
PATIENTS ALL START WITH
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX UPDATED EXPAND SOME
ASPECTS OF LAURA'S LAW LAURA'S
LAW HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWO. AND THAT
LOBBY CAME ABOUT BECAUSE OF
THAT- YOUNG MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL WH WAS KILLED BY
A PATIENT. WHO WAS NOT AT THAT
PARTICIPATING ADEQUATELY WITH
TREATMENT- FROM THEM. SO
ADVANCED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
IS THE MOST AT LEAST
RESTRICTIVE CARE FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SEVERE AND PERSISTENT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- AND OFTEN
TIMES EVEN WHEN FACED IDEA HAVE
HAVE A MANDATED PEOPLE WILL GO
INTO TREATMENT VOLUNTARILY. SO
THIS IS THE ACCOUNT AND
CURRENTLY. ONLY UP TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS. IN THIS
HEALTH TWENTY COUNTIES HAVE
OPTED IN. THIS THIS YEAR WILL
SAY THAT ALL COUNTIES WILL BE
IMPLEMENT LOWERS LAW IN LESS
THEY OPT OUT SO COUNTIES CAN
STILL OPT OUT IF THEY SO CHOOSE
THIS BILL ALSO CLARIFIES THAT
MONEY THEN USED FOR ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT WILL NOT
TAKE FROM CHILDREN SERVICES OR
OTHER ALREADY EXISTING SERVICES
OR WILL BE REDUCTION. IN
SERVICES FOR OTHER JUST
ENHANCED SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
SUFFERING WITH PERSISTENT AND
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH WHOSE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES PREVENT
THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO
VOLUNTARILY OFTENTIMES GET THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED- WE
THIS ALSO WILL REGROUP REMOVED
TO SUNSET THERE'S CURRENTLY
STILL ON SET THE THREE NUDE
EVERY COUPLE YEARS WE THINK
THIS IS BEEN PILOT ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS NOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHAT TIME. DO A
PORT ON THIS AND TO TALK ABOUT
THE OUTCOME OF IT- AND AS YOU
ALL KNOW WE HEAR AND THEN
SACRAMENTO DRIVING AROUND THE
STREETS EVERYWHERE WE SEE THIS
CRISIS EVERY DAY WITH OUR VERY
OWN EYES AND OFTEN THINK WHAT
DO I DO WHEN YOU SEE SOMEBODY
WHO IS CLEARLY. HAVE
CONVERSATION TO SOMETHING
UNABLE TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES
AND LIVING ON OUR STREETS- THE
IT IS IN LIGHT OF THIS THAT
THIS BILL IS OFF TODAY. IT IS
SPONSORED BY. THE IT'S LIKE
GETTING TH SO. WITH ME TODAY
TO SPEAK. RENTAL HAGAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION. I MISTER NICK
WILCOX FOR WHO- LORE HIS
DAUGHTER WAS LARA. STARTED THE
ACTUAL LAW. MEMBERS WILL RECALL
WE HAD A- MOVING TRIBUTE AS HE
AND HIS WIFE RETIRED EARLIER
THIS YEAR SO THIS IS ONE OF THE
LAST THING HE WANTED TO GET
DONE. AND SO. I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR I WILL WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE AND- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO WE HAVE TO WITNESSES
AT THE PIER SO BOTH THE ON THE
PHONE- THREE MINUTES EACH MR
HAGAR PLEASE PROCEED WHEN OF
MISTER MODERATOR ME OVER THE
PHONE LINE. THE TRIGGER YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEY ARE YOU MAY
HAVE SELF MUTED WE'RE NOT
HEARING YOU. NOT SO HELLO YEAH
WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW OKAY SIR
THANK YOU MISTER. A AND TAKE
MEN AND- MISTER WILCOX- LAURA'S
LAW IS- COURT SUPERVISED
INTENSIVE TREATMENT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND HA BEEN A FACTOR
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS- IT IS
FUNNY COUNTIES THE STRENGTH OF
A LAWRENCE LAW PROGRAM IS
ENGAGING PEOPLE LIVING ON THE
STREETS HAVE DIFFICULT FINE
ENGAGING AND TREATMENT. THE
MOST OBVIOUS BENEFIT IS IN USE
IRAQ'S HOSPITALIZATION AND
INCIDENTS OF VIOLENCE BUT OF
PARTICULAR INTEREST IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT WHERE POLICY MAKERS
AND THE PUBLIC EQUAL. ON
HOMELESSNESS THEY T. PROGRAMS
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
PROGRAMS HELP PATIENTS MAINTAIN
STABLE HOUSING AND THE CREEKS
THAT HER AUNT'S THE MEDICATIONS
THIS IMPROVES THEIR STABILITY
AND THE COMMUNITY AT SUPPORTS
RECOVERY AND THAT'S A ANTI
HOMELESSNESS RIGHT OF MEASURE.
THIS BILL DOES CHANGE THE
PRESUMPTION THAT COUNTIES WOULD
OFTEN ADD TO AN OPT OUT MODEL.
BIT GOSH. BETTER THAN SURE IT
HELLO. MINUTE CAN HAVE A CALM
AND A VERY PUBLIC PRICE.
READING MERITS OF THE FOR THERE
TO WE THINK THE IS VERY. IT ALL
ALLOWS IS FOR COUNTY THAT WANT
pPROGRAM THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO DO THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION'S VERY
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL. AND
WE URGE YOU. FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR HAGAR OUR NEXT WAS
WITNESS MISTER WILLCOX. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS NICOLE ****
I'M CALLING IN THIS MORNING IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
THIS BILL WOULD REMOVE THE
SUNSET CLAUSE FROM LARGE LAW
AND REQUIRE COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW AND LASTLY
AFFIRMATIVELY OPT OUT MY WIFE
THE I HAVE FAULTS WITH THIS
SENSE TO. WHEN LAW OFFICE FOR.
UNDER CONSIDER IN THAT YEAR OUR
DAUGHTER LAURA. WAS A VICTIM IN
A RAMPAGE SHOOTING PERPETRATED
BY A MAN WITH SEVERE UNTREATED
MENTAL ILLNESS WE UNDERSTOOD
EARLY ON THAT. MANY WITH SEVERE
MENTAL ILLNESS DO NOT RECOGNIZE
OR ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR CONDITION
AND THEREFORE DO NOT ENGAGE IN
TREATMENT. LARGE LAW WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO CREATE A LEGAL
STRUCTURE AND A TREATMENT
PROGRAM TO ENGAGE SUCH
INDIVIDUALS. WE ENCOUNTERED
STRONG OPPOSITION AT THAT TIME.
IN ORDER TO MOVE THE ISSUE
FORWARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER HELEN
THOMPSON THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AGREE TO
A FIVE YEAR SUNSET CLAUSE IN
OUR OWN COUNTY NEVADA COUNTY-
IT WAS THE FIRST COUNTY. TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT LARGE LAW AND
SINCE THEN MANY COUNTIES HAVE
FOLLOWED. NOW OVER HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVING COUNTIES
THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED THE LAW.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS EXTENDED
THE SUNSET ON THREE OCCASIONS
SINCE THAT. THE BAD OUTCOMES
THAT OPPONENTS PREDICTED AT THE
OUTSET HAVE NOT MATERIALIZED IN
OUR COUNTY THE OUTCOMES HAVE
BEEN BETTER THAN WE HAD
ENVISIONED WITH REDUCTIONS IN
HOSPITALIZATION. INCARCERATIONS
AND HOMELESSNESS ORDER ORDER
ITSELF HAS NOT BEEN UTILIZED AS
FREQUENTLY AS WE HAD EXPECTED
AS ABOUT COUNTY HAS FOUND THAT
IN OVER 50% OF CASES THE COURT
ORDERS ARE NECESSARY AND PEOPLE
ENGAGING TREATMENT VOLUNTARILY.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE HOPE
FOR AFTER ALL THE PRIMARY GOAL
OF LARGE LAWS TO ENGAGE PEOPLE
IN LONG TERM TREATMENT SO THEY
MAY START ON THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY. WE BELIEVE THE LARGE
LAW HAS NOW PROVEN ITSELF AND
THE TIME HAS COME TO MAKE IT
PERMANENT AND MAKE IT AVAILABLE
TO EVEN MORE CALIFORNIANS.
FIGHTING QUALITY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE. IS THE HUMANE THINGTO
DO. AND IT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF SOCIETY. ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS OVER THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS. PEOPLE OF
APPROACHED AMANDA NOT AND
THANKED US. FOR A WORK ON LARGE
LONG AND SAID THAT WITHOUT IT.
YOUR LOCAL ONES WITH NO LONGER
BE A LOT. THANK YOU HIGHER
DRIVE BOTH ON AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SIR- ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO. SUPPORT THE BILL. SEE
NO ONE MISTER MODERATOR YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINE FOR OTHER
WITNESSES TO SUPPORT JUST THEIR
NAME AN ORGANIZATION. TURN THE
PHONE LINES IN WHICH TO VOICE
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY NINE THAT'S
FIVE NINE. ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN CAN YOU CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR ME IT. NO RESPONSE
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOURNAL O'DONNELL I AM PART OF
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. OKAY WELL
IT'S A LITTLE EARLY BEING OUT
GRADING TIME FOR SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. LINE ONE FORTY THREE
ONE FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS BARBARA
LEVERAGE FROM THE FEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALEX TROTMAN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARQUEE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINEONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT ONE THREE EIGHT CHERYL IS
OPEN. YOU KNOW IT'S REPRESENTED
TEN HEALTHCARE THAT REPRESENTS
THIRTEEN ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS
IN ONE ADULT INPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITY ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
ONE THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CAN WE GET BETTER HEALTH AND
THE CARD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
TESTIFY IN THE VIEWING ROOM.
SEE NO ONE- MISTER MODERATE YOU
MAY OPEN THE LINE FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY NINE FIVE
NINE. AN FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES RICHARD GALLO
AFTER CALIFORNIANS CAL BOYCE'S
OPPOSING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE ONE THREE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MICHAEL AND I AM INCLINED
THE CONFLICT THE POSITION I
LIVE IN FEAR COUNTY AND- ALL
PUBLIC ENOUGH AB ONE NINE. ONE
NINE. THANK YOU. LITTLE AYE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
BILL FLOYD WITH ACTIVE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN I HEAR MY NAME IS A
COMMUNITY I AM A CONSUMER WITH
LARGE SPENCER HEALTH SYSTEM IN
THE COUNTRY ACTUAL CUTTING
PROVIDE TO HELP AN ACTIVE
COMBAT LEARNING SHOWN LEVERS I
NAY VOTE IN THIS RELEASE A
SECOND TYPE THING HOW WILL
BILL. THANK YOU. YOU THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO SIX TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND SIXTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK
YOUR LINE. DURING THE AUDIO
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO AGAIN MANY
MCDONNELL O'DONNELL ACTIVE
COMBAT. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVEN ONE
ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. A
DOCTOR WOULD MEMBERS THIS IS
THIRD CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION NONE THE LESS AMEND
THAT- ON THE BILL AND WE
APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS OF
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS IN YOUR
COMMITTEES AFTER WORK- AND- OUR
CONCERNED. WE DO HAVE DURING
DURING A CONCERNS. TO THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER NINE
FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUNGER YEARBOOKS AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. A WE NEED MORE
RISK BY THE SERVICES. THEY NEED
MORE YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
MORE THAT JUST CUED UP PLEASE
ALLOW MOMENT. ALL RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE SEVERAL DURING UP WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY TO WEAR
HEARING AUDIO HI THIS IS LEN
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
ALSO HAVE THE SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION ALONG WITH OUR
PARTNERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. THANK
YOU. GIVE ORDER LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE ONE FOUR
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN DENNIS
CUSTOMER WHAT THEY FEEL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE NO FORMAL
POSITION WE HAVE- EXPRESSED
CONCERN SO OFFICE OFFICE IN THE
BOOK TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
OFFICE. OKAY THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN ONE THREE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR OUR TERRACE WILL BE
HAPPY MESSI I YOU CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE. A LATE UP OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. POSITION ON THE BILL
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO TALK
TALKING FURTHER WITH THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE HAVE ONE MORE HEADLINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR ONE FOUR
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR YEAR.
SORRY BUT THE HEAT FROM ACTED
CALIFORNIA ALL DONE AT THE
HOUSE. MRS STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. ANYONE THAT IS OFF
THE AUDIO TO AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- LIKE TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE- MADAM.
MISS EGGMAN EXCUSE ME I'M SO.
FREE TO AFFECTING BOTH- YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD WITH THAT WITH
ALL SIDES- AND PEOPLE KNOWING
MY STAFF I HAVE A STUFFED FULL
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON
THIS BILL AND I WE APPRECIATE
ALL THE SUPPORT WE RECEIVE. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION- AT. AT SOME POINT
WE NEED TO ACT THE- I HAVE
OFTEN REFER TO OUR MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. LIKE OUR- OUR
FOREST FIRES WE WILL FOR A LONG
TIME WE LOCK EVERYBODY UP
WITHIN LIKE HOW THEY BEHAVE.
AND THEN WE DISCOVERED THAT WAS
A REALLY BAD IDEA AND THEN WE
WENT TO ANOTHER SIDE WHERE WE
DIDN'T HOLD ANYBODY FOR PRESS
ANYBODY INTO TREATMENT. SAME
THING WE DO WITH OUR FORCE
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN WE CLEAR
CUT OLD GROWTH. WE KNEW THAT
WAS A REALLY BAD IDEA AND THEN
WE DID NOTHING. WE HAVE WILD
FIRES IN OUR STATE AND WE HAVE
WILD FIRES A MORE STREET WITH
OUR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I FORGOT TO
MENTION. EARLIER MISTER WILLCOX
POINTED OUT SMALLER COUNTIES
CAN- FORM TOGETHER TO DO AN
AMMO YOU TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TREATMENT. THAT WAY AND AGAIN.
ANY COUNTY CAN CERTAINLY POPPED
OUT- BUT THIS IS AN EVIDENCE
BASED. PROGRAM THAT ACTUALLY
WORKS. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS EGGMAN
THIS BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I JUST WOULD
NOTE THAT EIGHTEEN YEARS IS A
LONG TIME TO WAIT FOR A LOT OF
BECOME PERMANENT- THIS DOES
SIDE. HAPPY SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY- WE DO HAVE A MOTION
REMOTE FROM- MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
A SECOND BY. MISTER BIGELOW IS
A BIGGER YES OKAY RIGHT WE GOT
TO BE EASIER TO COULD REMEMBER
MY OWN NOTES SOUTH. SO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD
I MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I'D BIGELOW
BIGELOW I BONTA. BONTA I BURKE
DARIO RIO I FLORA FLORA I
LIMóN. MCCARTY MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON
WALDRON I MAYES MAYES AYE.
NAZARIAN I. BILL PASSES
THIRTEEN ZERO SO THIRTEEN ZERO
LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR OTHERS
TO ADD ON THINKING A SEGMENT
NEW PLEASE GO ON TO YOUR NEXT
BILL AB TWENTY FIFTEENS CHAIR
OF THE MY NEXT BILL DOWN DEALS
WITH IMPATIENCE SO GET
SOMETHING GOING TO OUTPATIENT.
THOSE YOU WANNA A HOUSING WHERE
YOU'RE AND GO. HOPEFULLY NOT
LATER THIS WEEK THIS HAS TO DO
WITH THE R. LPS PROCESS SO
CURRENTLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- IF YOU IF YOU ARE
UNABLE TO CARE FOR YOURSELF
WHETHER YOU'RE DANGEROUS PEOPLE
KNOW THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY
CRITERIA YOU ARE ABLE TO BE
HELD AGAINST YOUR WILL FOR A
PERIOD OF THREE DAYS. FOR
STABLE XIN. THAT THREE DAYS AND
THEN IN OR TO BE ABLE TO HOLD
SOMEBODY FOR TWO WEEKS. WE FIND
THAT IS WHER THE BIG DROP
OFFICE MANY PEOPLE HELD AGAINST
HER WILL FOR THREE DAYS PARK IS
NOT ENOUGH TIME TO STABILIZE
THEM IN WHICH TIME THEY CYCLE
BACK OUT INTO THE STREETS. AND
OFTENTIMES WILL COME THROUGH
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN. WE
WANT TO CHANGE THE CRITERIA FOR
BEING ABLE TO KEEP SOMEBODY FOR
THE TWO WEEK COLD. TO THE
ABILITY TO FOR THEM TO CARE FOR
THEIR MEDICAL NEEDS- OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE COME AND THEY MIGHT HAVE
BLOOD SUGARS YOU KNOW OVER
THREE HUNDRED OR- SEVERE
ABSCESS ON YOUR SUPPORT. OTHER
KIND CARE NEEDS MEDICAL
HEALTHCARE NEEDS THAT THEY-
ATTEND TO. BECAUSE OF THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. SO THIS WOULD
SIMPLY SAY AGAIN WHEN I TRY TO
GET MORE PEOPLE INTO THE- WHO
IS BEING HELD AGAINST THEIR
WILL. AT WE DO HOLD SOMEBODY
AGAINST OTHER. STABLE EFORE WE
DISCHARGE THEM OUT WITH THE
PLAN THAT THEY'LL HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO FOLLOW. SO THAT'S ALL
THIS DOES IS IT ADD ONE MORE
DIMENSION TO THE CRITERIA. OF
WHAT WHAT WE NEED TO DO IN
ORDER TO HOLD SOMEBODY FOR TWO
WEEKS VERSES. AT SEVENTY TWO
HOURS. WELL THIS YEAR- PEOPLE
KNOW IS. ACT BOTH AS A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL. AND AS A
FAMILY MEMBER I HAD AN AUNT
WITH SEVERE PERSISTENT BI POLAR
DISORDER. I'M I'VE TAKEN TO.
DEALING WITH THAT. AT THE THEY
SPENT TRYING TO GET THEIR MOM
OFF THE STREET AND INTO
TREATMENT- ONE TIME. IN A HOLD
FOR THREE DAYS THEY BEGGED HER.
TO KEEP HER FOR TWO WEEKS THAT
WOULD STAY WITH. HER SHE WAS
REPLACED. RATE THE- HAVE DIED.
EVERY TIME I SEE MY COUSIN SHE
SAID PLEASE PLEASE HOW WOULD
YOU GIVE PEOPLE DIGNITY TO LET
THEM LIVE HONEST LIKE THAT
MEMBERS I OFFER TO ANY WITH YOU
KIDS WE'RE DRIVING DOWN THE
STREET RIGHT NOW I HAVE AN
ELEVEN YEAR OLD AND LOOK OUT
THE WINDOW AND THERE'S SOMEBODY
CLEARLY HAVING HAVE A SO THE
MIDDLE THIS. OF AT AN SHE SAYS
TO ME MOMMY WOULD WE DO AND I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE AN
ANSWER FOR THAT WE HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT HELPS PEOPLE WE
DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM THAT TURNS
ARE BACK ON PEOPLE AND IS TOO
CONCERNED ABOUT. MAKING SURE
EVERYBODY HAS THE RIGHT IF ANY
WAY THEY WANT. WE BELIEVE
PEOPLE HAVE THE RIGHT TO LIVE.
BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE SOMETIMES
OR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. DON'T
LET THEM MAKE THE DECISIONS
THAT THEY NEED. THIS IS SIMPLY
A WAY TO BE ABLE TO STABILIZE
PEOPLE. BEFORE THEY GO OUT ONTO
THE STREETS- THIS IS- THAT WE
HAVE WORKED VERY HARD WITH THE-
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THIS. AND WITH ME
TODAY I ALSO HAVE RENTAL HAGAR
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION- SO AGAIN WE HAD
DISTRICTS BEFORE KOBE. IS GOING
TO GET. HOPEFULLY WE'RE GONNA
COME OUT WITH TOOLS. WE KNOW
NOW NO WE HAVE TO ACT- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
EGGMAN- WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE MR HAGAR WOULD YOU
LIKE A MISTER MODERATE YOU MAY
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR OR
WITNESSES TO PROCEED. BY
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THIS IS
RANDALL TAKE AGAIN- BUT THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION WE'RE VERY PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS LEGISLATION-
AT THE SEGMENTS THAT THIS IS-
FOCUSING AND VERY AND A VERY
SURGICAL WAY ON A DIFFERENT
PART OF OUR TREATMENT SYSTEM
AND IT HAS TO DO WITH A
PERSON'S MEDICAL STATUS AND
REALLY IT HAS TO DO WITH HOW
THAT ITSELF BEARS ON THE BILL
OF RIGHTS SAFELY YEAH
COMMUNITY- WHEN IT TRYING TO
CONSIDER WHETHER OTHER PERSON
SHOULD BE. CAPPED I YEAH WE ARE
SEVEN TO OUR WHOLE FOR THE FOR
THE DAY TO TREAT. WE WANT TO BE
A TO CONSIDER. THE MEDICAL
STATUS OF AN INDIVIDUAL CURRENT
LAW FAILS TO ADDRESS THAT. A
CERTIFICATION- REVIEW HEARING
OFFICERS MORE OFFICERS OF THE
SUPERIOR COURT WILL TELL YOU
CONSIDERANY THING THAT HAS TO
DO WITH A MEDICAL OR PHYSICAL
MALADY- THAT THEY'RE CONFINED
TO FINDING WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE A SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND THAT IT YEAH SO IS A VERY
VERY NARROW LOCATION OF THE LAW
BUT IT IS CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THAT PREVENT HEARING
OFFICER CONSIDERING ANY
EVIDENCE WHEN THE PSYCHIATRIST
WOULD POINT OUT TO THEM BUT
THEY DO HAVE. THE HI. BLOOD
SUGAR LEVEL THAT THE OPEN SORE
ON THEIR LEG OR WHATEVER MIGHT
BE. THIS BILL DOES CORRECT THAT
SITUATION ALLOWS EVIDENCE OF A
PERSON'S MEDICAL CONDITION TO
BE INTRODUCED THE EVIDENCE. AND
CONSIDER IN ANY. FORM THE
NATION AND WE THINK THAT THIS
IS A REALLY. REALLY OF THE
THANK YOU FOR. ALMOST ARE IN
AND NEED OUR HELP WE APPRECIATE
SUPPORT ON THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER HAGE WE HAVE
OF THE MISTER IS GONNA BE
ANOTHER WITNESS. YES THANK YOU
THIS IS A KID GROWS ON BEHALF
THE PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION
ONLY AT THAT. BOB REVIEWS OF
THE PROCESS. BY WHICH THE
HEARING OFFICER CAN CONSIDER
WHAT MISTER HAGER DESCRIBED IT
DOES NOT DICTATE NOW COME TO
THE HEARING OFFICER BUT UNDER
CURRENT LAW MANY HEARING OFF
SHE SAID WE HAVE NO ABILITY TO
LOOK AT THE HEALTH CONDITION-
AND ITS RELATIONSHIP TO- THE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION AND
THIS WILL NOW GET THE ABILITY
OF PSYCHIATRISTS TO. BRING THAT
IN THANK YOU FOR THE HEARING
OFFICER TO CONSIDER IT WE DO
CONSIDERED A NARROW CHECKING
BUT IN PORT CHANGE BECAUSE OF
SO MANY PEOPLE WHO TO FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY IN THE MISS VIEWING
ROOM. SEEING NOTHING THERE WILL
GO AHEAD AND MISTER MODERATE
YOU MAY OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JUST
THE NAME AN ORGANIZATION ONLY.
CUTE PLUS PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO VOICE
SUPPORT ON THE AUDIO PHONE
LINE. WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE ONE
FOUR THREE YOUR LINES. OKAY ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THEY WOULD NOT
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN ONE ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS BRANDON MY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK LOW
POINT FORTY FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ALICE HAWTHORNE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL WITH THE
WITH THE EVENT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO ONE
FIVE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
PAYLESS REPRESENTING TEN
HOSPITALS WE OPERATE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT IN A PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITY JUST BILL ISN'T REALLY
A BIG. THANK YOU. THANK LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE ONE
FOUR THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FOUR THREE A LINE IS OPEN
WE'RE HEARING AUDIO. HEARING NO
RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX ONE
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
LINES OPEN WE'RE HEARING NO
AUDIO. NO RESPONSE FROM THAT
LINE THERE AND NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
WITNESSES LISTED IN OPPOSITION
BUT- WILL OBVIOUSLY HAVE A IS
THERE PLEASE I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY IN THE IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM.
SEE NINE WILL HAVE MR MURRAY ME
OPEN THE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION ONLY IN A PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER. FIFTY NINE FIVE
NINE. YES RICHARD GALLO ABSENCE
CALIFORNIA CAL BOYCE'S OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
CAROLINA'S OPEN. OECTA METERS
BUT LET'S TALK COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH PLAN
COALITION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE ONE FIVE NINE YOUR LINE.
ONE FIVE NINE. OKAY SORRY ONE
FIVE NINE IS NOT BEING Q. ANY
LONGER WELL NINE ONE HUNDRED
AND. FORTY FOUR ONE FOUR FOUR.
I DON'T THINK HE WITH A
CALIFORNIA. IS STRONGLY
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE SIXTY FIVE YOU'RE
FREE TO SPEAK. YEAH IN THE
EARLY YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW.
YEAH WILL FLOYD WITH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DONALD DONALD WITH ACTORS
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED THE
BILL. THANK YOU WILL GO BACK TO
LINE ONE FIFTY NINE ONE FIVE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS. SIGN WITH
THE VOLUNTARY SERVICES.
MALICIOUS INTENT WHEN I OPPOSE
THIS BILL AB TWO ZERO ONE FOUR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE THIRTY THREE WILL BOOK
ONE THIRTY THREE IS WITHDRAWN
WILL GO TO ONE FORTY THREE ONE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE ONE FOUR THREE WERE
HEARING AUDIO. THE HEAD RELEASE
THAT LINE LOOKS LIKE ONE THIRTY
THREE HAS RE QUEUED ONE THREE
THREE ARE OPEN. AND THEN I
CALLED IN AND- I AM OPPOSITION
A. B. YOUR LITTLE ONE. THANK
YOU. WE'VE EXHAUSTED BUT YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
WILL WHICH I CLOSE MY SEGMENT-
I JUST. THINK THE MEMBERS FOR.
HEARING THIS BILL TODAY AND I
THINK AGAIN WE ALL HAVE A-
CRISIS OF CONSCIENCE GOING
WHERE I'M STREETS AND WE SEE.
TO WHICH YOU CAN JUST ABOUT.
ALSO THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IS ON BOARD NO NO PEOPLE LIKE
MY FRIEND MR- FROM WAS A FORMER
AT THE END. IT IS ALSO A HUGE
BURDEN ON THE TAXPAYER TO BE
OUT OF THE E. R. WITH THEIR OUT
OF CONTROL. FIRST RESPONDERS
HAVING TO GO OUT AND RESPOND TO
PEOPLE THIS IS A WAY TO GET
PEOPLE STABLE. SO THAT AND THEN
THEY BEGIN OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IBM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTAKE YEAR
CURRY TO HEAR A SECOND. SECOND
BY MISTER RODRIGUEZ QUESTION IS
ARE YOU SETTING THE AMENDMENT
YES OKAY SO THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
FIFTEEN MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD
I WOULD BUY ME. MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AYE GEAR CURRY
I'D BEEN LOW. HI BIGELOW ON I
BONTA. WANT TO. BURKE RIO.
FLORA FLORA I LIMóN LIMóN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON. WALDRON
I'D. MISS KOREA BILL HAS
THIRTEEN CAREER VERY CARILLO. I.
THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN BOTH
SPEAK OUT BILLS THAT LEAVES THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
SEGMENT. OUR NEXT- MISTER FOR.
AB. TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS WANT TO
START BY THANKING YOUR STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR EFFORTS IN
ALLOWING THIS BILL TO BE HEARD
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
WOULD ALLOW COUNTY RECORDER'S
TO CONTINUE ACCEPTING A TRONIC
VERIFICATION OF IDENTITY FROM
OUTLETS REQUESTING CERTIFIED
VITAL RECORDS ONLINE.
CALIFORNIANS ARE CURRENTLY ABLE
TO OBTAIN THE VITAL RECORDS
THROUGH. THE COUNTY RECORDER'S
OFFICE IN THREE WAYS NUMBER ONE
GOING TO THE OFFICE AND PERSON.
NUMBER TWO MAILING IN OR FAXING
A NOTARIZED QUEST TO THE
RECORDER OR THREE. APPLYING
ONLINE BEEN ONLINE VALIDATION
PROCESS. THE THIRD OF JUNE.
ALLOWS FOR INDIVIDUAL TO SAVE
TIME AND MONEY. IN REQUESTING
RECORDS. AB TWENTY THREE AND
I'M SORRY TWENTY SIX THIRTY SIX
OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHICH-
BOTH HOUSES UNANIMOUSLY ALLOW
FOR. BUT TRYING TO GET REQUEST
FOR RIDE- RECORDS. TO BE
ACCEPTED AS LONG AS THE
APPLYING INDIVIDUAL PROVIDED IN
DEPTH VERIFICATION. IT TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX SIMPLY SEEKS
TO ELIMINATE THE SUNSET DATE OF
THIS ORIGINAL PROGRAM THERE'S
BEEN NO IDENTITY THEFT OR FRAUD
ATTRIBUTING ATTRIBUTED. TO THE
USE OF SUCH SYSTEMS THIS
PROGRAMS WITH HOW TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN LOS ANGELES SAN
MARINO RIVERSIDE SACRAMENTO
ELDORADO INSURANCE AND ON THE
COUNTIES. WE ALSO MADE A
COMMITMENT WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO CONSENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM TO ROOM TO REMOVING
AND ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
HERE TO TESTIFY SUPPORT ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS
WRONG. ACOSTA ANSWER FROM RICK
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY
RECORDER'S SO SHE XIN OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR FLORA YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. I'MSORRY WE DO HAVE
ONE IN THE VIDEO ROOM YES. OUR
SECOND WITNESS IN THE WITNESS
VIDEO THIS IS CITING SO. A LOT
OF PRESSURE ON A LOT OF
PRESSURE. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROB RESPONSE
OR WITH THE CAN YOU REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION- HOPEFULLY CAN HEAR
ME HERE- DO APPRECIATE THE
SELLER FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD. AS HE STATED THIS IS
ABOUT REQUESTING RECORDS THIS
DOES NOT HOST RECORDS ONLINE
THIS IS OUR REQUEST METHODOLOGY
THAT AND LIVE THE PANDEMIC
ALLOWS US TO REQUEST DIRECT IF
WE FROM THE COMFORT OF THEIR
OWN- AS REPORTERS ASSETS
ABILITIES HE FOR US. AND WE'VE
SEEN ALL RIGHT SIR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY ABLE TO USE THIS
PROCESS AND THE JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE ABOUT IT THE SIMPLE
THIS YOUR MOBILE THE S. YEAH I
KNOW. THAT PROCESS WHEN OUR-
CHILDREN. I NEED IS THAT THOSE
PREVENTIVA CAN AND SAND STATE
GOV COUNTY SAN BERNARD NINE SAM
JOAQUIN SO US WE THINK THAT
IT'S A MAY AS THE SO EVER NOTED
WE HAVE NOT ANY AND OF. ACROSS
THE NAY AS WAS LATE THE DOCK OF
THIS WE HAVE OVER FORTY STATES
CURRNTLY USING THIS SIMILAR
SYSTEM AND IN PLACE HAPPY
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK. SEN I
BELIEVE WITNESS ON PHONE. I AM
YOU MIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LAURA
CURTIS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THE
LEADING ASSOCIATION FOR GLOBAL
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX AND
APPRECIATE THE OTHER BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR A- DAY I'D LIKE
TO. POINT FIRST MULTI LAYERED
REMOTE I DIDN'T APPROVING
INDUSTRY STATE PROVIDING THE
SECURITY WAY OF REQUESTING BY
RECORD THIS METHOD TO ACCEPT
ELECT I DON'T RECORD REQUEST
MUST MEET OR EXCEED THE-
STANDARDS AND A G. DRIVE YEAH.
ONE SECURITY. BACK IN THE YOU
KNOW A CHRONIC TRANSACTION ACT
REQUIRE. SPECIFICALLY THE NET
STANDARDS FOR ELECTRONIC
IDENTITY VERIFICATION REQUIRE
STRICT SCRUTINY ABOUT CAN IN A
MULTI STEP PROCESS. APPLICANTS
GOVERNMENT ISSUED ID AND DATE
OF BIRTH MUST BE VALIDATED
ALONG WITH THE FOLLOWING
INFORMATION AS PART OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. THE BILL
THAT THE APPLICANT PROVIDE MUST
BE PREVIOUSLY IF YOU DO WITH
APPLE CAN. AND KNOWN TO THE
AGENCY THE CREDIT CARD THAT THE
APPLICANT PROVIDE. IN THE NAME
OF THE APPLICATION HI THE FIVE
ACCOUNT. THE PHONE PREVIOUSLY
SO WITH THE APPLICANT KNOWN TO
BE BEING BE PER. FOR RE TIME.
AT THE TIME OF THE REQUEST.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE APPLICANT MUST CERTIFY
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY THAT
THE APPLICANT AUTHORIZED
ACCESS. TO RECORDS REQUESTED OR
THEY'D BE IN VIOLATION OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE AS WELL
COMMITTING CREDIT CARD FRAUD.
IN FACT IF THE STATUTE WERE
SAID TO LET. HER KNOW RE
PROCESS ONLY RECALL ONE VISUAL.
VERIFICATION OF. I THE DRY
LICENSE AND A- SECURE
REQUIREMENTS. ARMAND ARE
DICTATED BY STATE SEVENTY A
VITAL RECORD REQUEST RECEIVED
BY AGENCIES COME FROM OF
CALIFORNIA THE PERSON LIVE OUT
OF STATE IN NEED VITAL BECAUSE
THEY WERE BORN FOR EXAMPLE IT
WOULD ACTUALLY BE THE OUT OF
STATE NOTARY THAT WHAT I THE
VERIFICATION. THANK YOU. SEVEN
IN THE FOR NOT TO MAKE AN
ONLINE REQUEST OR FELT THE AUTO
THE DEDICATION PROCESS ONLINE.
THEY CAN STILL REQUESTED
DOCUMENTS THROUGH THE MEMORY
PROCESS IF AN INDIVIDUAL
HAPPENED TO BUILD ON LINE
IDENTIFICATION PROCESS IT ONLY
EMPHASIZES HOW STRICTLY
STANDARDS ARE. AS MENTIONED
THIS EITHER FIVE VERIFICATIONS
AN ONLINE PROCESS THIS WILL
VISION VISUAL VERIFICATION OF A
SINGLE IT IN THE NOTARY
PROCESS. THIRD PARTY OTHER
STATE ARE YOU WRITING THIS MORE
SECURE ONLINE ELECTRONIC ID
PROVING PROCESS. ONLY MET THANK.
WITH A ON A P. NOTARIZED
STATEMENT IF THIS LAW WERE TO
SUNSET. FINALLY IT'S IMPORTANT
REMEMBER THE EIGHTY TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX. FOR THE
QUEST A DOCUMENT. IS NOT AN ACT.
THE DOCUMENTS THEMSELVES.
OTHERS IS A MISS MURRAY MAIL.
THOUGH THE IS. FOR MEMBERS GRAB
WITH ASSISTANCE OF. THANK YOU
THOSE LISTENING ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WISH TO VOICE
SUPPORT IN A PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT TO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
KELLY BROOK URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE ONE
OTHER LITTLE LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FOUR ONE SIX FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU CAN MEMBER
JOHNSON WITH PAC MAN WORK THANK
YOU. NO ONE ELSE STOOD UP AT
THIS TIME PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. IN THE
WETNESS VIEWING ROOM. SEE NO
ONE MISTER MODERATE YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HERE IN SILENCE I
THINK THAT MEANS THERE ISN'T
ANYBODY THERE. THAT CORRECT
MISTER MODERATOR. TWO WE LOSE
OUR MODERATOR. HELLO MISTER
MODERATOR. IN ORDER TO LINE OF
LINE ONE TWENTY SIX ONE ONE
TWENTY SIX ALAINA CURRENTLY
OPEN. AND WE ARE CRAP THAT WE
ARE. IN OPPOSITION TO THAT WELL.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. AT IT.
THE FIVE. AT THE TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED. PLEA ON SORRY YOU SAID
PLEASE PROCEED. NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL CHANGE A
MODERATOR SO TAKE ME A SECOND
TO GET A CLUE IN HERE SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. OF ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM. SEE NO ONE
BRING BACK TO THE AUTHOR WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK THREE I DON'T THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FLORA- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL. WE
DID NOT MISTER MAYES. WHEN MR
MR MAYS MADE THE MOTION A
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW. OUR
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MASS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I. WOULD I
MAYES. MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AYE GEAR CURRY I'D BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'D BONTA. BONTA AYE
BURKE. CARILLO FLORA FLORA I
LIMóN MCCARTY NAZARIAN. RAMOS
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON I'D.
IT HAS NINE VOTES BILL IS OUT
BILLS THAT WILL LEAVE THE BILL-
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON IT WOULDN'T MAKE A- BEFORE
MR GLORIA OUR NEXT AUTHOR
PROCEEDED WITH WE'RE GOING TO-
CHANGE THE AFTER MISTER GLORIA
OF MR MCCARTY WHO HAS A BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEETING TO. GOING TO
PRESENT FOR MR MAKE NINE MISTER
GLORIA MR CALL- YOU WOULDN'T
ORDINARILY BE AN EXPERT WITNESS
SWITCH TO GIVE MISTER CARTY
APTITUDE TEST FIVE FOUR MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN SO. MR GLORIA. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HAVE FOR LEARNING
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX- TO YOUR
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING
CALIFORNIA VOTERS RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WITH THE
PASSAGE OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR IN THE YEARS
SINCE ITS ENACTMENT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE A NUMBER
OF MODIFICATIONS TO MHSAA
INCLUDING INCREASED OVER OVER
ON THE EXISTING REVISION
PROCESS AND ESTABLISHING
RESERVE LEVELS COUNTY HEALTH
PROGRAM. SENATE USUALLY OUR
HOUSING WAS DESCRIBED AS FIVE
DAD GREEN GRAY. THOSE THAT ARE
NOT ALREADY TO A MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER AT THE POINT THE FIRST
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS NEVER
GET NUMBER CALIFORNIANS SOON
DISPLAY SUCH A DISORDER THE
LONGER THEY REMAIN ON SHELTER.
THIS BILL RIGHT. HAVERHILL HELP
NEEDING. UNSPENT REVERTED MHSAA
FUNDS TO BE USED FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROVIDING SERVICES
TO PEOPLE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
WHO ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS I THINK THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION FOR THEIR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS I BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS ANY
FINAL DRAFTING IF THE BILL'S
FORTUNE NOT TO RECEIVE THIS
COMMITTEE'S APPROVAL. THIS
MORNING THE AUTHOR OF LAST
YEAR'S AB FORTY THREE WHICH TRY
TO IMPROVE UPON THE COMPETE
PLANNING PROCESS I CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THE LOCAL AGENCIES IN
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE BEST
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITH ME TODAY THAT.
SENATE COUNCIL MEMBER A CHAIR
THE SANTEE LEGAL TASK FORCE THE
HOMELESS CAN MEMBER CHRIS WILL.
THANK VERY MUCH MR GLORIA.
MADAM MY READY MAY OPEN THE
LINE FOR OUR TESTIMONY. IN
SUPPORT. FIFTEEN GERMAN IF
YOU'RE AT THE PORT OF THE BILL
PEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE A
WITNESS- COUNCIL MEMBER CHRIS
WARD TO TESTIFY. PLEASE OPEN
THAT LINE THANK YOU AND I.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHRIS WARD
ON THE INDIGO COUNCILMEMBER
REPRESENTING DOWNTOWN AND
TRAVEL URBAN NEIGHBORHOODS IN
THE CORE OF SAN DIEGO- ALSO
SERVICE THE CHAIR OF THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL TASK FORCE ON
THE HOMELESS AND OUR REGION
CONTINUUM OF CARE. IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO SPEAK TODAY. OR OR
HMM WERE GLORIA. OPPOSED
ASSEMBLY TWENTY SEVEN SIX. THE
LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW IT
REVERTED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUND DOLLARS TO BE SPENT IN
SUPPORT OF PROVIDING SERVICES
TO SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS THOSE INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THOSE
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND ARE YOU. WE
KNOW THAT HEALTHCARE NEEDS ARE
TOP PARTY. UNITY NOW MORE SO
THAN EVER. ALLOWING FOR GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW AND YOU
CAN'T. HAVE DONE UNDER. BILL
HELP. A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
THAT ACCOUNTS FOR SOME OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES I KNOW PERSONALLY
DEGREE NEED FOR FUNDING TO THE
POOR INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS WHO ARE ALSO. EX THING
HOMELESSNESS AND WHAT CAN I
THAT IMPORTANT FOR COUNTY SUCH
A TEN COUNTY DEFENDANT AND
MEETS AT THAT ALLOCATION. IF
IT'S NOT ACCOMPLISHED AND
EXPANDED APPLICATION FOR
REPORTED FUND IS IMPORTANT IN
CAN BE VERY HELPFUL- JUST RIGHT
NOW THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO. WE APPROVED THE
CREATION TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS HE WILL HELP IMPACT
FUND TO BRING MUCH NEEDED
OPPORTUNITY AND LONG TERM AND-
HEALTH SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WHAT ALLOCATION AND-
SO YOU THINK HE TWENTY FIVE
SEVEN. WOULD CERTAINLY BRING
BALLOT WITHIN GO WELL OTHER CAL.
CITIES IN TOWN I THINK YOU IN
THE- YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU
VERY MISTER WARD. SINCE SUPPORT
MADAM- MADRE YOU MAY OPEN THE
LINE FOR OTHER SUPPORT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION ONLY. THANK YOU
IT'S ONE NINE ZERO TO VOICE
YOUR SUPPORT WILL GO THE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOU'RE
NOT AS A- NINE. BILLION CARE TO
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR WE ARE SUPPORTED
FROM AND THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
ONE THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL THEM ON COMPETITIVE
COUNTY AND I. SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE A COUPLE
MORE QUEUING UP WILL GO TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
ONE SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI TONY CASTANEDA CUT ME
LOS ANGELES A SECOND TO. THE
GOAL OF SCHOOL OF LIFE YES.
THANK YOU. YOU WILL CALL LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
SEVEN ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF OF THAT SO YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU THANK. THAT HAS
EXHAUSTED THE PHONE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
IN THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM.
SEEING A BLANK SCREEN WILL MOVE
ON AS ARE ANY OF ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES- MISTER. MODERATOR YOU
MAY OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN OFFICE. YOU ARE
NOT POSITION AND WISH TO HAVE
YOUR VOICE HEARD YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE ONE IT'S GOING TO LINE UP
TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JOURNAL O'DONNELL WITH
ACTIVE CALIFORNIA. OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. AND WE
ALSO HAVE ONE FROM LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MEANS BUT LARGEST COUNTY IN THE
STATE THIS IS ACTUALLY-
PROPOSED AN ARCHITECT A AS LONG
AS- THE SERVICES ARE BEGINNING
TO MEDIATE COMPLIANCE AND- THAT
CPPA IS REINSTATED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR ONE FOUR FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AMPLE WITHOUT THE
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NO ONE ELSE IN THE AUDIO
Q. AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEE
NONE BRING BACK TO YOU MISTER
WHERE I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST SPENT MY APPRECIATION
TEAMS CHAIRMAN TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR CONSIDERATION I
WITH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EITHER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DID
WE HAVE A MOTION. WE DID
PERMITS AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BY
MISTER RAMOS. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS AND DO
DO ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR. AND SIX THIS
CALL THE ROLL. AB FIVE TWENTY
SIX SHOULD DO PASSED. CREATION
WOULD. WHAT I MACE. I GET A
CURRY I GET VERY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE RIO. FLORA LEMOND
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I'D NAZARIAN
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON.
BILL IS ON CALL SIX VOTES LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL FOR YOU MISTER
GLORIA AS AS AS I'M AT NOW STE
EARLIER WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MR
MCCARTY WHO IS IMPERSONATING
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN TODAY. SO HE
CAN GO TO HIS BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING YOU'RE NOT REALLY
IMPERSONATING YOU'RE
REPRESENTING MY APOLOGIES SO.
YOU'D LIKE TO TRY TO
IMPERSONATE HIM GO RIGHT AHEAD
SO OKAY. AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY.
THANK YOU A LIST OF CARING
MEMBERS I AM PRESENTING THIS
BILL IN THE HOUSE BECAUSE THIS
TO MAIENSCHEIN TODAY- THIS BILL
IS ABOUT- MATERNAL A MENTAL
HEALTH IT'S IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS OFTEN
OVERLOOKED ESPECIALLY AMONG
WOMEN AND CHILDREN MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN ONE FIVE WOMEN WILL BE
A TWO BY I MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER DURING THEIR PREGNANCY
OR THE FIRST YEAR GIVES BIRTH
AND PROBABLY MENTAL. IN
CHILDREN HAS BEEN. FOR CLUB IN.
THEIR CAPTAIN DIED. A TREATING
ME HEALTH. AND A SHORTAGE OF
PROVIDERS WITH THE APPROPRIATE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE NOW
THE INSTANCES OF MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS. HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO INCREASE
EXPONENTIALLY AS MOTHERS FACE
THE POSSIBILITY OF PREGNANCY
CHILDBIRTH THE RAISING A CHILD
DURING A GLOBAL. DAM MAKE.
SOCIAL AND PHYSICAL ISOLATION
AND ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY. THE
MENTAL HEALTH ASPECTS ON
CHILDREN WHO HAD BEEN A LOT OF
NORMAL ROUTINES WILL LIKELY
MANIFEST FOR YEARS TO COME.
EARLY IN APPROPRIATE DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT HAS BEEN PROVEN
TO MAKE IT MORE SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND CAN REDUCE
THE RECURRENCE OF FASHION.
REYES IN CERTAIN TIME WE
CAñADA THE IMPACTS ON IT'LL
HELP AND WE MUST FIND WAYS TO
DELIVER APPROPRIATE. DELIVER
CARE APPROPRIATELY EFFICIENTLY
AND SAFELY. THIS MEASURE WOULD
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
PSYCHIATRISTS AND INCREASING
THE PREVALENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND MOTHERS AND CHILDREN. BY
REQUIRING HEALTH PLAN THIS IS
THE THIS IS THE CORRECT HERE BY
REQUIRING HEALTH PLANS TO
DEVELOP. A DOCTOR DOCTOR
TELEPHONE. PSYCHIATRY
CONSULTATION LINE TO SUPPORT
PROVIDERS IN BUILDING THEIR
CAPACITY TO DIAGNOSE AND TREAT
DISORDERS. TELL PSYCHIATRY
CONSULTATIONS CAN EXPEDITE CARE
TO PATIENTS ELIMINATE
UNNECESSARY APPOINTMENTS AND
REDUCE HEALTHCARE COSTS. ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY. WITH ME IS
AMBER GINSBURG. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MCCARTY. MISTER MODERATOR YOU
MAY OPEN THE LINE FOR OUR
TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT. Q.
SPEAKER LINES ARE OPEN. MULLIN
I AM RUNNING A CROSS CHECK
AGAINST THE SPEAKER WAS FOR
THIS ONE. AMBER GINSBURG OKAY.
YEP SHE ENDED UP IN THE WRONG
ROOM ONE MOMENT PLEASE I'M OVER
HERE. BURKE AND YOUR LINE IS
OPEN IN YOUR FREE TO SPEAK. HI
JESSICA YES GO AHEAD PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS AMBER SHE CAN
FOR HER MOTHER. TO AND I
THOUGHT ON THE GOVERNING
COUNCIL MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
NOW EXACTLY TWENTY WEEKS
PREGNANT I WOKE UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT AND HAD A
MAP OF PANIC ATTACK I THOUGHT
IT WOULD BE FINE. I HAD THREE
MORE THAT NIGHT AND THEY KEPT
GOING AFTER THREE DAYS OF NOT
SLEEPING I ENDED UP IN THE ER I
FELT CRAZY AND HELPLESS. YOUR
DOCTOR SAID THAT BECAUSE I WAS
PREGNANT COULD NOT GIVE ME
ANYTHING GO HOME RELAX SHE SAID
THE PANIC ATTACKS CONTINUED
WORKING TURN FOR MY TWO YEAR
OLD BECAME NEAR IMPOSSIBLE I
WAS AFRAID TO SLEEP I BECAME
AFRAID OF THE NIGHT. THE SECOND
MY PACK. I CONTINUED QUE.
PRACTICE OF. PROVIDER ALFA TALK
TO HIGH RISK OB AND IS. NO ONE
KNEW WHAT TO DO. TRY IN A
PROPER SLEEP DATA OUR LAB.
BECAUSE HAD. OUT OF POCKET.
TAKE WARM BUT NOT. BATH GO ON
BUT- LEAVE. AS THE DAYS AND
WEEKS AND THEN MONTHS WENT ON I
CONTINUE TO SEEK HELP FROM MORE
PROVIDERS WITH NO LUCK. I GOT
SICKER AND BECAME MORE HELPFUL.
I BEGIN TO DOUBT I'D EVER GET
BETTER. YOU MIGHT. WERE NOT
GAINING WEIGHT AND WE HAVE BEEN.
AFTER MY DD WAS BORN. START
FINALLY AT THIRTY FOUR WEEKS.
MY PROVIDERS FOR THE FIRST TIME
SUGGESTED I GO ON AN ANTI
DEPRESSANT AND EXPLAINED THAT
IT WASN'T WITHOUT REST. I
EXPLAINED THAT I WASN'T
DEPRESSED IN THE CLINICAL SENSE
I WOULD SEPARATE PERSISTENT
PANIC AND ANXIETY AND THEY LOOK
AT EACH OTHER AND IT'S A PLACE
THAT COULD POINT HER. FRANK
WITH IT SO WITH THAT AND I
THINK THEY CARE OF. A HIGH RISK
OB WHO IS GIVING ME AN OFFER ON
HEARD MY STORY THAT I'M SORRY
YOUR THOUGHT. BUT I WOULD BUT
MY WIFE BETTER I WILL PRESS. I
CAN HOLD YET ANOTHER FAMILY
FRIEND A HIGH RISK OB THING
THAT BY KATE CLOSED PLUS I
WOULD NEAR END IN MORE WAYS
THAN. I NOW KNOW THAT MAN
EXACTLY WHAT I NEEDED TO HELP
WITH LIVE AND DIRECT. AB FOR.
HE WAS BORN I GOT ONE. EIGHT
NINE. EIGHT THAT ALL CRAP BACK.
I WAS DOWN TO MY PRE PRESS.
WEIGHT DAYS AFTER GIVING BIRTH
I WAS ON ONE. THE VENTURE I DID
FIND PROVIDER WHO. THE MATERNAL
BUT HEALTH WITH INTO WE I WOULD
ON MEDICAID STILL SAFELY MIGHT
BE AT ALL RHETORIC. IT TOOK
WILL. ACT RESOURCE LIKE THIS
WOULD SAVE ME I'M SO GLAD WE
NOW HAVE PRENATAL. SCREENING
TOOL THREE TWENTY NINETY. BUT
WITHOUT THE EXTRA TO HELP GIVE
THE SITE WITH THE STEP SHOULD
BE WE AN UNFINISHED ROOF. I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE HOW MANY-
BEES AND WOMEN ARE APPOINTMENT
HALL HOPPING TO FIND AN ANSWER
NOW THAT THEY'VE BEEN SCREENED.
I WOULD IT DOESN'T APPOINTMENT
AND ALL THAT NEWARK DOCTOR THAT
PROVIDERS WITH NO ANSWER AT
LEAST KNOW INFORMED ANSWER. OFF
WITH GREAT ALL I WOULD AND
GOING ON A WILD GOOSE CHASE. WE
CANNOT FAIL WOMEN LIKE THAT.
LIKE THE MORE I THINK OF ALL IT
AND POST PARTUM WOMEN DURING
THE DOWN ISOLATED AND THEY GO
THAT OF THEIR VERSUS GOING ON
THEIR OWN WHILE COULD KEEP USED
TO THAT THAT WILL HELP THEM.
AND ONLY GOING TO BE GETTING IN
THE- AND ON CAN. PRENATAL POST
PARTUM MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES. ISOLATION FEET
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. DURING
THE PANDEMIC ESPECIALLY
ISOLATION FEARS OF GETTING ILL
AND THE INABILITY TO ASK OUR
PARENTS FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
FOR HELP ONLY MAKES IT HARDER
FOR PREGNANT AND POSTPARTUM
WOMEN RIGHT NOW. PEOPLE
SUFFERING ANXIETY OR SUFFERING
SO MUCH WORSE SO NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED THIS TOOL I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY WITHOUT HESITATION.
STATING ARE OVERBURDENED HEALTH
SYSTEM MY AND OUR CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF MOTHERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- IS THERE
ANOTHER WITNESS IN THE QUEUE OR
HAVE A WITNESS LISTED DR
VIRGINIA CHANNELS DR VIRGINIA
CHAN IN THE KEY. SHE IS NOT
CURRENTLY LISTED ON THE AUDIO
DOCTOR CHEN IF YOU ARE ON AS A
PARTICIPANT IN ERROR PLEASE
PRESS STAR ZERO FOR AN OPERATOR.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO-
DOES NOT APPEAR SHE'S ON THE
AUDIO OKAY IF SHE COMES BACK
WE'LL GIVE YOU THAT OPPORTUNITY
WILL GO AHEAD ON TO OUR OUR
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM. WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES THERE- STEPHANIE
WALKEN'S AND PRESTON YOUNG SO
PLEASE GO AHEAD IF YOU ARE IN
THE WITNESS UNION. OUR MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEVENTY Y.
CONFIRM HAVE THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES. BUT WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THE BILL AND I UNDERSTAND
THE DESIRE THE DOCTOR HAS TO
ENSURE ALL ENROLLEES IN CHURCH
HAVE IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO CARE.
WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
REQUIREMENT FOR HEALTH PLANS
INSURERS TO HAVE A PSYCHIATRIC
AVAILABLE TO CONSULT WITH A
PHYSICIAN- IS NOT ONLY
CONCERNING WITH RESPECT TO THE
TIMING IN A NOTE. COST
IMPLICATIONS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY AS NOTED BY THE TO
BURKE ANALYSIS. THE LACK OF
EVIDENCE HAT DOES NOT MANDATE
WILL RESULT IN BETTER PATIENT
OUTCOME. AS YOU KNOW WELL I
MEMBERS STRIPED INCORPORATE
EVIDENCE BASED CARE. DO NOT
DIRECTLY ENGAGE IN THE PRACTICE
OF MEDICINE BY THE STILL TAKING
IT DITIONS OR AT. THEM ON HOW
TO ASSESS AND DIAGNOSE THEIR
PAY. I THIS TYPE OF PROBE. AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY PRESUMABLY
CROSSES THAT TO BUY. HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURERS IN THE
POSITION OF DICTATING MEDICAL
PRACTICE. RIGHT AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE BURKE ANNETTE. AT A-
TEENS. DAY AND I'M- BILL IS
HOLDEN APPROACH SHIN BLACK.
FOUND THAT THERE WAS A- AT ON
THE- SITES THE ACTOR DE.
GENERAL IN ADDITION EVIDENCE ON
THE BACK OF YOUNG YOU CONSUL
FOR CHILDREN POST PARTUM FIRST
CHIPPER WHEN ONSEN THERE WAS A
CLAIM AT THE SHOWING THAT
PSYCHE IT CANCELS OUR- IMPROVE
APPROACH TREATMENT OF MENTAL
AND- AS MEASURED BY IN. IN THE
RICH. OF MORE APPROPRIATE CARE
MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
PATIENTS PROVIDER KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILL DEVELOPMENT FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT PROVIDER
SATISFACTION AND TIMELINESS OF
SERVICES. LEAVING US WITH THE
QUESTION GIVEN THE CURRENT
UNCERTAINTY SURROUNDING OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AS WE
COLLECTIVELY FACE THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TOGETHER IS
THIS THE RIGHT TIME TO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL MANDATES ON OUR
SYSTEM. AND IS THIS AN
EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED POLICY
TO PLACE THAT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY BRING ADDITIONAL
VALUE TO PATIENTS WE ARE
SEEKING TO PRIORITIZE.
REGRETTABLY WE DID LEAVE THE
EVIDENCE BASED ANALYSIS SHOWS
THAT IT IS AND FOR THAT REASON
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB.
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU. NEXT
THE WITNESS. YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS PRESSED AND
YOUNG I AM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY- TWO POINTS
I'D LIKE TO MAKE TODAY THE
OVERARCHING CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE AT THIS BILL IS THE FACT
THAT THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CREATION OF A TELEHEALTH
PROGRAM OF THE PASSED ON TO
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES BY. WAY OF
INCREASED PREMIUMS- NOW SOME OF
YOU MAY SEEM THAT COVER
CALIFORNIA RECENTLY CAME OUT
WITH AN ESTIMATE THAT NEXT YEAR
THEY FEEL PREMIUMS COULD RISE
ANYWHERE FROM 4240% DUE TO THE
UNEXPECTED ANUNANTICIPATED
COVERT RELATED EXPENSES THIS
YEAR SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
POTENTIAL INCREASED NEXT YEAR
COMBINED WITH- WHEN ADVERSITY
LATE IN BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT
THAT QUITE FRANKLY I DON'T
THINK. SINCE THE GREAT
DEPRESSION I'M AND SO IF WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A MANDATE SUCH AS
IN LAYER PREMIUM IN A TOP OF
ALREADY INCREASING PREMIUMS AND
SUCH A DIFFICULT BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT IT'S GOING TO MAKE
DOING BUSINESS IN THE STATE
THAT MUCH MORE DEPTH AND NOW-
THE SECOND POINT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS IF PHYSICIANS AND
HEALTH NETWORKS AS WELL AS
MEDICAL GROUPS. HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SPECIALISTS AT THIS TIME-
SO THE BILL WELL IT IS
CERTAINLY WELL INTENTIONED ONE
THAT CERTAINLY IS A PERSONAL IN
MANY REGARDS TO ME IT IS NOT
NECESSARY TIMES WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. TO AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE OTHER
WITNESSES AND THE WITNESS
VIEWING ROOM IN OPPOSITION.
THEY MAY JUST IT'S JUST YOUR
BILL THE STATE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION ONLY AND ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTS. GEN HAMPTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS ALSO RESPECTFULLY
THOSE I THINK YOU. UNDERSTOOD
THERE WAS ONE OTHER IS THAT
WERE MY WERE WE WRONG. THAT'S
IT OKAY OKAY VERY GOOD THANK
YOU- OTHERS ON WE MISS- MISTER
MODERATELY MAY OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
WE JUST NAME AN ORGANIZATION
ONLY. THANK YOU IT'S ONE NINE
ZERO TO SPEAK OUT IN SUPPORT WE
WILL FIRST START WITH THE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE ONE TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE ONE TWENTY NINE CAN
YOU CHECK YOUR LINE FOR SELF
NEED FOR HEARING AUDIO. ACT THE
BYE BYE POLICIES THAT VETERAN
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PAN AT THE
COMPANY I WORK OUR ACT BE ABLE
TO DO IT STERN SUPPORT ABOUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN ONE
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ORIGINALLY FROM THE LIGHT ON
SENATE'S MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
AND MOTHER I AM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE ONE
EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN WE'RE HEARING THE
AUDIO. WILL MOVE ALONG TO LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE ONE
EIGHT FIVE YOU'RE ONE OF THE-
RIGHT CENTER ITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX
ONE EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JULIE MATTER REPRESENTING THE
TIME BURKE INSTITUTE INSTRUCT
THE TALK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
ONE NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
DEBORAH KAUFMANN WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH NOW I'M IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE UP ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RENDON WHICH THE PART
THANK YOU. YOUR LINE SIXTY TWO
SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS ALLEY AT THER TO WITH
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO ONE NINE TWO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ACTUALLY WILL GO
TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE ONE SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI KELLY O'CONNOR CASE
NUMBER TEN O'CLOCK NOW AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO ONE NINE TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI KAREN BASIC
PLAN ALONG FROM MONTEREY PARK
WHO HAS RECOVERED FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH ORDER. THE TERM
ABOUT BUT IT IS A FULL. THANK
YOU. THE LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS
CRITICAL MCCAULEY WITH TWENTY
TWENTY MOM IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO NO
MORE SUPPORT NO MORE
OPPOSITION- BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WILL OF RETURN OF
THE AUTHOR WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE- SOME OPPOSITION REMARKS
HERE THAT I'M CERTAIN THAT THE
AUTHOR YET AGAIN I'M PRESENTING
HAPPENS TO ME CHINESE. IS
STILL- ENGAGING WITH WITH THOSE
GROUPS AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
SO AFTER THIS COMMITTEE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
IS THERE A MOTION I'VE DONE THE
FACT IS THERE A MOTION. I'M
SORRY I HAD A WHO WHO IS THE
WHO MADE THE RIVER MUCH I'M
SORRY. MR SANTIAGO THE IN THE
NEW SECONDED IT SO MISTER BONTA
WILL SECOND IT THEN OKAY I'M
SORRY OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MISSION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOOD I WOULD I. MAYES
AGUIAR-CURRY I GET VERY I'D
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA
AYE BURKE CORREO. FLORA LARA
KNOW LIVE ON. MCCARTY. MCCARTY
I NAZARIAN. WAS IT AYE RAMOS.
RAMOS I READ REGUS RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT ICE. TO
KNOWS BAILEY'S OUT LEAVE THE
BILL OF WILL LEAVE THE ROAD
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU MISTER- MCCARTY MISTER
KALRA THANK YOU I AM. FOR
INDULGING US I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE INCONVENIENCE. YOU HAVE AB
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- IN ORDER
TRACK MARKET TRENDS ON HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS AND
POSTURING AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN REQUIRES HEALTH
INSURERS TO SUBMIT AGGREGATOR
REPORTING FOR PLANS OFFERED IN
THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETS. NOW
MORE THAN EVER REGULATORS AND
POLICY MAKERS NEED A COMPLETE
PICTURE OF OUR STATE'S HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKETPLACE TO SHED
LIGH ON HOW CONSUMERS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE PURCHASE
HEALTH COVERAGE EITHER. ON TOP
OF CALIFORNIA OR OFF EXCHANGE
ON THE OPEN MARKET. GOING TO
HAVE A CALIFORNIA PREMIUM
INCREASES IN THE INDIVIDUAL AND
A POINT IF MARKETS FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. COULD GOOD RANGE UP
240% OR MORE SOLELY BECAUSE A
CALL THE NINETEEN COSTS THE
ABSENCE OF FEDERAL ACTION. AB
TWENTY ONE AGING IS NEW TO
GAUGE HOW CALIFORNIA HEALTH
INSURANCE PURCHASERS AND
INDIVIDUALS SMALL GROUP MARKETS
RESPONDING TO THESE NEW CHANGES
IN PREMIUM NOT SOMETHING I
WOULD GET. TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY OPPOSITION. I'M
OFFERING AMENDMENTS TO DELAY
NEW REPORTING REQUIREMENTS BY
AN ADDITIONAL YEAR. AND ADDRESS
INCONSISTENT DEFINITION TO
WEIGHTED AVERAGE PREMIUM. OVER
NINETEEN EXPECTED TO AFFECT
HEALTH INSURANCE MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND INDIVIDUALS
PURCHASING HEALTH INSURANCE
NEED ASSURANCE. THEY'RE GETTING
VALUE FOR THEIR PREMIUMS. THAT
IS WHY SMALL MAJORITY SUPPORTS
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN. AND
UNDERSTAND. HEALTH INSURANCE
TRANSPARENCY IS CRITICALLY%
IMPORTANT COMBAT AGAINST IRAQI
SKYROCKETING INSURANCE RATES- I
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR OF COURSE
IN HIS STAFF CONTINUES SUPPORT
OF THESE EFFORTS OF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS. TO BRING MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO OUR HEALTH.
INSURANCE MARKETS. PROVIDING
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY BY VIDEO
CONFERENCES AS MEAN PULL THAT
REPRESENTING HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER KALRA WILL GO TO THE
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS YES MEAN
PALETTE OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION. OF
THE SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN. AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN AIMS TO IMPROVE RATE
REPORTING AND BOTH THE
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL BUSINESS
MARKETS WHICH SERVES ABOUT FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. SO THAT WE CAN
GET A GOOD PICTURE OF RATE
INCREASES IN THE INDIVIDUAL AND
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE FACING
BOTH AND COVERED CALIFORNIA AND
TO THE OUTSIDE MARKET OFF
EXCHANGE. IN LIGHT OF THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN MARCH AS
MISTER KALRA ALREADY STATED
COVER CALIFORNIA RELEASED A
REPORT PREDICTING A HEALTHCARE
PREMIUMS COULD RISE AS MUCH AS-
40% IN THE INDIVIDUAL AND
EMPLOYER MARKETS. YOU NEED TO
KNOW IF THE SMALL BUSINESSES
AND SELF EMPLOYED INDIVIDUALS
IN YOUR COMMUNITY. YOUR
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING RATE
INCREASES THAT HIGH OR THEY'LL
GET MORE MODERATE INCREASES AS
WE ALL HOPE. YOU'LL HEAR FROM
THE HEALTH PLANS TODAY THAT
BECAUSE OF CLUB IN NINETEEN
THIS ADDITIONAL REPORTING WILL
BE BURDENSOME TO THEM. WITH
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS LOSING
THEIR JOBS AND THEIR. FOR THEIR
JOB BASED HEALTH COVERAGE. WE
BE TRIED HOW THIS IS IN GRAY
AND YOU'RE YEARS. WE OFFERED ME
A MAN IN ANALYSIS. IN RESPONSE
TO THOSE CONCERNS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM. AS
CALIFORNIA WORKS TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY AND COST
CONTAINMENT AND HEALTH
INSURANCE WE ARE STILL BLIND TO
KEY INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
COVERAGE PEOPLE HAVE. THANK YOU
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
MODERATOR YOU MAY OPEN THE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FOR OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. IF YOU
WISH TO VOICE SUPPORT THE BILL
IN A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINEONE TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND ONE TWENTY NINE WE
ARE HEARING THE AUDIO YOU CHECK
YOUR LINE FOR SELF MEANS. WELL
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS
ENTER THE TREND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN I THINK HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE SIX FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TEN FORTY ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FOUR TWO ZERO FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT BACK IN
DOLLARS NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
ONE FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO AND EIGHTY S. ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NOT ONLY THAT ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA CHRONIC
CARE COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN
TWO ZERO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HILLARY LEVER. IMPAIR
DIEGO UNSUPPORTED THE BILL FROM
THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. WE HAVE
EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
NOTICE UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THE
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GENERAL WOULD MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEFF HAND HOW
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS RIDLEY HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL TODAY UNLESS AS
AMENDED. I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL FOR TRYING TO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS RELATED TO
THE BILL. I WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR TO LINK THE NEW
ROARED REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
LAID OUT IN THIS BILL. TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WE ARE
STILL CONCERNED THAT THE
MAJORITY OF PROVISIONS IN THIS
BILL STILL BE IMPLEMENTED ON
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THERE ARE VARIOUS FACTORS AND
CONSIDERATIONS THAT GO INTO THE
RATE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND
MANY OF THESE FACTORS HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTERED WERE
IMPACTED BY THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC. WHICH MAKING JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IMPLEMENTATION DATE INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING. PACIFIC LATE IT IS
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT HEALTH PLAN
RATE FILINGS ARE DONE PROST
ACTIVELY. PLANTS ARE PREPARING
TO SUBMIT THEIR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE RATES IN THE NEXT MONTH.
AND IT HAD TO ESTIMATE THE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC.
ESTIMATE THE IMPACT THAT THIS
PANDEMIC WILL HAVE ON FUTURE
RATES. ADDING TO THIS
COMPLEXITY PLANTS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUCTED BY COVER CALIFORNIA
pTO SUBMIT TWO DIFFERENT SETS OF
RATES FOR THIS YEAR'S RATE
FILING TO CAPTURE THE POTENTIAL
IMPACTS THE PANDEMIC MAY HAVE
IN THE FUTURE. FURTHERMORE
PLANT WILL BE SUBMITTING THEIR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE RATES. WITH
THE CURRENT SPECIAL ENROLLMENT
PERIOD STILL ON. WHICH WILL
UNDER. COME THE RATE
DEVELOPMENT. IN THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. AS PLANS START TO START
THE RATE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO RATES
THIS FALL WE BELIEVE THAT THE
FULL REPERCUSSIONS OF THE
PANDEMIC ON THE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM WILL NOT HAVE
BEEN FULLY REALIZED.
CONSIDERING THIS WE BELIEVE
THAT DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THIS BILL
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE- WILL
ALLOW STAKEHOLDERS THE TIME
NECESSARY TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND
FURTHERMORE WILL ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE TO OBTAIN AND ANALYZE
MORE TYPICAL DATA SUBMISSIONS
FOR A DEVELOPMENT. LASTLY WE
ARE ALSO CONCERNED AS SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL
UNNECESSARILY MODELS PER
INDUSTRY STANDARDS. AND WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AUTHORS ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS SPECIFICALLY REGARDING
THE WEIGHTED AVERAGE PREMIUM
DEFINITION INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL. THE DEFINITION IS STILL
IN CONSISTENT TO THE CURRENT
INDUSTRY PRACTICE. WE BELIEVE
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT. FOR THE
REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED IN THIS
BILL TO BE CONSISTENT AND
STANDARDIZED INSURING A BROADER
UNDERSTANDING AMONG HEALTH
PLANS STAKEHOLDERS AND
REGULATORS. I WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE OFTEN
THE SPONSORS IS JUST AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SEVENTY
WALKING FROM BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES-
WE'D ALSO LIKE TO ECHO MANY OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AS WELL AS
ENSURING THAT THAT- TERMINOLOGY
USED IT'S CONSISTENT WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSOR THEY HAVE HAD AN
OPEN DIALOGUE WITH US
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS. WE
THINK GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT'S
GOING ON WITH THE PANDEMIC AND
ALL THE DIFFICULTY THAT ALL OF
OUR MEMBERS SHARE ALONG WITH
THE PUBLIC ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THE INFORMATION PROVIDED
IS ACCURATE AND THOUGHTFUL WE
THINK IT'S IN OUR BEST INTEREST
TO WITH TO DELAY THE EFFECTIVE
DATE FOR THE BILL IN ITS
ENTIRETY TO. TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE AS WELL TO WORK TOGETHER
ALONG WITH THE REGULATORS TO
ENSURE THAT THE TERMINOLOGY
THAT'S USED IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH THEIR INTERPRETATION AND
THAT ALL THE IN POINT POINTS
ARE. BROUGHT UNDERSTANDING ALL
OF THOSE DIFFERENT PIECES SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE RAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR THE
BILL. FOR TAX. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINES FOR OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION FOR JUST THEIR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE. IF YOU
IF YOU WISH TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE THAT JUST CUTE UP
PLEASE ALLOW MOMENT TRUSTEE OF
OUR LINE NUMBER. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR AND MARK HURLBERT SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY APOLOGY I WAS
NOT IN THE QUEUE I'M ACTUALLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
APOLOGIES FOR BEING WRONG QUEUE
AGAIN MARK HURLBERT WITH SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SCENE NUMBER TECH CLOSE MISTER
KALRA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ALBUMS HERE. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER SANTIAGO A SECOND BY
MISTER BONTA. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUT. AS DO PASS AS AMENDED YEAH.
AB TWO ONE ONE EIGHT MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOOD HI WOULD I
MAYES. MAYES NO AGUILAR CURRY
ARE YOUR CURRY II BIGELOW
BIGELOW NO BONTA. BONTA I BURKE
BURKE I RIO. FLORA FLORA NO
LIMóN. MCCARTY MCCARTY I'D
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON.
BILL IS NINE I KNOWS THREE BILL
IS OUT OF HIS CAR REALLY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
WILL MOVE ON TO AB NINETEEN
THIRTY EIGHT MR LOW PLEASE COME
FOR MISTER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN. THIRTY
EIGHT- WITH RESPECT TO A
PRESCRIPTION DISCOUNT OF
PROGRAMS- THIS IS- VERY MUCH OF
IT I TRANSPARENCY. EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING WITH RECEIVING
FEDERAL PUBLIC TAXPAYER DOLLARS
ARE UTILIZED FOR THOSE DIRECT
PURPOSES WITH RESPECT TO HEALTH
CARE SERVICES UNFORTUNATELY IS
SUCH THAT THERE ARE ENTITIES-
TO WHICH THEY ARE UTILIZING
FAIRLY IN PUBLIC TAXPAYER
DOLLARS DIRECTED TOWARDS.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES INTENDED
FOR THE SERVICES UTILIZED IN
POLITICAL FASHIONS AND NOT
DOING SO IN A TRANSPARENT WAY-
SIMILARLY THERE OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE ALSO
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT OF MEMBERS
OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY. THIS IS
PART OF THE NOTION TO WHICH
OFTENTIMES MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS TO HAVE FRANK
CONVERSATIONS AND HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE- THE BILL
IS CO AUTHORED BY. FORMER LGBT
CAUCUS CHAIR'S WIENER EIGHTEEN
AND MYSELF- BECAUSE THERE ARE
ENTITIES THAT ARE AGAIN USING
PUBLIC TAXPAYER DOLLARS
INTENDED FOR HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR DOING POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES AND MEMBERS WHAT
TYPE OF POLITICAL ACTIVITIES AM
I REFERRING TO. THERE'VE BEEN
NOTED POLITICAL ADS REFERENCING
SPECIFICALLY MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE FOCUSED ON REMOVING
NECK ROSE IN A PARTICULAR CITY
REFERENCED AS THE URBAN RENEWAL
MEANS NECRO. REMOVAL NOW WHAT
ASSOCIATED NOTION OF FEDERALLY
TAX KELLY GIVEN PUBLIC TAXPAYER
DOLLARS INTENDED WITH MEDICARE
UTILIZED IN POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENT. ON A NON
ASSOCIATED IMPACT- THIS IS WHAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOCUS ON THE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS CODE CRISIS ON
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
PUBLIC TAXPAYER DOLLARS FUNDED
DIRECTLY TOWARDS HEALTHCARE. TO
THAT INTENDED SERVICE SO AGAIN
MA'AM THIS IS A TREND MAY. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ABIDE BY THE
SAME TYPE OF REGULATIONS IN
PLACE AND IF IT ENTITY. SO
DESIRES TO UTILIZE THEIR FREE
SPEECH TO ATTACK MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. PUBLIC OFFICIALS.
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS THAT'S
THEIR- RIGHT THAT IS THEIR
RIGHT BUT YOU SHOULD NOT BE
DOING SO WHEN I RECEIVING
CONTRACTS. FEDERAL CONTRACTS.
WITH PUBLIC DOLLARS INTENDED.
FOR HEALTH CARE SERVICES I
MEMBERS THAT IS THE BILL AT
HAND- TRANSPARENCY MEASURE I
GIVES ME NO DELIGHTS INTRODUCED
THIS BILL BY SIMILARLY- WE MUST
HAVE FRANK CONVERSATIONS WHEN
THERE ARE FLAGRANT ABUSES IN
OUR COMMUNITY WE NEED TO HOLD
OUR OWN ACCOUNTABLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I. THANK
YOU MISTER LOWE WE HAVE WITNESS
WE HAVE A WITNESS IN THE
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM I BELIEVE.
AS PART OF THIS BILL IN SUPPORT.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN. I THIS IS
DEBORAH CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT FIFTY
THOUSAND OWNERS AND MANAGERS-
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAS A STATEWIDE
HOUSING SHORTAGE OF NEARLY
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION UNITS
ADEQUATE HOUSING AND HEALTH
CARE OR TWO VERY IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS IN OUR SOCIETY. THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
STRETCHED THE STATE'S HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM TO ITS LIMITS
MAKING IT EVEN MORE IMPERATIVE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH CARE DOLLARS
IN THE STATE TO BE SPENT NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE ON HEALTH
CARE. THESE DOLLARS SHOULD GO
TO PATIENTS NOT SPENT. TO
INFLUENCE OR FIND LOCAL STATE
BALLOT MEASURES WERE UNRELATED
LITIGATION. THAT EXACERBATES
THE STATE'S CONTINUING HEALTH
CRISIS AND HOUSING CRISIS
UNFORTUNATELY THERE HAVE BEEN
DOCUMENTED CASES OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS WHERE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
SPENT TO NEGATIVELY AFFECT.
EFFORTS TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA MAKING A BAD PROBLEM
WORSE. IN NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT
INSURES THAT PUBLIC RESOURCES
ARE SPENT FOR THE PURPOSES FOR
WHICH THEY ARE INTENDED IN
ORDER TO DETERMINE THE MOST-
DIFFICULT AND ABUSIVE
SITUATIONS. ANY ENTITY THAT
USES DOLLARS FROM PUBLICLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS TO STOP HOUSING
PRODUCTION IS HARMFUL TO THE
STATE ON GOING HOUSING CRISIS.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A WITNESS ON THE PHONE MR
STABLE HOUSE. YES MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PATRICK
TABLE HOUSE I DON'T EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL PORTABLE HOUSING WHICH
IS MADE UP OF. FOR PROFIT AND
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS LENDERS-
HOUSING TAX CREDIT INVESTMENT
FIRMS ON SITE SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
NEWSOME HAVE EMPHASIZED OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A
NECESSITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND SHOULD BE COMBINED WITH
ADEQUATE HEALTHCARE- THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO
PROVIDE SHELTER FOR THE
HOMELESS AND OTHER FAMILIES
WITHOUT ALSO PROVIDING. SUCH
HOUSEHOLDS WITH A BASIC
HEALTHCARE TO DO LESS THAN IT
IS TO RISK THAT WE FEEL SHORT
OF KEEPING MANY CALIFORNIANS IN
DECENT SHAPE AN ADEQUATE
SHELTER. AB NINE THIRTY EIGHT
WOULD ASSURE THAT SUCH
HEALTHCARE RESOURCES ARE
UTILIZED PERSISTING SENIOR
CITIZENS OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
THE BASIC HEALTHCARE AND
MEDICAL SYSTEM SO THEY NEED. TO
REMAIN HEALTHY AND PRODUCTIVE
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE THE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND PORTABLE
UNITS IN RURAL CALIFORNIA OF
WHICH APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
THOUSAND UNITS WERE FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS ON. SOCIAL SECURITY-
INCOME ALONG THE SENIORS AND
MANY OTHERS IN URBAN
COMMUNITIES RELY ON ON THE
SALABLE THEIR SERVICES-
DISCOUNTED DRUGS THE- FEDERAL
AND STATE PROGRAMS REGRETTABLY
SOME HEALTHCARE. DOLLARS IN
SOME INSTANCES OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS HAVE BEEN UTILIZED IN
SOME MANNER OR ANOTHER TO
PROPOSE RESTRICTIONS ON THE
DEVELOPMENT REPORTABLE HOUSING.
GIVEN THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS FURTHER
EXACERBATED BY CORPORATE
NINETEEN CHECK OUT REGIS AND
MISUSE OF HEALTHCARE PROBLEMS
SHOULD NOT BE PROVIDED
PERMITTED. HEALTHCARE PLAN
SHOULD BE EXPENDED ON
HEALTHCARE NEEDS AS INTENDED
AND NOT ON MATTERS WOULD
OBSTRUCT AND DELAY THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- THAT SHOULD INCLUDE
HEALTH SERVICES. WERE POSSIBLE
THE CALIFORNIA CAL SUPER
PORTABLE. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR IP ON BE NOT THIR EIGHT.
REMOVE ONE MORE POTENTIAL
IMPEDIMENT TO OUR MEMBERS
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE MORE FOR
HOUSING TO CALIFORNIANS THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDER OUR VIEWS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UNDERSTAND
WE HAVE A WITNESS IN THE
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM IN
OPPOSITION BUT I'M SORRY. SHE'S
BUY GOT AHEAD OF MYSELF HANG ON
OTHERS IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
MISTER MODERATOR YOU MAY OPEN
THE LINE FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. JUST THEIR NAME AND
POSITION OF AN ORGANIZATION
ONLY. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
VOICE SUPPORT ON THE AUDIO
PHONE LINE TO ME PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN TO ONE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE OUT OF
REGULAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. IN
SUPPORTING THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ORDER LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR TWO
TWO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
NUMBER FORTY DOLLARS WITH CITY
OF SANTA MONICA IN ORDER EIGHTY
NINE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR NUMBERS CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. HE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY WE'LL
GO ONTO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SIX TWO TWO SIX OUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES SOME OF PARENTS OF
KIDS IN THE GROUP. TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN I. DO NOT AGREE
WITH THIS. OKAY THANK YOU. NO
ONE ELSE MCCUE AT THIS TIME
OKAY NOW WE WILL GO TO THE
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM- FOR A
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN YOU'RE ON BEHALF
OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION- THIS IS A TALE OF
TWO BILLS I'M THE FIRST ONE IF
YOU LIVE READ THE BLACK AND
WHITE OF THE- OF THE BILL YOU
CAN SEE THAT THIS IS A DIRECT
ATTACK ON AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION- WHICH- AIMS TO. GET
ITSELF INVOLVED IN RENT CONTROL
ISSUES BY SPONSORING PROP TEN.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THEY ARE ALL OF OUR OPPONENTS
THE PEOPLE THAT PUT UP EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO TRY AND KEEP
CURRENT LAW RELATIVE TO RENT
CONTROL COMPLEX. ON THE BILL.
INDICATES IN ITS FINDINGS THAT
THERE ARE THERE IS EVIDENCE
THAT THE- THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
RELATIVE TO HF VIOLATING SOME
LAWS RELATIVE TO THE THREE
FORTY B. DRUG PRICING PROGRAM-
WE HAVE ASKED REPEATEDLY FOR
THAT VIDENCE- AND IT IS NOT
BEEN FORTHCOMING. WE HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT WE'VE ACTUALLY
DIRECTED PEOPLE TO ON THE
FEDERAL PERSONAL WEBSITE AS
WELL AS TO MEDI CAL WHICH WE'VE
BEEN AUDITED ON THESE PROGRAMS
AND NOTHING HAS BEEN FOUND ON
TOUR ABOUT ANY. OF THE MONIES
THAT REVIEWS SO WE AGREE
ACTUALLY WITH THE PREMISE OF
THE BILL THAT NOBODY WHO'S
GETTING PUBLIC FUNDS SHOULD USE
THOSE PUBLIC FUNDS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADVOCATING A BALLOT
MEASURE. AND WE DON'T DO THAT-
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT
THIS BILL FROM IF YOUR POLICY
STANDPOINT. IT'S A BAD IDEA TO
CONSIDER WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR PUBLIC FUNDS TO
BE USED IT IS AN APPROPRIATE
HOWEVER TO SINGLE OUT A SINGLE
ORGANIZATION AND SAY THAT THEY
CANNOT DO THIS. IF A BILL WHAT
IF THE BILL WAS AMENDED TO LOOK
AT- AT OTHER THREE FORTY BE
ENTITIES OTHER ENTITIES THAT
HAVE USED PUBLIC FUNDS TO FUND
BALLOT MEASURES AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT DEVELOPERS AND- A
PROPERTY OWNERS AND LANDLORDS
ETCETERA. THEY SHOULD ALSO BE
PROHIBITED BEING ABLE TO USE
PUBLIC FUNDS FOR THESE PURPOSES
IF THAT WAS THE BILL WE WERE
PROBABLY END UP SO. IT BECAUSE
WE THINK THAT'S A GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY IT IS NOT A GOOD PUBLIC
FATHER POLICY. TO PUNISH A
SINGLE ORGANIZATION AGAIN FOR
STEPPING OUT. IN FRONT ON THIS
ISSUE. I'M I WOULD ADD JUST AT
THE- TWO TO CLOSE WITH- THAT
PART OF THE OTHER- POLICY
QUESTION IS WHETHER IT IS EVEN
APPROPRIATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE TO BE CONSIDERING A
BILL. THAT SETS STANDARDS FOR A
FEDERAL PROGRAM. THREE FORTY B.
IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM. I'M THERE
THE STATE HAS NO AUTHORITY ON
TO STEP UP. IN IN- INVESTIGATE
OR SET NOT RAMBLERS AROUND HOW
THE MONEY CAN BE SPENT- SO IT
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE- UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
NOT. AN APPROPRIATE PROGRAM
IT'S ALSO NOT PUBLIC FUNDS IN A
THREE FORTY BPP PROGRAM MOST
PEOPLE DO NOT REALIZE. THAT IT
IS NOT PUBLIC FUNDS IT IS NOT
MEDI CAL FUNDS IS NOT MEDICARE
IT'S NOT FEDERAL FUNDS IT IS
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANY FUNDS
THAT ARE IN THE THREE FORTY PRO.
WE DON'T. ANY WE STRONGLY
EMERGING TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE- MISTER
MODERATOR YOU MAY OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE MINUTE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NOT AT THIS TIME.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER MAYES. IT'S
JUST A QUESTION- I'M TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY- BECAUSE I THINK-
THE POLICY IS RIGHT BUT JUST
WANTED TO GET SOME
CLARIFICATION MAYBE FROM THE
AUTHOR IN REGARDS TO. THIS AT
LEAST FROM THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THIS SEEMING TO BE
NARROWLY TAILORED TOWARDS ONE
PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION BECAUSE
AS A WHOLE I DON'T NECESSARILY
LOVE THAT IS BROAD ENOUGH TO
COVER. ANYBODY THAT WOULD-
WOULD WOULD I USE THE TERM BUT
ABUSE OF THE SYSTEM OR IS IT
ONLY SPECIFICALLY DESIGNATED
TOWARDS OF ONE. ORGANIZATION
THE VERY MUCH OF A THROUGH THE
CHAIR OF VERY MUCH
SPECIFICALLY- OUTLINING AS
NOTED IN THE CAMINO SAYS SOME
KEY PRINCIPLES AND GUIDELINES
TO WHICH TO FOLLOW WE HAVE NOT
SEEN THE FRAGRANT ABUSES. OF
THIS MAGNITUDE OTHER THAN ONE
ORGANISER IT'S HEALTHCARE SO
WE'VE OUTLINED SPECIFIC
CRITERIA OUTLINED AND IT ONLY
APPEARS THAT THIS ONE ENTITY.
IT IS USING THESE TYPE OF
ABUSES AND AGAIN IT IS TO SAY
SUCH THAT THE REVENUES
GENERATED FROM THIS FEDERAL
PROGRAM DIRECTLY- FOCUS ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SHOULD BE
USED AS SUCH AND THE ENTITY
STILL WISHES TO ENGAGE IN THEIR
FREE SPEECH. YOU'RE FREE TO DO
SO BUT NOT IN THE SPECIFIC
RESTRICTED FUNDS. SO WOULD IT
APPLY TO OTHER ORGANIZATIONS OR
OR WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THIS ONE
ORGANIZATION. MY UNDERSTAND
THAT NO OTHER ENTITY IS
ENGAGING IN THIS OTHER TYPE OF
ENGAGEMENT- WITH RESPECT TO THE
DOLLARS IN THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT WERE FOCUSED ON TO WRITE
AS OF NOW WE ARE ONLY AWARE OF.
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AS
THE ONLY OPPOSITION THAT WE
HAVE SEEN- REGISTER NOW BUT IF
THERE WAS IT WOULD APPLY TO
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL NOT
JUST TO THE ONE ORGANIZATION
SURE WE I MEAN USUALLY OPEN TO
THEY CALCULATE ALL ACROSS THE
BOARD THAT IS THAT OF THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT. SO WILL
ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TO ENSURE
THAT IT'S AS EXPANSIVE AS
POSSIBLE NOT JUST TALKING. ONE
ENTITY OKAY THANK YOU. ANYONE
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MR IS AREA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I CREATED A MAKE SHIFT.
COVER SO THAT I COULD SPEAK
INTO THIS AND NOT OVER MY MASK-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
SPOKE TO OUR DEAR COLLEAGUE WHO
HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT
FOR EARLIER THIS MORNING AND I
TOLD HIM HOW DIFFICULT OF A
TIME I'M HAVING BECAUSE ON THE
ONE HAND IT'S A WONDERFUL
TRANSPARENCY BILL WHICH I DO
APPRECIATE I THINK WE ALL NEED
TO- HOTEL ACCOUNT- EVERY
ORGANIZATION THAT PARTNERS WITH
WHETHER THE FEDERAL OR STATE OR
LOCAL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THE DELINEATION OF
THE FUNDS RECEIVED ARE USED FOR
THE APPROPRIATE PURPOSES THAT
WAS INTENDED FOR. AT THE SAME
TIME- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
ORGANIZATION HF THAT IS A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PLUS ANNUALLY
FUNDED ORGANIZATION. HAS A
PRIVATE FOUNDATION ARM. AND HAS
DONE INCREDIBLE WORK OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS- I'VE WORKED WITH THEM
PERSONALLY AS A STAFFER AND AS
AN ELECTED I'VE CARRIED
MULTIPLE BILLS. WORKING WITH
THEM. MOST RECENTLY THEY-
SECURED A BUILDING IN MY
DISTRICT. SEVENTY THREE UNIT
BUILDING AT A COST OF. ALL IN
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
UNIT. TO BE USED FOR HOMELESS
SHELTER PURPOSES. AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF COMBAT HIV
VIRUS WHEN. SOCIALLY A LOT OF
FOLKS WITH DISTANCE THEMSELVES.
FROM THE ISSUE SO IT PAINS ME
GREATLY TO NOT SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE I DO APPRECIATE
THE INTENT BUT AT THE SAME TIME
I'VE PERSONALLY HAD A
RELATIONSHIP IN A WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THIS
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS AND I'VE
SEEN WHAT THEY HAVE TO OFFER
OVER THE YEARS AND BE ATTHE
FOREFRONT AT A TIME WHEN NO ONE
WAS. AT THAT PLACE AND SO- I A-
WOULDN'T WANT TO SEND A
STINKING MESSAGE TO THEM THAT'S
WHY I WILL REFRAIN FROM VOTING-
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF ANY ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WISH TO ASK A QUESTION
A COMMON. CNN WILL BRING IT
BACK TO MISTER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND-
COLLEAGUES- AGAIN VERY MUCH
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
TO HOLD OURSELVES TO A HIGHER
STANDARD IN WHICH WE SEE PUBLIC
TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND ARE
ENROLLED IN PROGRAMS TO WHICH
THERE IS PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES. SPECIFICALLY
DEDICATED FOR THIS PURPOSE. AND
SO WE STILL WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE GREAT WORK OF THE MANY HARD
WORKING INDIVIDUALS OF INTENDED
PURPOSE OF THE ORGANIZATION I
DON'T WANT TO DISCOUNT THAT AND
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT TO
THE AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
AND THE COLLABORATION AND
FOCUSED ON PREVENTION. AND
REALLY DATING THE IMPACT OF
AIDS PARTICULARLY IN THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AS WELL RECOGNIZED.
BUT THIS IS A Y. MENTION THIS
GIVES ME NO GREAT DESIRE TO SAY
THAT WE WANT TO TARGET. A
MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF OUR OWN
COMMUNITY. BUT IT IS ALSO THE
OBLIGATION AND DUTY THE ETHICAL
STANDARDS TO WHICH WE HOLD
OURSELVES TO ACCOUNT AND AGAIN
WHAT IS ACTUALLY OCCURRING. THE
REVENUES GENERATED FROM THIS
PUBLIC PROGRAM IS BEING
UTILIZED AND POLITICAL ADS TO A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE AS AN
EXAMPLE TO SAY THAT A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE DESIRES TO
REMOVE BLACK PEOPLE. FROM THE
COMMUNITY. SPECIFICALLY USING
RESOURCES FROM A PUBLIC PROGRAM
IN A POLITICAL AD STATING. THIS
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
DESIRES TO REMOVE NEGRA. BLACK
PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY.
SIMILARLY THAT SAME
ORGANIZATION SPENT THE SAME
DOLLARS TO ATTACK A MEMBER OF
THIS BODY STATING THAT THIS
MEMBER IS IN THE POCKET OF THE
**** INDUSTRY. NOW I REALLY
TAKE THE QUESTION THEN
ESPECIALLY AND LIMITED
RESOURCES IS THIS THE INTENDED
PURPOSE OF THE REVENUES TO
WHICH WE SHOULD HOLD THIS
PROGRAM IN THIS ENTITY TO
HIGHER STANDARDS IN WHICH YOU.
RECEIVE REVENUES GENERATED FROM
THE PUBLIC INTEREST THAT'S WHAT
THIS CONVERSATIONS ABOUT. WE'RE
NOT DISCOUNTING THE GREAT WORK
IF YOU STILL WISH TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE POLITICAL
PROCESS YOU CAN DO SO BUT NOT
FROM THIS RESTRICTED FUNDS DO
WE STILL WISH TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORTUNATE PASSES COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE ALL
ENCOMPASSING. ABSOLUTELY WE
WILL I WILL ABSOLUTELY COMMIT
TO THAT BUT AGAIN LET US BE
VERY CLEAR ON WHAT THIS BILL IS
DOING IT IS SPECIFICALLY ON
PARTICIPATION OF THIS LIMITED
PROGRAM ON PRESCRIPTION
DISCOUNT. AND THE REVENUES
GENERATED FROM THE PROGRAM
SHOULD NOT BE USED FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES IT SHOULD BE
USED SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
DIRECT HEALTHCARE PURPOSES TO
WHICH THAT OBLIGATION. AND THE
RELATIONSHIP AND I CONTRACTED.
WITH RESPECT TO MEDICARE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
SPECIFICALLY DEPARTMENT HEALTH
AND HEALTH SERVICES. NOT EQUAL
EDUCATION NOT ATTACKING. AND
POLITICAL ENGAGEMENT AND VERY
DEROGATORY WAY- SO AGAIN
MEMBERS THIS IS A TRANSPARENCY
BILL THIS IS SPECIFICALLY
AUTHORED BY MEMBERS OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS FORMER CHAIRS BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO HOLD
OURSELVES TO THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS AND TRANSPARENCY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER LOW. DO I
HEAR A MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY
MISS BURKE- THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AB NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT DO
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD.
WOULD I MAYES MAYES I
AGUIAR-CURRY A YEAR CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW I'D BONTA.
BURKE I TO RIO. THREE OH NOT
VOTING FLORA FLORA I LIVE ALONE
LIMóN I MCCARTY. NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN NOT VOTING. RAMOS
RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO. NINE ICE.
ZERO NO BILL PASSES MR LOVE
BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY MISTER HIS AREA
YOU HAVE TO BILLS ACTUALLY
MISTER NAZARIAN. THIS ONE THE
FIRST ONE IS TWENTY TWO OH
THREE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT. AB TWENTY TWO OR THREE.
WHICH WOULD CAP COPAYS FOR
INSULIN AT FIFTY DOLLARS PER
THIRTY DAY SUPPLY OF INSULIN
AND NO MORE THAN A TOTAL OF A
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN A CALENDAR
MONTH THE COST OF INSULIN FOR
PEOPLE LIVING WITH DIABETES HAS
RISEN DRAMATICALLY OVER THE
YEARS MY BILL AIMS TO HELP THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
NEED INSULIN TO SURVIVE.
ACCORDING TO THE ANNOUNCES BY
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
YOU PROGRAM LOW KNOWN AS
CHIPPER. MY BILL WOULD HELP
THIS BILL WOULD HELP ONE OUT OF
THREE CALIFORNIANS USING
INSULIN. AND WOULD SAVE THEM AN
AVERAGE OF 51% IN OUT OF POCKET
COSTS PER YEAR. BY THE WAY JUST
TO PUT THINGS IN CONTEXT THERE
ARE FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THAT HAVE DIABETES AND TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
TYPE ONE DIABETES ANNUALLY.
THANK YOU- I GET THE HINT OF.
BETTER IT HEARINGS TO INSULIN
REGIMENS IS CRITICAL ESPECIALLY
NOW AMID THE COVERT NINETEEN
EPIDEMIC AND ITS IMPACT ON
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES A RECENT
STUDY SUGGESTS THAT THE DEATH
RATE FROM COVERT NINETEEN IS
FOUR TIMES GREATER FOR THOSE
WITH DIABETES IN A RECENT
ARTICLE BY THE AMERICAN JOURNAL
OF MEDICINE. STATES RESPONSIBLE
MANAGEMENT OF DIABETES REMAINS
IMPERATIVE IF INDIVIDUALS WITH
DIABETES EFFECTIVELY MANAGE
THEIR CONDITION THE RISK OF
GETTING SEVERELY SICK FROM
QUOTED NINETEEN IS ABOUT THE
SAME AS THE GENERAL POPULATION.
SO NOW MORE THAN EVER PEOPLE
LIVING WITH DIABETES NEED OUR
HELP TO LOWER THEIR KOBE SO
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD THIS
LIVING THIS LIFESAVING DRUGS.
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY WILL
TELL YOU THAT MY ILL- WILL
HELP MAKE INSULIN AFFORDABLE.
THAT MIGHT HAVE BILL TO HELP
MAKE INSULIN AFFORDABLE WILL
MAKE INSURANCE PREMIUM
SKYROCKET BUT THE CHIPPER
ANALYSIS ESTIMATES THAT TOTAL
PREMIUMS FOR PRIVATE EMPLOYERS
PURCHASING GROUP HEALTH
INSURANCE WOULD INCREASE BY
ONLY POINT- 002% IN FACT THE
JOB ANALYSIS FOUND THE BILL
WILL HAVE ZERO IMPACT ON
CALPERS BECAUSE HMO PRODUCTS
OFFERED BY CALPERS ALREADY HAVE
COPAYS AT FIFTY DOLLARS OR
LESS- WITH US ON THE PHONE IS
DOCTOR FRANCISCO PIETRO WITH
THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION WIFE- HAD THE HONOR
OF BUT PARTNERING TO PRESENT
THIS BILL- AND ALSO MICHELLE
LIEU OF A- HEALTH TRUST. WHO
WILL ALSO TESTIFY AND MISTER
CHAIR MY APOLOGIES BUT I DO
ACCEPT THE FOR AMENDMENTS. THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD AND I'M
HAPPY TO. ENUMERATE THEM- WHAT
IS THE CO AUTHORSHIP ONE IS THE
AUTHORIZING THE AG TO
INVESTIGATE INSULIN PRICING AND
REPORT FINDINGS BY NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THESE REPORTS
WILL CONSIDER THE ROLE OF EACH
ENTITY. IN THE ENTIRE SUPPLY
CHAIN TENSER CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND PRICING OF
PRESCRIPTION INSULIN INSULIN
DRUGS AND DETERMINE WHETHER
ADDITIONAL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
ARE NEEDED. THIRD ADDITIONALLY
IT SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT A
PERSON OR BUSINESS SUBJECT TO
THE SUBDIVISION SHALL NOT BE
COMPELLED TO REVEAL INFORMATION
THAT IS TYPICALLY CONSIDERED A
TRADE SECRET OR PROPRIETARY
BUSINESS AND FOR INFORMATION
AND FINALLY. SUNSETS THIS BILL
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR CONSISTENT WITH THE SUN
SETS IN THE KOBE CAPS IN
EXISTING LAW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU TO YOUR
COMMITTEE ON YOUR WORK. WITH ME
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER IS ERIN WILL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING- MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
FRANCISCO PRE WELL I'M VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION I'M- A LONGTIME
VOLUNTEER I'M ALSO A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN PRACTICING IN THE
PATIENTS WITH DIABETES. AND AM
THE VICE CHAIR OF THE ABA'S
NATIONAL THAT BECAUSE WE
COMMITTEE. THE EIGHTY EIGHT OF
THE- COPAYS WHAT THE- THAT WAS
A COOL IN CALL ALL A YEAR AGO
AND IN FACT. EIGHT OTHER STATE
WHO THIS BUDGET. INCLUDING
ILLINOIS MAIN MACS NEW USED
PROPERTY. WASHING AND WHAT
VIRGINIA. IN TWO THE
LEGISLATURE INTRODUCED IN THE
THIRTY CAN WE'RE HOPING THAT
CAL WILL BE THE TENTH WHO WHO
THIS. L. A MEMBER TO JERRY
MENTION MAKING SURE THE PEOPLE
BY AFTER IN ONE IS CRITICAL. IT
A RATIONING DOES OF WE SEEN ON.
VERY FREQUENTLY PUT PEOPLE AT
HIGHER RISK FOR ALL COMPLICATE.
AND DEATH FROM HIGH SUGAR. VERY
QUICK EVEN THE FOR NET BUT LIKE
THIS ONE. DURING THIS. IF EVEN
MORE CORE THAN EVER TO KEEP
WITH DIABETES HEALTHY AND OUT
OF THE ARTS OF. BECAUSE IF THEY
CAN THE CREW. ALTHOUGH THEY ARE
AT THE SAME OF GETTING THE
DISEASE THEY ARE MUCH INCREASED
OF HELP COMP. AND DEATH. AND
EVERY THREE IN YOUR DIED KIND
AND TECH OF THE IN STAY OR
ELEVEN HUNDRED PATIENTS. BROWN
A GREATER THAN FOR. GREATER
RISK OF DEATH. DIABETES AND IT
WAS THE MOST PROMINENT
COMORBIDITY FOUND- IN THOSE WHO
AT THIS BAD OUTCOME. IN
ADDITION THE KEEPING PEOPLE
WITH DIABETES OUT OF RUMORED TO
TWO ROOMS AND OUT OF HOSPITALS
MEANS THAT WE MAINTAIN OUR
HEALTHCARE CAPACITY AND KEEP
OUR PROVIDERS ABLE TO
CONCENTRATE ON TREATING THE
PATIENTS COPE WITH NINETEEN.
RATIONING AND SKIPPING DOSES OF
INSULIN IS A GROWING PROBLEM ON
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES THE EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUND THAT ONE IN FOUR
INSULIN USERS HAVE REPORTED
THAT THEY WERE IMPACTED BY THE
COST WITH MEDICATION. 32%
REPORTED HAVING TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THEIR INSULIN THE
UTILITIES- ABOUT UP FOR THAT
THEY- LEFT INFORMED AND WAS
PRESCRIBED. OR MS JONES IS
WEEKLY BECAUSE OF INABILITY TO
AFFORD THIS. I CALIFORNIA WITH
THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITH DIABETES HAVE TO ACT
PROVIDES SOME REALLY AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE- BALL TO. BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY OUR NEXT WHICH
WITNESS MACHEL LOOP. ALSO ON
THE PHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISS
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHELLE LEE WHEN I'M
THE CEO IF THE HEALTH TRACK.
THE HEALTH TRUST IS A NONPROFIT
OPERATING FOUNDATION FOCUSED ON
BUILDING HEALTH EQUITY IN
SILICON VALLEY WE PROVIDE
DIABETES SELF MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS TO LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS IN ADDITION TO AN
ARRAY OF OTHER SERVICES. WE
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMAN THIS
AREA AND FOR CARRYING AB TWENTY
TWO OR THREE AND ARE PLEASED TO
CO SPONSOR THIS BILL. WHICH
WILL MAKE INSULIN MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR NEARLY ONE THIRD
OF THOSE DIAGNOSED WITH
DIABETES AND CALIFORNIA. AB
TWENTY TWO OR THREE PROVIDES A
REASONABLE COST EFFECTIVE
APPROACH FOR ADDRESSING THE
SOCIO ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
DIABETES. AND WILL IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS BY CAPPING OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR COPAYS. IN OUR
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA WE SEE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT OF
DIABETES ON SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS FOR EXAMPLE
DIABETES RATES FOR LATINOS ARE
TWICE THE RATE OF NON LATINO
WHITE. DIABETES IS ALSO A
THREAT TO THOSE INNER AGING
COMMUNITY WITH 25% OF THOSE
OVER SIXTY DIAGNOSED WITH
DIABETES. AND DIABETES IS THE
SIXTH LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. ACCORDING
TO A STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE
JOURNAL OF THE AMERICAN MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. NEARLY 26% OF
DIABETICS WHO ARE PRESCRIBED
INSULIN REPORTED COST RELATED
UNDER USE. LEADING TO POOR
GLYCEMIC CONTROL AND POTENTIAL
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS INCLUDE
HEART DISEASE STROKE AMPUTATION
END STAGE KIDNEY DISEASE
BLINDNESS AND EVEN DEATH. THESE
COMPLICATIONS OFTEN LEAD TO
HIGHER COSTS FOR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. INSULIN RATIONING IS
COMMON FOR LOWER INCOME
PATIENTS WHO ARE OFTEN FACED
WITH THE DECISION TO PURCHASE
LIFESAVING MEDICATION OR TO PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES PAY THE RENT OR PAY
THE UTILITIES BILL. AS YOU'VE
HEARD COPING NINETEEN HAS
EXACERBATED ARE CONCERNED FOR
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES AS THEY
ARE AT HIGHER RISK FOR SERIOUS
COMPLICATIONS. AS YOU HEARD
FROM THE AUTHOR PEOPLE WITH
DIABETES ARE FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE FROM COPE IN
NINETEEN. FURTHERMORE AS AN
EMPLOYMENT STORES MANY HELPFUL-
LOSING JOBS AND ALSO HEALTH
INSURANCE WE FEAR MORE PEOPLE
MAY RESORT TO INSULIN RATIONING
DURING THESE CHALLENGING TIME.
DOZENS OF OTHER STATES HAVE
INTRODUCED- PASSED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION WE KNOW THAT IN
COLORADO THE FIRST STATE TO
PASS SOMEWHAT SIMILAR
LEGISLATION THERE HAS NOT BEEN
A PRICE INCREASE IN PREMIUM.
THE HOTTEST INCREASES YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWENTY TWO OH THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
YOU MAY OPEN THE LINES. IF YOU
WISH TO VOICE SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER.
STAY HERE WE GO I NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT TWO ZERO
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
CENTER WITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE WILL BE OBGYN AND THE
CALIFORNIA. MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELL NOW THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT TWO TWO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHRISTIAN
VIERI REPRESENTED AMERICAN
PARTICIPATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LINE TWO THREE
ZERO TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS HILARY
RESERVE FROM FEAR THE A GOLF I
AM A PERSON WHO HAS TYPE ONE
DIABETES AND DEPEND ON INSULIN
TO STAY ALIVE. I THANK YOU FOR
OUR COUNTRY- SOMETHING THAT IS
VERY AND FOR HAVING THAT DOWN
AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE REPORT
IT AS A GROUP. THANK YOU JUST
REMIND WITNESSES JUST YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION PLEASE
AND YOUR POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX TWO THREE SIX OR ONE
IS OPEN. BUT I'LL LEAVE THE
BALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY
ANDERSON WITH THE ARK AND
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY
CALIFORNIA COOPERATE IN FORT.
THANK YOU. THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE TWO THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWO
THIRTY FIVE CHECK YOUR LINE FOR
SELF ME PLEASE. KATHERINE HI
BUT COMMUNITY HEALTH
PARTNERSHIP PERCENT CLEARANCE
AND THE TAIL COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. A LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SEVEN TWO THREE
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I YEAH
HI LYDIA BORN WITH THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THAT AND
SECURE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MOVING ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM. MR
WINDOWS AND I BELIEVE ALSO-
WITH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS AND ALSO PRESTIN
YOUNG CAL CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
LOUISA'S WITH A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY TWO ZERO THREE.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY
INSTITUTED BY LAW A DRUG COPAY
CAP THAT APPLIES TO ALL
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. NEW LAWS A
CREATE DIFFERENTIAL TREATMENT
OF SPECIFIC DRUGS ARE BAD
PUBLIC POLICY FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS. ONE DAY INCREASE
CONSUMER PREMIUMS ARE
PARTICULARLY AT A BAD TIME- IT
IN THIS CASE THIS BILL INCREASE
THE PREMIUMS IN THE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE MARKET BY OVER TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. TO THE
DIRECTLY INTERFERE WITH HEALTH
PLAN BENEFIT DESIGNS IN A WAY
THAT COULD LEAD TO OUT OF
POCKET INCREASES FOR OTHER
SERVICES. THREE THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT OR LIMITED
RESEARCH AT BEST TO SUPPORT
CLAIMS THAT THIS APPROACH WOULD
RESULT IN MORE IT HERE IT'S
TAKING INSULIN OR THAT THEY
WOULD BE BETTER OUTCOMES AND BE
INDEPENDENT SUBURBAN ALICE'S-
GOES INTO DETAIL ON THIS- AND
LASTLY THE DO NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING PRICE
THAT DRUG COMPANIES CHARGE FOR
THEIR DRUGS. ON INDEED THEY
COULD MAKE THAT PROBLEM HARDER
TO CONTROL. AND BUT WE DO WHAT
ONE WOULD KNOWLEDGE THE-
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
LEAST INTENDED TO ADDRESS ON
THAT PARTICULAR POINT BUT WE
BACKGROUND HEALTH PLANS TO PAY
FOR THE VAST MAJORITY OF COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MOST
EXPENSIVE DRUGS. ACCORDING TO A
REPORT ISSUED UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S GROUNDBREAKING
TRANSPARENCY LAW SB SEVENTEEN
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN. HEALTH
PLANS PAY 92% OF THE COST OF
THE TWENTY FIVE MOST COSTLY
DRUGS ACROSS ALL CATEGORIES. ON
BY LAW BENEFIT DESIGN PREMIUMS
CANNOT CHANGE MID POLICY YEAR
THE US OF A PERSON'S OUT OF
POCKET COSTS CHANGES IT IS
BECAUSE THE UNDERLYING PRICE
CHARGED BY THE MANUFACTURER HAS
GONE UP. ON IN ON THIS FRONT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE SOME DISTURBING
TRENDS SOME OF THOSE ARE
OUTLINED IN YOUR ANALYSIS SO-
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
GO OVER ALL OF THOSE. BUT ON
THE INULIN FRONT IN PARTICULAR
PRICES HAVE NOT SLOWED ON
DESPITE PUBLIC OUTCRY. RICE
BIKES IN THE INCREASING DEMAND
FOR INSULIN HAVE A DIRECT
IMPACT ON THE AFFORDABILITY OF
PREMIUMS. REGRETTABLY THIS BILL
IS INTRODUCED DOES NOTHING TO
TEMPER THE RAPID DRUG INCREASES
IMPLEMENTED- BY- SOME OF THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THESE DRUGS.
NOW WE DO STRONGLY BELIEVE IT
AND IT'S VERY OBVIOUS THAT
INSULIN IS A CRUCIAL TREATMENT
FOR MILLIONS. AND HEALTH PLAN
CERTAINLY SYMPATHIZE. WITH
THOSE A REPLY PROMISE AND
IMPORTANT TREATMENT OF MANY OF
OUR PLANS HAVE IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES TO HELP IN
RELEASE DO WHAT THE COST AND WE
HAVE ALSO SUPPORTED COMMONSENSE
PUBLIC POLICY APPROACHES- SB
SEVENTEEN FOR INSTANCE ARE WE
AS WE MENTIONED EARLIER IS. IS
PROVIDING GREATER TRANSPARENCY.
BUT IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE
BEST VALUE OF THIS LAW ALL
MANUFACTURERS OF FALL INTO THE
LONG NEED TO PARTICIPATE SO-
BILLS THAT INTERFERE WITH THE
MARKETING INSTITUTE STRICT
PRICE CONTROLS IS THIS BILL
DOES WHAT UNDER FIRE. UNDERMINE
OUR EFFORTS MANAGE POTS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS HERE IS TO THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER SHARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESTON YOUNG
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY TWO OR THREE- THE BILL
CERTAINLY ADDRESSES A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM BUT IN
UNFORTUNATELY CREATES ANOTHER
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND THAT IS THE
FACT THAT INSULIN CAPS LAID OUT
IN TWENTY TWO OR THREE WILL
INCREASE PREMIUMS FOR-
EMPLOYERS. IN RELATION TO THE
HEALTH CARE BENEFITS KNOWS
MISTER LOUISE US ALLUDED TO THE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE MARKET
WILL EXPERIENCE PREMIUM
INCREASES IN APPROXIMATELY-
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS OF VALUE
THE TRIP URBAN ALICE'S
INDICATED THAT THE EMPLOYER
PREMIUMS WILL INCREASE AROUND
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS- AS I ALLUDED TO
EARLIER IN THE PREVIOUS BILL
COVER CALIFORNIA ESTIMATES THAT
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
PREMIUMS WILL INCREASE ANYWHERE
4440% IN RELATION TO THE
UNEXPECTED COVERT RELATED
EXPENSES THAT WE- EXPERIENCED
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. NOW IS
THE TIME WHEN BUSINESSES ARE
JUST TRYING TO STAY AFLOAT IN.
THE TO BOURBON ALICE'S
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT SMALL
EMPLOYERS WILL EXPERIENCE THESE
PREMIUM INCREASES AT A RATE
HIGHER THAN ANY OTHER
EMPLOYMENT SEGMENT. SO BETWEEN
THE PANDEMIC ISSUES AND RISING
PREMIUMS NOW IS AN
INAPPROPRIATE INOPPORTUNE TIME
TO VOLITIONAL A LATER MORE
EXPENSES ON BUSINESSES THAT
ARE. SIMPLY TRYING TO WEATHER
THE STORM AND GET THROUGH THIS
TIME- THE SECOND POINT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE THE REASON AMENDMENTS
THAT CAME OUT LAST NIGHT AND I
REVIEWED THIS MORNING. START
ADDRESSING MORE PERVASIVE ISSUE
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THEM AND
THAT'S THE FACT THAT THERE'S A
LACK OF COMPETITION IN THE
INSULIN MARKET. AND SO WHILE
THE MANDATE WILL SAVE MONEY FOR
SOME ON THE FRONT AND IT'S
GOING TO INCREASE EXPENSES FOR
ALL INSURANCE ON THE BACK AND-
IN IT UNFORTUNATELY WILL NOT
ADDRESS THE DEEPER MORE
PERVASIVE ISSUE. THAT IS
CAUSING THE INSTANT PRICES TO
RISE. SO IT IS IT WITH THESE
POINTS IN MIND THAT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AB TWENTY
TWO OR THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS A ME TOO
WHEN THE- WITNESS VIEWING ROOM.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SEVENTY
WHAT COMES ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
NOT POSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER MODERATOR ANY
BUDDY IN OPPOSITION AND THE
PHONE LINES YOU MAY OPEN THE
LINES. IF YOU WISH TO- SHOW
YOUR OPPOSITION YOU MAY DO SO
BY COMING UP WITH ONE ZERO
COMMAND. WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR TWO FOUR
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LAUREN SICK I'M A PERSON WITH
TYPE ONE DIABETES AND I OPPOSE
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
THANK YOU. MODEL LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR TWO
THREE FOUR. YEAH BUT MEMBERS-
MISTER MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON
THE AMERICAN HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER FLORA. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
CONFIRM THAT TO THE AUTHOR.
THAT THIS BILL ONLY HAS TO DO
WITH INSULIN AND DOES NOT
AFFECT ANY OTHER DRUGS. THAT'S
CORRECT THE ONLY OUR STUDENTS
ON. YES THANK YOU. MR MAYES.
WELL THEN I'M GONNA FOLLOW UP
TO THAT- SO AS MISS LOUISA SAID
HAD TALKED ABOUT HIS TESTIMONY
AT THAT THERE'S ALREADY A CAP
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS ON
ALL DRUGS SO WHY INSULIN WASH
INSULIN ONLY BE CAP TWO HUNDRED
AND IS THERE IT IS SHOULD WE BE
LOOKING AT OTHER DRUGS AS WELL
TO BE ABLE TO CAP- OR DO WE
NEED IT AS A AS A COMMITTEE BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY- BEING A BEING TOO HIGH
SO WHY INSULIN. I WOULD LOVE TO
ENUMERATE THE REASONS BY THE
WAY AND MISTER CHAIR IF YOU
DON'T MIND I IF THE TECHNOLOGY
ALLOWS I'M HAPPY TO HAVE DOCTOR
PEER TO ALSO- CHIME IN OR MISS
LOU TO CHIME IN ON ANSWERING
THIS ON A MORE TECHNICAL BASIS
BUT JUST SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF POINTS OF A COUPLE OF
POINTS AT LEAST A I'D BE VERY
PROUD TO WORK WITH YOU NEXT
YEAR ON DOING THIS ON MANY
OTHER DRUGS SO IF YOU'RE UP FOR
IT I'M I'M HAPPY I WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY- WHEN I WORKED
STARTED WORKING ON THIS BILL
LAST ON THIS ISSUE VERY LAST
YEAR WITH WITH EIGHTY A
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS BILL. UP
PART OF THE REASON WHY I WANTED
TO DELVE INTO THIS WAS JUST
BECAUSE OF THE OVERWHELMING
EXPENSE AND COST TO THE STATE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BETWEEN TWO
CONDITIONS DIABETES AND OF
HEART RELATED CORNER RELATED
ISSUES HEART DISEASE- THOSE
COSTS ARE ASTRONOMICAL ON THE
STATE'S THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLAR HEALTH
CARE BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE
DOLLARS ALL IN SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE PERCENTAGES OF HOW MUCH
OF A DENT YOU CAN MAKE IN
CUTTING COSTS FOR- EVERYDAY
CALIFORNIANS FOUR MILLION OF
THEM BEING IMPACTED BY
DIABETES. THIS WAS A GREAT
START. AND LOOKING AT HOW TO
CONTAIN THOSE COSTS AND BE ABLE
TO MAKE PEOPLE HOLD ON TO THEIR
DOLLARS AND TO USE IT FOR
BETTER FOR OTHER PURPOSES. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT POLLING DATA THAT
SHOWS YOU THAT 26% OF THE
RESPONDENTS. RESPONDENTS ARE
MAKING A DECISION BETWEEN
WHETHER OR NOT TO YOU PAY FOR
INSULIN OR PAY FOR THEIR
UTILITIES OR FOR THEIR RENT. OR
FOR CHILD CARE THEN IT GETS
INTO MORE SEVERE AND PERSONAL
CIRCUMSTANCES SO I I'M HAPPY TO
ENUMERATE THE VARIOUS REASONS
WHY I FELT. GOING FORWARD AT
LEAST ADDRESSING THIS ONE ISSUE
AND BY THE WAY LAST BUT NOT
LEAST LET'S ALSO NOT FORGET
NOTHING HAS CHANGED IN THIS
DRUG. MAKE UP. NOTHING IN THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS. JUST THE
COST HAS GONE UP. SO UP IF MR
PLO OR ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE
TO CHIME IN MISTER CHAIR AT AT.
YOUR DIRECTION. OUR WITNESSES
IN. SUPPORT DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS TO ADD TO. MISTER IS
THERE AND I THINK HE DID A
REALLY NICE JOB OF PRESENTING
THAT. YEAH THIS IS DOCTOR PRE
UP FOR CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
YEAH SORRY YEAH I A ALSO WOULD-
ECHO WHAT MEMBERS VERY UPSET
AND JUST ADD A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS. INSULIN WAS
DISCOVERED BY DOCTORS TING
AND BEST ALMOST ONE HUNDRED
YEARS AGO IN NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE AT THE TIME. THEY
EXPLICITLY MADE THE DECISION TO
GIVE THEIR DISCOVERY- CHARGING
ONE DOLLAR FOR THE PATENT TO
BECAUSE THEY FELT. THIS
LIFESAVING MEDICATION WHAT'S SO
WITH CENTRAL TO THE WORLD NOW.
OF COURSE TOOK PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
THIS BUT THE LAST MAJOR CHANGE
AGAIN IN ONE MANUFACTURER
HAPPENED IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WHEN THE TECHNOLOGY
BECAME AVAILABLETO USE
RECOMBINANT DNA TO MAKE A COPY.
OF HUMAN INSULIN. AT WHICH IS
WHAT WE USED TO. RATHER THE
PREVIOUS. GROUND UP BEEF AND
PORK PANCREAS EXTRACTS
BASICALLY WE TOOK ANIMAL
INSOLENCE AND INJECTED THEM
INTO HUMANS UNTIL THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES EARLY EIGHTIES. THE
MEDICATION NOT CHANGED IT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR LIFE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DIABETES AND IS THERE ARE
NO GOOD REASONS WHY IT. WHAT IT
DOES. I THINK THAT THIS BILL IS
ONLY PART OF ADDRESSING THAT
PROBLEM BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOUR FOLLOW UP MR MAYES
JUDGES DEFY IF I CAN MAYBE THAT
THE GENTLEMAN THAT WAS. A JUST-
ANSWERING THAT QUESTION
COMMITTEE GOING A LITTLE BIT
MORE SO MY QUESTION IS
SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS TO. IF
CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW LIMITS.
COST SHARING TWO TWO AND A
FIFTY DOLLARS FOR ALL
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. THEN THE
QUESTION I THINK FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND AS A MATTER OF
PUBLIC POLICY. WHY WOULD WE
SPECIFICALLY CALL OUT INSULIN
AND NOT CAP CALL OUT OTHER
DRUGS AS WELL OR SHOULD WE COME
UP WITH SOME SORT OF FORMULA
AIRY FOR THAT OR SHOULD WE TAKE
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
THAT'S THE CURRENT TO DROP TO
DROP THAT. WE DO KNOW THE
INSULIN IS A LIFE SAVING DRUG
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
LIFESAVING. DRUGS AS WELL AND
I'M JUST WONDERING- AS AS FAR
AS PUBLIC POLICY IS THERE A
SPECIFIC REASON WHY THIS AND
NOT OTHER. DRUGS SHOULD BE IT
SHOULD BE CALLED OUT. YOU MAY
GO IN THEIR CHARACTER. YES THIS
IS DOCTOR PRE UP AGAIN- I THINK
INSULIN IS FAIRLY UNIQUE THERE
MAY BE AN ARGUMENT FOR PUTTING
OUT. SIMILAR CAP ON OTHER
MEDICATIONS AS WELL BUT THIS IS
A MEDICATION THAT PARTICULARLY
FOR PEOPLE WITH TYPE ONE
DIABETES. IT LITERALLY LIFE OR
DEATH THIS WAS A UNIFORMLY
FATAL DISEASE TYPE ONE DIABETES.
IN SHORT ORDER AT BEFORE THE
DISCOVERY OF INSTALLING- THERE
IS NO GOOD REASON FOR OF THE-
I'M A CO INCREASE IN PRICE AND-
I THINK THAT. AB CALLS FOR THIS
SORT OF ACTION IT MAY NOT BE
THE ONLY ACTUAL THE LEGISLATURE
ULTIMATELY ENDS UP TAKING ON
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICING AND
I'M SURE WE BEAT YOU KNOW
INTERESTED IN TALKING TO YOU
ABOUT THAT BUT I THINK THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT ACTION THAT YOU
CAN TAKE. ABOUT. THANK YOU ANY
ANYONE ELSE. I HAVE I HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND ACTUALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF MR LOUISA
SO STILL IN TE WITNESS FUNERAL
CUT LIKE TO ASK HIM A COUPLE
QUESTIONS IF HE DOESN'T MIND.
YOU KNOW THIS BILL WAS PASSED
IN COLOR WELL WAIT TO MISTER
RESOURCES BACK SO. RIGHT WHAT
IS YOUR CHAIR YES SO THIS BILL
WAS PASSED IN COLORADO LAST
YEAR AND ACCORDING TO OUR
INFORMATION THERE HAVE NOT BEEN
ANY INCREASES IN PREMIUMS I
BELIEVE MISTER IN THIS AREA AND
THE COST WAS. WAS PRETTY SMALL
OF ALL THINGS CONSIDERED. WE
HAVE A POPULATION CALIFORNIA
THAT BY MANY ESTIMATES AS 50%
PRE DIABETIC. WE HAVE FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE ON DIABETES-
EIGHT I GUESS FOR ME I JUST
WONDER IF PEOPLE WERE ABLE TO
AFFORD THEIR MEDICATION BETTER
WOULD IT NOT POTENTIALLY BE A
PLUS FOR INSURANCE COMPANIES SO
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY FOR
THINGS LIKE EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS WOUND CARE AMPUTATIONS-
PROSTHETICS. TO REPLACE THAT
THE AMPUTATED LIMBS- AND SO ON
SO- I WILL ALSO NOTE AND AS AS
AT THAT IN COLORADO. THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY WAS NOT
ULTIMATELY NOT IN OPPOSITION
THE BILL THEY WERE NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL SO WHY WOULD
CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS BE AGAINST A BILL THAT
HAS A PROVEN TO INCREASE
PREMIUMS IN ANOTHER STATE. AND
IT'S NOT I JUST HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE I FIELD
UNDERSTAND THAT. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THAT QUESTION
AND SO I'LL TRY TO TAKE THOSE
SEQUENTIALLY- THERE ARE NUMBER
OF ELEMENTS IN IN THAT- NUMBER
ONE I DID I DID- YOU KNOW
CHECKING IN WITH- OUR OUR
NATIONAL TRADE- THAT TOOK A
POSITION ON THE BILL- IN
COLORADO ON AND I CONCERNS WITH
THEM THAT- THEY ACTUALLY DID
NOT REMOVE- THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THAT BILL. IN THAT STATE NOW
YOU KNOW I CAN'T TELL YOU
BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'M NOT THERE
WHAT DO YOU KNOW WHERE THAT
FELL ON THE PRIORITY LIST. BUT
NEAR MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE REMAINS TECHNICALLY OPPOSED
AS OPPOSED TO THEIR NOT BEING A
PREMIUM INCREASE. ALL ALL ALL
TRY TO EXPLAIN THIS. TO THE
BEST OF MY ABILITY- MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE IS THAT-
WHEN THE BILL PASSED WAS
IMPLEMENTED. THE RATES FOR THE
FIRST YEAR OF ENACTMENT- HAD
ALREADY BEEN FILED. SO THOSE
PREMIUMS ARE YOU KNOW FIVE WERE
ABLE TO BE ADJUSTED AND
REFLECTIVE OF THE NEWLAW- YOU
KNOW IN ITS INITIAL PHASE. SO
MAYBE OVER A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME- THOSE- COST- YOU KNOW
WHAT I WORK FOR AN OUNCE AT
LEAST THAT THAT'S THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE OF THE
TECHNICALITIES THERE IN
COLORADO- I WILL SEE YOU KNOW
WE DO BELIEVE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT DRUG- AGAIN HEALTH
PLAN BENEFIT DESIGNS- ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO CHANGE- YOU KNOW
THEIR- YOU KNOW. WE HAVE A
GENERIC OKAY WE HAVE A
PREFERRED BRAND WE HAVE A BRAND
AND THEN FOR SOME DRUGS THERE
IS A CO INSURANCE- AGAIN- YOU
KNOW OUR PREMIUMS ARE REVIEWED.
I WILL SAY THAT- YOU KNOW MANY
OF OUR PLANS AND I NATIONALLY
HAVE- IMPLEMENTED STRATEGIES TO
ACHIEVE OUT OF POCKET COSTS ARE
ACTUALLY LOWER. ON THEN THIS
BILL BUT THEIR ABILITY TO DO
THAT IS REALLY BASED ON THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT THEY HAVE
WITH THE RIVER THE
MANUFACTURERS IF YOU
LEGISLATIVE LEE INSTITUTE A
PRICE CONTROL ON ONE SIDE OF
THOSE OF THAT RELATIONSHIP- YOU
CAN IMAGINE. WHAT THE INCENTIVE
WOULD BE ON THE OTHER SIDE TO
YOU- YOU KNOW ESTABLISH THE
RIGHT TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP AND
ARRANGEMENTS. ON THAT ALLOW FOR
LOWER OUT OF POCKET COSTS SO-
IN AND I WOULD ALSO POINT TO
THE CHIPPER ANALYSIS WHICH IS
ALSO REFLECTED IN IN YOUR
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHICH STATES
THAT. YOU KNOW THE EVIDENCE THE
RESEARCH DOESN'T NECESSARILY
POINT TO BETTER IT HERE ANSWER
OUTCOMES. ON BASED ON ON COPAY.
CAPS SO. I I'LL JUST LEAVE IT
AT THAT. THANK YOU. I GUESS
ASKING OTHER QUESTIONS THAT.
THAT THAT MAY BE THE CASE GEN
WHAT USE WERE GENERICALLY WITH
CO PAY CAPS BUT THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT MEDICATION AND WE
HEAR. ALL THE TIME THAT PEOPLE
HAVE A HARD TIME AFFORDING
INSULIN. SO ONE THE QUESTION I
HAVE FOR YOU AS I I'M NOT AWARE
THAT THERE'S ANY GENERIC
INSULIN. CORRECT YEAH- THAT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING AS WELL- AND I
KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF EFFORTS
INCLUDING- YOU KNOW AT LEAST AT
AT. ONE OF OUR HEALTH PLANS IS
INVOLVED. IN AN EFFORT TO TRY
TO- TRY TO CHANGE THAT DYNAMIC-
SO YOU KNOW WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL
SEE HOW FAR THEY GO THERE SO
THAT WOULD BE VERY- THAT WOULD
BE VERY POSITIVE- DEVELOPED IT
AS WELL. BUT I WILL SEE NEEDING
YOU KIND OF ALLUDED TO THIS IN
YOUR COMMENT I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT I MEAN WE DO HAVE A
TECHNICAL COMPLIANCE PROBLEM
WITH. CARVING OUT A DIFFERENT
COPAY CAP FOR SPECIFIC DRUGS.
AND YOU KNOW I WON'T- YOU KNOW
BORE YOU WITH ALL THE
TECHNICALITIES BUT THEIR- ALL
OF HEALTH PLAN PRODUCTS- BETTER
OFFER TO COVER CALIFORNIA HAVE
TO ACHIEVE AN ACTUARIAL VALUE.
SO THAT MEANS- IF YOU ALTER THE
OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR ONE
SERVICE- YOU MAY HAVE TO. YOU
MAY BE IN A SITUATION WHERE YOU
HAVE TO MAKE UP THOSE. COSTS
WITH RESPECT TO OTHER SERVICES
AND- YOU KNOW OUR FOLKS ARE
LOOKING AT THIS BILL TO BELIEVE
THAT A SEPARATE COPAY CAP FOR
INSULIN WILL. REDUCE THE
FLEXIBILITY ON PLAN BENEFIT
DESIGN- YOU KNOW HOW TO COVER
CALIFORNIA WHICH COULD IN YOU
KNOW. I THINK SOME MORE NOW
SEEMS TO BE DONE ON THIS COULD.
MEAN THAT YOU KNOW. OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR OTHER SERVICES
MIGHT HAVE TO BE ALTERED TO
MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE. DO YOU
HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MUCH. HOW
MUCHCALIFORNIA'S PAY AND
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS EACH YEAR
ROUGHLY HOW MANY BILLION
DOLLARS. I HAVE A DON'T HAVE
THAT NUMBER IN FRONT OF ME BUT
ROUGHLY. I MEAN IT'S IT IT'S IN
THE HUNDREDS OF. YEAH THAT
HUNDRED BILLION MAYBE MORE OR
LESS LIKE YOU KNOW I I'D BE
TAKING A WHILE YES I DO KNOW.
THAT HEALTH PLANS PAID NEARLY
BACK TEN BILLION DOLLARS JUST
SOME PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ALONE
WHICH IS YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
YOU KNOW PERCENTAGE OF THE- OF
THE HEALTHCARE PREMIUM DOLLAR.
SO IN THE HUNDRED PLUS BILLION
DOLLARS IN PREMIUMS WERE
TALKING ABOUT A POTENTIAL
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AT WITH
AN M. AND YOU'RE TALKING WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PREMIUMS WITH A
BE AND SO I THINK THE COST S
PRETTY SMALL. I WOULD SAY ALSO
THAT THERE IS A SUNSET WITH
THIS AS WELL. SO IF. IT
HEARINGS DOESN'T CHANGE- THIS
THIS POTENTIALLY WILL BE
REEVALUATED AND MAYBE THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT TO GO
AWAY. BUT I'D- BUT WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW- FOR SURE. OTHER
THAN WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE CAN'T
AFFORD THEIR INSULIN- RIGHT NOW
SO WE DON'T REALLY KNOW FOR
SURE HOW MUCH OF A POSITIVE
IMPACT THIS COULD POTENTIALLY
HAVE AND MAYBE. SAVE THE
INDUSTRY A LOT OF MONEY WE
DON'T KNOW THAT FOR SURE YET
BUT THAT'S WHY THERE'S A SUNSET
ON THIS IT WILL GO BACK AND RE
EVALUATE THAT. SO I YOU KNOW I
I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS WHY
IS ONE REASON I ASKED TO BE A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILLS I DO
BELIEVE THIS. I AM DISTURBED BY
WILL MAKE A COMMENT HERE WHICH
I WILL ALSO MAKE AN BUDGET
COMMITTEE. THAT ON OF I'M
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT- WITH
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THAT WE HAVE
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE ON INSULIN
CALIFORNIA. POTENTIALLY 50% OF
THE POPULATION BEING PRE
DIABETIC THAT- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE HE HAS
ELIMINATED. THE FUNDING FOR THE
DIABETES PREVENTION PROGRAM.
WHICH IS ALMOST WHICH IS LIKE
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
NOT VERY MUCH MONEY. WHEN YOU
CONSIDER HOW MUCH MONEY WE'RE
SPENDING ON DIABETES THE STATE
LEVEL- I'M DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
THAT THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM GO
AWAY BUT THAT'S THAT'S NOT YOUR
THAT THAT'S NOT YOU THAT'S NOT
YOUR ISSUE MUST PLEASE US.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I HOPE IT
WILL CONTINUE TO DEBATE FURTHER
HERE SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ANSWERS I APPRECIATE. YOUR
INPUT. SIX ANYONE ELSE. SEEN NO
ONE WE DO HAVE A MOTION- BY
MISTER SANTIAGO WAS SECOND BY
MISS AGUILAR CURRY- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY TWO OH THREE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY I GUESS I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BONTA. BONTA
I BURKE. BURKE I CARILLO. FLORA
FLORA NOT VOTING LEAN ON.
LIMóN I MCCARTY. NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE ROMMEL'S. RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON.
WALDRON I'D. TEN NINE ZERO
KNOWS BILL PASSES REGULAR
SECRETARY WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
UP AND FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD
ON- MOVING ON TO YOUR NEXT BILL
MISTER HIS AREA A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. OVER A HUNDRED
AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS HAVE PARKINSON'S
DISEASE AT A COST OF FIVE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
UP PARK IS REGISTRY IS MODELED
AFTER CALIFORNIA SUCCESSFUL
CANCER REGISTRY WHICH HAS BEEN
DETERMINED- WILL- WAIT EARLY
DETECTION EDUCATION AND
RESEARCH SHOULD BE DIRECTED. IS
TO ANNOUNCE THAT AFTER BECOMING
OPERATIONAL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE PARKINSON'S
REGISTRY HAS ALREADY BECOME A
NATIONAL MODEL HAVING COLLECTED
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND ELECTRONIC RECORDS AND
FORMED REPORTING PARTNERSHIPS
WITH HEALTH GROUPS LIKE SUTTER
KAISER DIGNITY SCRIPTS. AND
STANFORD HEALTH OUT WITH ME
ARE- VIRTUALLY- NEAT SAW OFF
WITH THE MICHAEL J. FOX
FOUNDATION AND DOCTOR NEPTUNE
MIZRAHI A- A PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE- AND WITH UCLA
HEALTH AS WELL. GREAT WILL GO
TO A WITNESSES IN IN SUPPORT
AND JUST AS A REMINDER GONNA
KEEP IT LIMITED TO A SIX
MINUTES IN THE IN THE WHOLE.
AND ALSO WANT TO MAKE THE POINT
AS WELL I'M NOT SURE THERE'S
MUCH IN OPPOSITION WITH THIS
AND SO WE CAN GO A LITTLE
QUICKER. WHO'S UP FOR YOU- SO
NUMBER. JERRY INJURED
READERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE THE
FELLOW WITH THE MICHAEL J. FOX
FOUNDATION FOR PARKINSON'S
RESEARCH. ALSO APPRECIATE ALL
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THERE FOR
YOUR- SUPPORT OF THIS ISSUE BY
CREATING THE PROGRAM IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. AND EXTENDING THE
SUNSET LAST YEAR WOULD
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JITTERY AND
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
REGISTRY BECOME A MODEL FOR THE
NATION- JUST HAVING. STARTING
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT'S ALREADY
COLLECTED OVER TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND LIKE TRONIC
RECORD BY FORMING REPORTING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH HELPS LIKE
SUTTER TIGHTER DIGNITY SCRIPTS.
STANFORD HEALTH AND OTHERS SO
THAT THE CONFIDENTIAL PATIENT
DATA IT AUTOMATICALLY SENT FROM
THE PHYSICIAN'S OFFICE TO THE
STATE WITH NO AND BACK TO THE
DOCTOR. REGISTER NEED TO BE
CONTINUED SO THE ONGOING DATA
CAN BE PROVIDED TO RESEARCHERS
IN THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY.
ENGINEERING CALIFORNIA
PARKINSON DISEASE REGISTRY IT'S
CRITICAL FOR MANY REASONS. THE
DATA WILL HELP IDENTIFY HIGH
RISK GROUPS SUPPORT PATIENT
CONTACT STUDIES AND SERVE AS A
VALUABLE DATA RESOURCE TO
PREVENT OPTIMALLY MANAGE
PARKINSON'S DISEASE. TO MORE
ACCURATELY DETERMINE PARKINSON
HOT SPOT LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA- THE DATA WILL ALSO
HELP RESEARCHERS THAT THE
INCIDENCE AND PREVALENCE AND
PATTERNS OF PARKINSON'S DISEASE
OVER TIME. AND HELP DETERMINE
THAT CERTAIN REGIONS OF THE
STATE THAT USE MORE PESTICIDES.
BASED ON CALIFORNIA'S PESTICIDE
REGISTRY HAVE HIGHER INCIDENCE
OF PARKINSON'S. STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN A CORRELATION BETWEEN
HIGHER PESTICIDE USE AND
INCREASES AND PARTITIONS CASE.
IN IMPROVE ON YOUR OF THE LINK
BETWEEN. THE MILITARY SERVICE
SINCE THE LARGER PORTION OF THE
VETERANS COMMUNITY HAS
PARKINSON'S COMPARED TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION. AND
CALIFORNIA'S PARKINSON'S
REGISTRY PROVIDES THE LARGEST
AMOUNT OF DATA TO THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION NATIONAL
NEUROLOGICAL CONDITIONS
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM WHICH IS
WORKING WITH RESEARCHERS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TO IMPROVE
TREATMENTS AND FIND CURES. OF
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
MILITARY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WORK THANK YOU SO MUCH MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON RENTS THEIR CHAIRS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NEPTUNE IS THROWING ME AND
I'M NOTIFIED IS WITH THE COPY
CAT DID YOU. ATTEND NOT KIDS
I'VE BEEN DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
MOVING TO STRETCH ISSUE FOR
FUNDING THE PAST FIVE YEARS SO
SUPPORTING THE STATE IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL. AS YOU
MAY KNOW NEUROLOGICAL DISORDERS
ARE NOT THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DISABILITY AND LONG DISTANCE
THE FASTEST GROWING. IS
PARKINSON'S DISEASE. H. GOLD
HERE THE ONLY. IN THE PAST
THREE. IT PAST TWENTY THE
NUMBER OF TO BE PARKINSON'S THE
HAVE MORE THAN FOR IT COULD BE
NOTHING. IT'S REACHED DOUBLE
AGAIN IN THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
IT'S IS A LAW RANGE AND THIS
THE HUMAN CHECK. GROWTH AND I
MENTIONED BY ASSEMBLYMAN
ALLEGEDLY ON ITS MORTIFIED
EIGHT. ANNUAL FOR STATE
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE NO FIVE
MARCHERS OR DIAGNOSTIC TEST FOR
PARKINSON'S DISEASE AND MORE
SIGNATURE THINK COM. ARE NON
SPECIFIC FOR DIFFERENT FIVE
YEARS. SO IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
UNDERSTAND CAUSES OF THE V.
HAVE LEARNED ABOUT NINE FIFTH
OF BECAUSE OF THE DC IN ARE NOT
YOU'RE NOT. THERE WE NEED TO
CRIED SHE COLLECTING THE MANGA
BAKER AND I DO. PART FOR YOU AT
THE STATE. I AM JUST THE CALLER
STATES I THINK THE CALL THE AND
READ THE HE- R. AND BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE A MORE YOUR FULL
CHAIRED TO OF MANY CASES. FOR
OUT THE STATE. THERE OUGHT TO
BE US WHICH- IS OUR TO CREE
RENT TWO YOU CAN AND WE NEED.
IT CHEN BE PRETTY. I DO IS THE
ONLY PARKING DATE IT FOR IT
PARKING YOUR REGISTRY AND
COUNTRY OBVIOUSLY THE BEST
ENVIRONMENTAL DATA BASE THAT WE
HAVE IN CALIFORNIA- THERE IS NO
PLACE IN THE COUNTRY OR IN THE
WAR THAT YOU CAN BE WITH THIS
TYPE OF RESEARCH. AND WE HAVE A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO CONDUCT
THIS RESEARCH AND IS BEING USED
AT THE MARKET AS MENTIONED BY
CDC AND OTHERS THEY- FOR
PARKING IS THE AND BY THE OF NO
LOGICAL THE SCHOOL DAY SO.
WHICH IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROMOTE RESEARCH
AND BRING ADDITION ARE FUNDING-
THAT COMES FROM SAID THERE ARE-
AGENCIES FOR RESEARCH AND THAT
THE KOREAN ACCORDING TO LEAVE
THE HOUSE A HIGHREWARD YOU
DETAIL BUT LIMITED IN SCOPE AND
QUALITY. OF EVENTS YOUR
COMPLETED AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATION AND ON
IMPROVING AT THE EXPENSE OF ITS
REGISTRY. I WILL GET THE
FOURTEENTH AND I. WOULD BE
ARGUED WITH YOUR. I WILL THANK
YOU. THANK SO MUCH AND WILL GO
TO THE PUB NOW OUR THERE ANY TO
ANY BUT A WISHING TO ADD ON AND
SO OF IS MISTER MISS SLAUGHTER.
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK OUT. OF THE
PHONE MAY PRESS AND AT THIS
TIME. AND WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
LETTER QUEUING UP PLEASE ALLOW
A FEW MOMENTS FOR US TO GATHER
BLUSH. THEM GREAT AND AGAIN
THIS IS JUST- YOUR NAME AND
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR AND
WHETHER SUPPORT IT. ALL RIGHTY
READY MISTER MODERATOR. ALMOST
NOT QUITE SORRY OKAY. DOES TAKE
A FEW MOMENTS. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT THAT TWO FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MANY HERE
WITH CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
SO SEASON AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU HOLD
ON THE LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX THAT'S TWO FIVE SIX
ZERO AND IS OPEN. THIS IS
BARBARA BUT WITH THE
PARKINSON'S ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT
THE BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU I MEAN MAY HAVE
LITTLE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY
WITH ONE OF MY ASSISTANCE ONE
MOMENT PLEASE OKAY I DO
APOLOGIZE. ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
ONE NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES ONE NINETY FIVE GO AHEAD.
I'M MORE THAN WHAT- PATTY
JENKINS ON THE VOLUNTEER
COORDINATOR FOR THE VENTURA
PARKINSON'S DISEASE SUPPORT
GROUP OF OVER THREE HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND CARE PARTNERS. WE
ARE A PART OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANY OTHER ADD ON
ME TO USE IN SUPPORT. KERRY
WELL NOW THE LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE THAT'S TWO FIVE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUILD
CLINCHED ADVOCATE FOR THE
PARKINSON'S COMMUNITY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER
MODERATOR JUST A MOMENT AND ONE
MORE JUST CUBA ONE MOMENT OKAY.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
THREE TWO FIVE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES THIS IS KAMALA
JALEO WITH CALIFORNIA BY TO
LIFE WE'RE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO BUILD TWO ONE
ONE. TWO BY ASSEMBLYMAN WHILE
MOST CONSTRUED CONGESTION THIS
BILL WE ARE NOT WE ARE ON THANK
YOU SO MUCH BUT THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY ON AB TWO EIGHT. TWO
ONE BY AND IS THERE AN- TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE. THE MODERATOR
WAS OR ANYBODY ELSE IN SUPPORT
ON AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE.
I HAVE ONE MORE THAT'S QUEUING
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
TO LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE TWO SIX ORDER LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS. IF THE DRUG
DEPENDENT WITH THE AMERICAN
PARKING THIS IS BECAUSE THE-
AND WE ARE SUPPORTING IT FAILED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT IS THE
END OF THE QUEUE. WE HAVE
NOTHING LEFT IN THE QUEUE GREAT
THIS MOVE TO. ANYBODY IN
BETWEEN IS OR ANYBODY IN
BETWEEN. NOT HEARING ANY THEN
WE WILL GO TO A WITNESSES AND
IN OPPOSITION OTHER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AND AS
A REMINDER THERE WOULD BE
LIMITED TO TWO WITNESSES FOR A
TOTAL OF SIX MINUTES THREE
MINUTES APIECE. ARE THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL. THE MOVIE TO HAVE A
FEW THAT ARE QUEUING UP ON THE
AUDIO IF YOU'RE READY FOR THAT.
YES THAT WOULD BE GREAT. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY SEVEN TWO FIVE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FRANK NO WHERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
GOLDEN WEST CHAPTER OF THE A.
L. S. LOU GEHRIG'S DISEASE
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER NOTE WHERE- WE DID
MOVE T OPPOSITION BUT WE'RE
GOING TO ADD YOU IN ON SUPPORT
SO ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES SO
MOVING TO WITNESSES. IN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION TO ABA AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE. MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY LIKE
TO LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS- I
THINK THERE IS A CROSSOVER
ISSUE THIS IS DOCTOR ALLEN WE
WERE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT AT THE
A. B. TWO EIGHT TWO ONE
PROFESSOR NEUROLOGISTS THAT
UCLA IN POSITION FOR MADISON
SELECT ON HEALTH RECORDS. A
OKAY SO WE'VE GOT ANOTHER IN
SUPPORT SO MAYBE MAYBE WE
DIDN'T FINISH WITH THE SUPPORTS
MR MODERNITY HAVE ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT. REGULAR BACK TO
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE. I HAVE ONE IN
THE QUEUE WE'RE GONNA FIND OUT
IT'S LIKE TWO HUNDRED ANDSIXTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OKAY. HELLO
YES THIS IS. AURORA SORIANO
BALLING HERE DIRECTOR AN
ADVOCATE FOR FIND THE CARD FIND
A CURE FOR PARKINSON'S DISEASE
I AM STRONG SUPPORT AT AB
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MOTOR ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT. ONE ELSE
COMING UP AT THIS TIME. JUST
SAY NO ONE ELSE'S QUEUING UP
OKAY AS A BACK TO THEN WE'RE
GONNA GO BANG UP. SO WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE SO IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE. THAT'S CUTE
THAT'S CUTE UP RIGHT NOW. NO
SIR OKAY WE'RE AND ASK THE
QUESTION ONE MORE TIME ANYBODY
THAT IS OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE ON THE LINE.
TO OPPOSED TO NOT SUPPORT
OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
GOING ONCE. GOING TWICE ARGAN
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER NAZARIAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISSION IS AARON AND- WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE LET ME
MAKE SURE DID WE GET A MOTION
ON OUT OF SUPPORT. A MOTION.
THE TERM MISTER FORM MOVED AND
WHO SECOND TODAY. AND MIGUEL
SECONDS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
MOTION USED TO PASS A CEMENT
DON'T DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MAYES MOVES
SANTIAGO SECOND WOULD. WHAT I
MAYES. MAYES AYE A YEAR CURRY
CURRY I BIGELOW BIGELOW I'D
BONTA. BURKE CARILLO FLORA
FLORA I LIMóN LIMóN AYE
MCCARTY NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE
RAMOS RAMOS I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I'D WALDRON WALDRON AYE. ELEVEN
ICE ZERO KNOWS BILL PASSES.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY WILL
LEAVE THAT ROLE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE
AB TWO ONE ONE TWO MISTER RAMOS
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF HIS OPPORTUNITY NOW I WOULD
LIKE A BY STARTING SAYING THAT
WE ARE ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AB
TWENTY ONE TWELVE ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
EVEN BEFORE THE CURRENT COVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SUICIDE RATES
AMONG ALL GROUPS HAVE BEEN
INCREASING DRASTICALLY THOUGHTS
OF SUICIDE AFFECT PEOPLE FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE THE RISK OF
SUICIDE IS ESPECIALLY
SIGNIFICANT AMONG ADOLESCENTS
OLDER ADULTS VETERANS. LGBT Q.
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH AND
ADULTS SUICIDE RISK IS
SIGNIFICANT IN NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES NATIVE AMERICAN
YOUTH FACE HIGHER RATES OF
SUICIDE THAN THEIR PEERS IN
ADDRESSING THE CRISIS OF
SUICIDE WE CRIER OF FOCUS ON
NATIVE AMERICAN YOU. THOSE WHO
ARE AT GREATEST RISK. ARE AT
EVEN GREATER RISK NOW THE
UNPRECEDENTED COVERT NINETEEN
CRISIS WILL HAVE EXPOSED
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON THE
COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES MENTAL
HEALTH DUE TO ANXIETY CAUSED BY
MANY FACTORS SUCH AS ISOLATION.
GRIEF OVER THE LOSS OF FRIENDS
AND FAMILY. HEALTH CONCERNS
INCREASE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
IN THE WAY OF ECONOMIC HARDSHIP.
AS WE LOOK FORWARD WE NEED TO
PREPARE FOR INCREASED PRESSURE
ON THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM
NOT ONLY DURING THE CRISIS BUT
LONG AFTER. AB TWENTY ONE
TWELVE TAKES THE FIRST STEP IN
ADDRESSING THE CURRENT CRISIS
OF SUICIDE BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS OFFICE WILL CENTRALIZE
STATE RESOURCES MARSHALL
EXPERTISE AND BUILT ON THE
VITAL WORK OF STAKEHOLDERS LIKE
THOSE WHO ARE HERE. WITH ME
TODAY IS ACTUALLY MALES FROM
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION. ALSO WITH ME TODAY
AS KIARA WHETHER FOR FROM TWO
FEATHERS NATIVE AMERICAN FAMILY
SERVICES WHO IS ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE COAT KARUK IN EUROPE
PEOPLE. MISTER CHAIR WE COULD
GO TO OUR WITNESSES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF WE HAVE ONE IN
THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM. AND
ONE ON THE PHONE SO. ASHLEY
MILLS. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY MY NAME IS ASHLEY MILLS
AND THEN RESEARCH SCIENTISTS
THE PROVIDER FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AND
LEAD AUTHOR OF STRIVING FOR
ZERO CALIFORNIA STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR SUICIDE PREVENTION. THE
COMMISSION IS PROUD TO JOIN THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SPONSORING ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE TWELVE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION. IN 200-018-4000
FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
CALIFORNIANS LOST THEIR LIVES
TO SUICIDE. THAT'S A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN MORE THAN A TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE MORE
THAN A TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
RESEARCH SUGGESTS THE NUMBER OF
LIVES LOST ISSUES THAT WILL
ONLY INCREASE FURTHER AS A
RESULT OF THE CALL THAT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. COORDINATED
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT SUICIDE PREVENTION IS
NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER. THE
STATE'S RECENTLY ADOPTED
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN WAS
BUILT ON TWO YEARS OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT ACROSS CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND IS
BACKED BY THE LATEST IN SCIENCE
OF SUICIDE AND ITS PREVENTION.
THE STATE PLAN OUTLINES TWELVE
GOALS TO ADVANCE EFFORTS TO
ELIMINATE DEATH BY SUICIDE AND
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. THOSE
GOALS BEGIN WITH THE STATE
LEVEL LEADERSHIP TO CATALYZE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
FOR AN EFFECTIVE PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO SUICIDE. THAT WORK
BEGINS WITH ESTABLISHING AN
OFFICE OF SUICIDE PREVENTION.
WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROB US FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
SAVING LIVES FROM SUICIDE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER- MODERATOR WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE ON THE LINE- KIERA
WEATHERFORD- SPEAKING A WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE WHEN IT WHEN YOU CAN. HOW
MUCH LANCE. OKAY WHETHER FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NOW. HELLO MY
NAME CARE WHETHER FOR I AM
SEVENTY YEARS OLD I'LL BE
EIGHTEEN EMPLOYMENT I AM
EXCITED TO SAY THAT I WILL BE
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
WITH ONE DAY I AM ENROLLED IN
THAT YOU'RE NOT RANCHERIA AND A
GROUP YOU'RE OUT AND CHECK ON
IT THAT. I AM THE RECIPIENT OF
THE NORTH COAST FOR THE
INDUSTRY HIGH CRIME RECORD
WHICH RECOGNIZES STUDENT THAT
OVERCOME HARDSHIPS AND COME OUT
ON THE ON THE OTHER SIDE. MY
GOAL IS TO ATTEND COLLEGE OF
THE REDWOODS IN THE FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO BECOME A WRITER
AND AUTHOR. BASED ON THE
EXPERIENCES I'VE A TIME I
BELIEVE WE ENSURE THAT ALL THE
THAT WITH TRONG POSITIVE
OUTLOOK ON LIFE I AM CONFIDENT
THAT I AM STRONG TO CONQUER ANY
NEGATIVE ENERGY OF OPTICAL. NOT
A- BEEN THE CASE. THROUGHOUT
LIFE I'VE EXPERIENCED MAY.
MEDICAL EXPERIENCES THAT A
YOUNG PART LIKE MY- SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO PAY. ONE OF THE MORE
PROMINENT OBSTACLE I'VE HAD TO
OVERCOME INCLUDING MY FATHER.
JANUARY FOURTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
MY FATHER WAS DONE TO DEATH IN
THE CHEST IN ORDER CALIFORNIA.%
AFTER FINDING OUT ABOUT HIS
MURDER I WAS FLOODED WITH
FEELINGS OF ANGER SADNESS AND
HOPELESSNESS. IN THE PILOT
THERE ANY MY WIFE CROSSED MY
MIND. IT WAS THE THOUGHT THAT
THE NEVER ENDING I REALLY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO. WITHOUT
MY MOM DID MANAGE YOUR FOSTER
ARE GETTING YES THEY WILL HALL.
ANY SYSTEM TO KEEP OTHERS NEAR
THE MAC AMERICAN FAMILY
SERVICES. I DON'T KNOW HOW I
WOULD HAVE MADE IT. TWO
BROTHERS AND MY MOTHER PROVIDED
ME WITH THE UNCONDITIONAL
SUPPORT THOSE ESSENTIAL TO
GETTING ME THROUGH THE DARKEST
TIME OF MY LIFE. SINCE THEN
RECONNECTING WITH MY CULTURE
FROM MY DAD'S SIDE OF THE
FAMILY HAS BEEN A POSITIVE
OUTLOOK. THAT HAD STRENGTHENED
MY TIED TO THE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY GETTING HELP FROM
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TEAM HAS ALSO
BEEN BECAUSE OF MY ABILITY TO
OVERCOME MANY OF MY DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCE THAT. I COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF HAVING A
STATEWIDE OFFICES TO THE
COLLECTION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT YOU AND HOW
THEY FEEL ABOUT THIS ISSUE. TO
REALLY PRIORITIZE IT WE NEED
MORE OPPORTUNITY MORE RESOURCES
SUICIDE RED HAT AND CONTINUES
TO BE A REAL PROBLEM AMONG
NATIVE AMERICANS. FOR EXAMPLE
NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH. TO THE
SIDE OF OFTEN FOUR. A NATIONAL
I. WE MUST COME TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS OF MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND CRISES OF
FOOD THAT OUR COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY DURING THE DIFFICULT
TIME IS OFTEN THE ONE TO
STRUGGLE THE MOST ARE THE
YOU'VE JUST LIKE MYSELF
CHOOSING PREVENTION PROGRAMS
LIKE I AM A PART OF I TO THE
OTHERS. SHOULD BE INCLUDED AS
PART OF AN ONGOING SEE EFFORT
TO REDUCE THE DISTURBING WAY TO
THE SIDE ANY OF. THE TIME TO
ACT IS NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE OTHER WITNESSES YOU
MAY OPEN IN SUPPORT. I AM ON
THE PHONE YOU MAY OPEN THE
PHONE LINES. MISTER MODERATOR.
IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK OUT IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
IT'S ZERO AT THE TIME. ONE NINE
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HIS MERE MARTIN WITH A
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
SUFFICIENT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE ONE EIGHT THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER ALI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST IN SUPPORT GIVE. LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
TWO SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
PARTICULAR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY. IN A
MONICA IN CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY ONE TWO SEVEN ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALICE
HAWTHORNE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION EXPORT THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER ADRIN
SHELTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE A CHILD
FAMILY SERVICES WE ARE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR A MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN TWO TWO LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN
COMMITTEE DISAGREED WITH
CALLING FROM CONSPECIFIC A
CENTERS FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE TWELVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY TWO
SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
SIXTY TWO CHECK A LINE FOR SELF
MUTE. HELLO LA THERE ARE NO
WITH THE COUNTY BE ABLE HELP
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY ONE ONE NINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON BARBARA REVERT WITH
THE FEINBERG IN HOUSTON
CHRONICLE CORD OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR TWO SEVEN FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HOW THE BOND WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS. AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE TWO SIX
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN A
VERY WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. TWO
FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY TWO FIVE THREE CHECK YOUR
LINE FOR MUTE. LET ME TOO THAT
YOU OKAY I THIS IS CAMILLE
JALEO WITH CALIFORNIA SHE RIGHT
TO LIFE COMMITTEE AND WE
SPEAKING AND OPPOSITE. TO EIGHT
TWENTY ONE PLEASE CARD FOR BILL
SO NAME. WE APPRECIATE THANK
YOU YOU WILL GO TO. TWO HUNDRED
WE HAVE TWO MORE IN Q. DID YOU
WANT GO TO THOSE. CAN YOU HEAR
ME SIR. NINETY WE'LL TRY BY TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE TWO
SEVEN NINE YOU'RE OPEN. WITHOUT
A DOUBT. OUT OF SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
LYING TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN TWO THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO THREE SEVEN YOUR
LINE FOR SELF NEW. HI THIS IS
LYDIA FOR A WITH THE AMERICAN
AMERICAN ACADEMY PEDIATRICS AS
WELL AS CALL FOR SCHOOLS ARE
WHERE SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
LINE TO HUNDRED AND SIX TWO SO
SIX ALIGN ITSELF. MISTER
CHAIRMAN. CRISTINA OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL PROFESSION
PARK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN
THAT IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN
OUR- AND WE HAVE NO WITNESSES
SCHEDULED- ANYONE IN THE
WITNESS VIEWING ROOM. SEEING NO
ONE WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
LINES FOR- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
VOICE OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. LINE TWO
FIFTY THREE TWO FIVE THREE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
CAMILLE JALEO AND WITH
CALIFORNIA TO LIFE COMMITTEE.
AND WE ARE HERE TO STAY YEAH
OFFICE TO THIS. BILL EVEN
THOUGH DO. ASSEMBLY ALMOST HOPE
OF THE YOU. GUIDE THE STOPPING.
WE REALLY THAT BUT OF. FOR
CREATE OF THIS IN YEAH ANOTHER
BEER ON. WITHIN STATE GOT. AND
THE IS USUALLY NOT FROM.
EFFICIENT MANNER OF CHAU HUMAN
TRACK PROP. ARE IN WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL PER INDIRECT AND NOW
THAT THE TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR.
FAKTISK THREE NINE HEALTH ACT
HAVE BEEN FAILURE OF EVEN THE
YOUNG LADY SPEAKS AND IN THE
THAT THERE ARE FAR FAR FAR TOO
MANY. OUR NEW. THEN YOU'D THINK.
THROUGH RENDON RESPECTED FACT.
ARE ALL. THAT THE GOVERNMENT NO
POWER WITH. FIFTY WOULD HAVE
STAFFA PLAY FOR A. TWO FIVE.
BY PROMOTE A PROBLEM NUMBER
CALLED BEST PRACTICES BUT EVEN
THAT INTO THE SHIFTING IN.
OBJECT PLAN. BEST PRACT IS JUST
THE LATEST. SORT OF NEW DOES.
THE CREATING GOVERNMENT PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS AND RAISING TAX
DOLLARS SIGNING YOUR OFFICIAL
AUTHORITY THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
GROUPS. NO HELP WILL REACH THE
SUFFERING INDIVIDUALS THIS BILL
GIVES PEOPLE NO HOME JEFF THE
SHIFTING SANDS OF BEST
PRACTICES TO COMFORT THEM IN A
TIME OF HUMAN TRAGEDY PLEASE
REJECT THIS BILL VOTE NO. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE SO
NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANKYOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING IT BACK TO- THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SCENE IN WHICH I TO
CLOSE THIS FROM US YES MISTER
CHAIR. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL THIS MUCH NEEDED BILL
DURING THESE TIMES WE TALKED
ABOUT. YES IN IN THE STATE-
WITHOUT GPT Q. ARE YOU IN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN YOU. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE IN
HER TESTIMONY OF HOW THIS IS
NEEDED. IN MOVING FORWARD
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY. I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
SECOND BY MISTER FLORA THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY ONE TWELVE. MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MAYES. MAYES I GET CURRY I
BIGELOW BIGELOW II BONTA. BONTA
I'D BURKE BURKE HI CARILLO
CARILLO ICE FLORA FLORA I AM ON.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN NAZARIAN
ROMMEL'S RAMOS I'D RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE WALDRON WALDRON I'D. THE
BILL HAS THIRTEEN I KNOW ZEROS
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
ROBERTS SAID LIKE TO BE
CONSIDERATION BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR TO YOUR BILL- WE WILL-
LEAVE THE ROLL UP AND FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND WE WOULD
OPEN UP FOR ANY CO AUTHORS IT
SO WISH TO- OUT ON TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE GET STATE YOUR NAMES WE GET
IN THE RECORD. RISK YEAH PLEASE
GO AHEAD- MISTER BIGELOW-
MISTER RODRIGUEZ IT LOOKS LIKE
A CHORUS OF MEMBERS. HI OKAY SO
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOING
TO MOVE ON. WE CAN MOVE ON TO
AB THREE TWO TWO FOUR MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURRS AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY FORWARD CRATER PROCESS
TO EXAMINE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKFORCE ISSUES
BY REQUIRING CITY PH SHOULD
CONTACT THE APPROPRIATE ENTITY
TO EVALUATE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ADEQUATE
STAFFING LEVELS. AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THIS WILL
ENSURE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
CAN PERFORM DAILY ACTIVITIES OF
PREVENTION AND PUBLIC HEALTH
AND DURING EMERGENCY TIMES
ADEQUATE GROUP ADEQUATELY
BLACKS TO MEET EMERGING
COMMUNITY SUCH AS DURING A
PLAN. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE CITY PA TO CONVENE AN
ADVISORY GROUP TO OVERSEE AND
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
THE EVALUATION AND THEN. ASK
CALIFORNIA PORT AND COVER FROM
COVERT NINETEEN IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE RE EXAMINE
HOW. HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
STAFF AND RESOURCE THIS BILL
ABOUT. OFFICERS OF CAL AND C.
I. CALLING. FIND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS MICHELLE GIVENS.
FROM THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS RODRIGUEZ-
OUR WITNESSES ARE ON THE PHONE
SO I WILL GO AHEAD HAVE THE-
MODERATOR OPEN THE PHONE LINES
FOR OUR WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY HAPPEN AND
CHAIRMAN. GOOD AFTERNOON HERE
MEMBERS MICHELLE GIVEN WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA ONE
OF THE POWERFUL BUNKER THE BABY
THREE FIFTY FOUR ALONG WITH
HELL ACT IN IT YEAH YOU. JUST
ILLUSTRATED OR ITS ONE
ILLUSTRATION OF HOW PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT CAN IMPACT THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND
ALSO HOW PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT
ADVERSELY IMPACT FACTORS AND
THE ECONOMY AS A WHOLE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR THE
FOR THE SECOND PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT IN NOVEL AND THEN NEXT
CARELESSLY TO PREVENT GREAT AND
THERE'S- LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT THE WORKING REDUCE
CHRONIC DISEASE IS A- HOW
INEQUITY IN OUR- AND ALSO. PRO
AIMED AT PROMOTING HEALTHY
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT WERELY ON TRAIN PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS SUCH AS
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE INVESTIGATORS PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES LABORATORY IN AND
EDUCATORS DEAFENING. HOWEVER
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT. I CAN'T
DECLINE EIGHT FEDERAL REPORT
THE ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY
THE TO REMAIN HEALTH PUBLIC
HEALTH EVERYTHING OUR NATION
BEEN UNDER FUNDED BY POINT FIVE
DOLLAR. WE OFTEN WHEN PUBLIC
HEALTH WORK WE'RE INVISIBLE AND
BECAUSE OF THIS IT'S BEEN EASY
TO ASSUME THAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ADEQUATELY AND STAFF AND HAVE A
STRONG INFRASTRUCTURE HOWEVER
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT TRUE
EIGHTY THREE TWO TWO FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH CONTACT WITH IT
AND ARE YOU A POLITICAL
DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND LOOKING BE
ORDERED TO. THE VALUE.
REPUBLICAN WORKFORCE INCLUDING
IDENTIFIED OF BERRIER AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ADEQUATE
STAFFING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IF LOOK AT IT
CREDENTIALING ACCESS TRAINING
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
STRATEGIES AND SUPPORT AND HOW
TO INCENTIVIZE THE PIPELINE TO
PROFESSIONAL TO WORK WITH AND
PUBLIC HEALTH EVALUATION WHAT
ALSO AT THE AT COULD BE AND
HEALTH INFORMATION TOOLS
EVALUATE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORY CAPACITY AND
EVALUATE RECENT TREND WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING
STREAM TO PROVIDE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND THE REPURPOSE IT
TO FIFTEEN AT THE WORK OF LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. A REPORT AND
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF EATING
RIGHT AT THE LEGISLATURE THIS
EVALUATION WHAT IDENTIFIED GAPS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS THE ABILITY
OF LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO
PROTECT AND IMPROVE THE HEALTH
OF OUR COMMUNITIES FOR THESE
THAT RESPECTFULLY ARE YOU YES
ON. EIGHTY THREE TWO TWO FOUR
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK WE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS
WILL BE SANCHEZ SAYS YEAH YOU
CAN. I REMEMBER GOING TO THE
SHALL GIVEN AGAIN IT WOULD NOT
OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE A SECOND IN
TODAY. OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S
FINE- MISTER MODERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINE FOR
ADDITIONAL- MEMBER OF.
TESTIMONY SUPPORT JUST NAME-
ORGANIZATION POSITION PLEASE.
MESSAGE I. Q. UP IT'S ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
ONE FOUR SIX ZERO ONE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CAN MEMBERS
AND EIGHTY S. HERE APOLOGIES
FOR THE LATE NOTICE AT THE AYE
IN CALIFORNIA IS HOW TO COOK
MONSTER DID BILL. WHICH YAK AND
OTHER LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT TWO NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON PREFERRED CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SOLANO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE TWO
SEVEN SEVEN CHECK FOR SELF MEET.
YOUR NO RESPONSE WILL MOVE ON
TO LINE THREE ZERO ONE THREE
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NICOLE MORTAL MEN ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FOR ANYTHING- COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE TWO TWO FOUR. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE TWO SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HUNDRED SIXTY NINE OR
HEARING AUDIO. MOVING ALONG
WILL GO TO LINES THIRTY THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I CAN'T
BE BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER THE SENSATION OF
CALIFORNIA PRACTICAL SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND THAT ENDS THE
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVING ON TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE WITNESS ROOM FOR.
OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE- YOU MAY
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE EIGHT ZERO
IF YOU LIKE TO VOICE OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE- WHICH I CLOSE THIS
RODRIGUEZ. YES OUR RESPECT LAST
RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
SANTIAGO. AND THE SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THIRTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD.
WOULD I MAYES. MAYES I OUR GEAR
CURRY AGAIN CURRY I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I'D BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE BURKE I RIO CORREO ICE
FLORA. LIMóN MCCARTY NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE. TWELVE I ZERO NO
BILL IS OUT THAT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER RODRIGUEZ MISTER
SANTIAGO EUROPE AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'M HERE I'M HERE PROUD
TO PRESENT- AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN WHICH ESTABLISHED A
CHANCE GENERAL WELLNESS EQUITY
FUND TO CREATE PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE MEDICAL AND
DIRECTOR FOR THE SERVICES TO
CHANGE GENDER. ANON
CONFRONTATIONAL AND OR INTERSEX
PEOPLE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS T. G.
I HAVE A I KEEP IT BRIEF MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF BEEN A LONG DAY I
HOPE THAT I'LL BE OKAY WITH YOU
AND WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES. WILL
ALSO TESTIFY BRIEFLY THINGS
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO HANG ON A SECOND HERE
GET MY TO MY RIGHT PAGE.
SHOCKING REFERS TO USING PAPER
HERE- WE HAVE A TO TUNE TO A
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE. YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
LINE FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALEX
BELL SOUTH I AM THE LEGAL
DIRECTOR AT THE TRANS GENDER
GENDER VARIANT AN INTEREST TAX
STUFF THE PROJECT FOR TGI
CHAPTERS PROJECT. A GROUP OF
TGI PEOPLE INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
OF PRISON JAIL AND DETENTION
FINER CREATING UNITED FAMILY
AND STRUGGLE FOR SURVIVAL ENTRY
I'M THE TRANSPONDER WALLACE IN
EQUITY FUND AT THE NOT THE
THIRTY TIMELY ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES GEN UNDER THE FOURTH
AND FINAL BOOK FOR YOU. BUT IN
BAD INCREASE STRESS AT SERIOUS
COMPLICATION WE ARE ASKING FOR
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
CREATE INTEREST THE LOCATE
HOLISTIC HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CRITICAL GENERAL HEALTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES. INCLUDING REFERRALS
TO SUPPORT OF HOUSE ON THE
FUNDS WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED AT
GRANT TGI LAD ORGANIZATION
APART ARE QUALIFIED HEALTHCARE.
PROVIDERS AND CLINIC. WE ARE
CUTTING BACK THE FUNDING TO
PROVIDE A TO BE SO BECAUSE-
ACCORDING TO THE TWENTY TWO.
THE LACK TRANSFERRED BY THIRTY
THREE PRESS OF TRANS PEOPLE WHO
HAD BEEN APPROVED AND THE- YEAR.
BEFORE HAVING AT LEAST ONE
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCE WITH A
DOCTOR OR OTHER HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER RELATED TO BEING
TRANSPONDER. RANGING FROM
SEXUAL OR PHYSICAL ASSAULT TO
DENIAL BASIC CARE NOT RELATED
TO GENDER AFFIRMATION. HE 4% OF
SURVEY RESPONDENTS REPORTED
HAVING TO TEACH THE PROVIDER
ABOUT TRANSGENDER PEOPLE IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE APPROPRIATE
CARE. OTHER RESULTS 23% OF
RESPONDENTS REPORTED THAT THEY
AVOIDED SPEAKING HEALTH CARE
THEY NEEDED. IN THE PAST YEAR
DUE TO THE FEAR OF BEING
MISTREATED OTHER TRANSGENDER
PERSON. INVESTING IN ORGANIZED
PATIENT BLOOD BY ARE PARTNERING
WITH TGA PEOPLE AS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT AFFORDABLE
COMMUNITIES RECEIVEBATES AND
AFFIRMING MEDICAL SERVICES.
WILL ALSO ADVOCATING HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS IN FACT PRACTICES THE
WORKING WITH THE RAPIDLY
GROWING DEMOGRAPHIC. THE TGI
COMMUNITY IS ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO POKE AT NINETEEN
YOU'RE THE HIGH RATE THE
MEDICAL CONDITION THE LEADER
TOOK A COMPLICATION. MORE THAN
ONE OUT OF FIVE TRANSGENDER
DON'T HAVE A LEAST ONE OR MORE
CHRONIC CONDITION.
TRANSMITTABLE YOU THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION TO BE LIVING
WITH HIV. AND LGBT PEOPLE USING
USED TOBACCO OUT OF 50% HIGHER
LATE IN THE GENERAL POPULATION.
THESE ARE ALL FACTORS THAT
INCREASE INCREASE. BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN COMPLICATION RATE.
THANK OF THE NINE REST PAIRED
WITH THE- WERE LOCKED IN FACT
MEDICAL CARE HOW DRAMATIC
INCREASE SO BAD URGENT NEED FOR
KEEP YOU I. COMPANY COLLISION
NOT A CARE. THIS IS THE OFF. TO
MAKE AN IMPACT THE LIVES OF PGA
PEOPLE DURING A TIME WHEN
SECTION IN BATON IT'S CRITICAL
TECH COMMUNITY MEMBERS BALL
BEING AND SURVIVAL. I WOULD
BUCKLEY AFTER I GOT IT AB
TWENTY TWO. EIGHTEEN THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE NEXT
WITNESS. SO DO WE HAVE A SECOND
WITNESS IN THE QUEUE MISTER
MODERATOR. IN SUPPORT ARE YOU
LOOKING. YEAH FIVE MY NAME IS
BAMBI HAVE SEVERAL AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE DENTAL
CAN OF COALITION YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY. IT DOES LOOK
IN A COALITION OF THE NATIONAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION AND A
DIRECT SERVICE PROVIDER FOR
TRYING TO THE NON CONFORMING AN
INTERSECTION TO GET PEOPLE IN
LOS ANGELES. OUR ORGANIZATION
LIKE MANY OTHER TRANSLATOR
GONNA STATIONS AND GROUPS. WERE
BUILT OUT OF NO. THREE
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S A LOT OF
STIGMA AND DISCRIMINATION PLAYS
AGAINST OUR COMMUNITY. DID YOU
EIGHT PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
TRANSFORMING OF COLOR RIGHT
VIEWED BY SOCIETY UNEMPLOYABLE
UNPROFESSIONAL UNCOMFORTABLE.
AND OFTEN TIMES IMPOSTORS THE
CRIMINALS. WE FACE MANY
BARRIERS IN OUR SOCIETY BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
SERVICES THAT WOULD HELP US
BECOME HEALTHY PEOPLE. BECAUSE
OF THE LACK OF ACCESS TO A
SPECIFIC CARE ARE HEALTH
DETERIORATED. AND IN THE
CONTEXT OF ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN WE ARE TAKING
WHERE BEING A **** BUT OUR
COMMUNITY ATTEMPTING TO BALANCE
OUT FROM RECEIVING HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. WHICH ARE LIFESAVING
FOR MANY OF US AND DID NOT HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH CHILDREN.
TRANSACTION RELATING SUPPORT
FOR TGI PEOPLE ARE IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. FOR SOME OF US
IF MEDICAL AND SURGICAL FOR
SOME OF OUR SOCIAL AND FOR SOME
OF OUR IF BURCHELL. AND FOR
MANY OF OUR ALL OF THE ABOVE.
ALL OF WHICH BY THE HEALTH
OUTCOMES OF PEOPLE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE OF THE
DISCRIMINATION AND THINK MOTHER
COMMUNITY FACELESS HE PUSHES
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY OUT OF
CARE AND TO SEE A DOCTOR DAVID
PRACTICES IN THE BLACK MARKET.
THEY SAY THAT THE LIFE
EXPECTANCY OF A TRANS WOMAN IS
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE. I AM
A LIVING TESTAMENT THIRTY
PROVIDED WITH THE APPROPRIATE
SUPPORT AND RESOURCES ONE CAN
BECOME HEALTHY PERSON HE-
BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT THAT I
HAVE RECEIVED FROM MEMBERS OF
MY COMMUNITY I WAS ABLE TO
BUILD A REPEAT OF NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION. END UP AN
ORGANIZATION WE ARE WORKING TO
BUILD A HEALTHY TRANS COMMUNITY
AND A BEAUTIFUL STATE. THERE
ARE MANY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
TRANSLATED ACROSS THE STATE
THAT ARE PROVIDING SAFE AND
AFFIRMING SERVICES TO TRANS
GENDER NON CONFORMING INTO SIX
PEOPLE AND NOT LOOKING NOT HELD
IN A HOLISTIC WAY. NOT JUST
MEDICAL OR PHYSICAL. WE NEED TO
IN THE PROVIDER EDUCATION TO
THOSE IN THE MEDICAL FIELD TO
ENSURE THAT TRANS PEOPLE ARE
SAFE. WHEN SEEN. WE NEED TO
BUILD PARTNERSHIPS WITH CLINICS
CREATE COMMUNITY EVENTS THAT
ARE PROVIDE HEALING AND
WELLNESS. BASED PROGRAMMING.
HAVE AFFIRMING MEANT THE WHOLE
SERVICE. AND ADDRESS OF THE
ROOT CAUSE OF THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THAT WE
EXPERIENCE. THE SERVICES THAT
WE NEED ARE SCARCE AND DOES NOT
MEET THAT THE AMOUNT OF THE
NEARLY. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND. PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE HOPING THAT
WITH THE APPROVAL OF THE
TRANSGENDER WELLNESS AN EQUITY
FUND WHERE GOING TO EXPAND THE
CAPACITY OF ORGANIZATIONS TO
CONTINUE. DOING THIS WORK AND
SUPPORT THE HOLISTIC HEALTH OF
TGI PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING PROVIDING CORBETT
NINETEEN RELATE HEALTH. CARE TO
OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY DAY HELLO I HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHALLENGE THE
CURRY ON. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MOVE ON TO OTHERS IN
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. EASTERN
ANYBODY IN THE- IN THE IN THE
VIEWING ROOM. SEE NO ONE ON
WILL OPEN THE LINE ON THE PHONE
FOR- PEOPLE IN SUPPORT JUST
YOUR NAME- AN ORGANIZATION ONLY
PLEASE. MISTER MODERATOR. YES
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
EIGHT ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN TWO EIGHT SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I GET
AFTERNOON AMANDA MCALLISTER
WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA LGBT
Q. HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NOT WORKING FOR. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
TWO FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I AM SORRY I'M SUPPOSED TO BE
IN THE OPPOSITION CUTE NOT BE
SUPPORT Q. OKAY I WILL RELEASE
YOU YOU'LL HAVE A CHOICE CHANCE
TO QUEUE UP FOR THE OPPOSITION
PORTION. WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY
THREE SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN LAURIE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND TEN
THREE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON AT THE COLLECTED
CHAU WITHIN DOCU HOUSE
ADVOCATES AND BOARD MEMBER OF
GENDER JUSTICE LA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN THREE ONE
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU CAN AFTERNOON TAMMY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY TWO NINE ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE A WITH THE TRANS
LOOKING A COALITION AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY THREE TWO NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI KELLY AT
THE GARDEN WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FOUR TWO SEVEN FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I CAN FIND
AT THE NATIONAL THIRTY CANCEL
SHOW OCCURRED AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SEVEN TWO THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE TWO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR LINE FOR MUTE.
MOVING ALONG WILL GO TO LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHT TO
THREE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE ARE NOT OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY LINE YES
TWO SEVEN SEVEN SIR GO AHEAD.
AT ABOUT THAT MY NAME IS
INDEPENDENT TAYLOR AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO ONE EIGHT THE TRANSCEND
ALONG WITH EQUITY FUND- OTHER
TRANSGENDER PERSON WHO'S BASIS
COMMISSION HEALTHCARE AND OUT
OF THE THREE TO THAT IS YES
YOUR NAME IN OUR- NAME AND
ORGANIZATION VISIT. HERE THANK
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO THREE TWO TWO
ZERO ONE OPEN. LINE THREE
TWENTY TWO YOU HAVE AN OPEN
LINE. BUDGET WILL GO TO LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THREE TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DONNA NIGHT AT THE AT THE
MANUAL WITH CALIFORNIA NOT
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TO EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU. LINE THREE TWENTY
FIVE THREE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ENTER WITH THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN FISH
AT NINE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THREE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY LGBT
COMMUNITY SUPPORT THE BILL. CO
SPONSOR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND THAT IS THE END OF THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION- REMINDED ME OF TWO
WITNESSES BOTH ON THE PHONE
pREMIND THEM THAT THEY ARE THEY
HAVE THREE MINUTES EACH AND-
THAT WILL GO AHEAD- MISTER
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
ALIGN RIGHT OKAY- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SPEAK AN OPTICIAN AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN TODAY MY
NAME IS MARK PERRY I'M THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS OLD AND I LIVE IS
THE MAN FOR NEARLY NINE YEARS
I'D HAVE CROSS SEX HORMONE THAT
G. MAJOR SURGERY THAT WENT
THROUGH ALL THE LEGAL CHANGES
YOU TRANSITION FROM HIM ALL THE
MAIL I'M HERE TODAY TO PLEAD
WITH YOU NOT THE SOUND STATE
MONEY FOR TREATMENTS BUT IN THE
END A PERMANENT DAMAGE TO
PEOPLE BODY AND- MANY THE REAL
ME. YEAH SORT OF THIS TOLD YOU.
I'M NOT TRYING. I DON'T YOU I
WAS BORN WAY AND SHE WAS MEANT
TO BE AND I BELIEVE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THAT I WAS. A
MAN TRAPPED A WOMAN'S WHEN I.
STARTED PROCESS I HAD TO MEET
WITH A THERAPIST ALL NEVER
FORGET ONE OF THE SESSIONS. HE
PUT ON A NOTEBOOK LOOK RIGHT
MIND AND SHE SHOULD WEAR OUT.
YOU REALLY HAVE ISSUES WITH
YOUR MOM. AND I WAS STUNNED I
DIDN'T KNOW HOW WE GOT FROM
TALKING ABOUT BEING A MAN TO
TALK ABOUT MY MOTHER. SHE'S
MADE THIS CONNECTION THAT I HAD
THIS THE- WOUND OF REJECTION.
AND BUT I KIND OF LOOK BETTER I
DID WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT IS
EVER SO MUCH PAIN THERE I JUST
WANTED TO ESCAPE AND BECOME
THE- MAN. AND SO I WENT OUT SHE
JUST ALLOWED ME TO GO DOWN OF
LEGAL PROCESS. AND SHE JUST
GAVE ME WHAT I WANTED ME IN
THIS DIAGNOSIS AND- I TOOK THE
LETTER HE GAVE ME TO THE DOCTOR
BEGAN HORMONE TREATMENTS. AND
BUT AS I WENT DOWN THIS ROAD
AND I WAS THE HAPPIEST PERSON
IT WAS EXCITING. BUT I'D- AFTER
THE- THAT STILL. CHECK THE
PROBLEM. AND THE DEATH FOR AND
NEVER WENT AWAY. AND I REALIZE
THAT. OF THE DOING WITH CHIANG.
CHANGING THE OUTER. BODY CHANGE.
THE BECAUSE- APPEARANCE BUT IT
WASN'T. HELPING THE PROBLEM.
AND THIS IS NOT JUST- MY
OPINION I'VE KNOWN MANY OTHER
TRANSGENDERS NOW THAT WILL TELL
YOU THE SAME THING BUT- ALL
THIS TRANSITION PROCESS THE
STATE. IT NEVER. TRANSITION YOU
INTO THE OTHER TAX- AND- SO I
JUST. I BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATIVE BY ME AS A MAN I
WOULDN'T. AS I WOULD HAVE MY
BREAST FEEDING EXTRA MONEY THAT
OVER THE FEMALE BODY BUT I WAS
REMINDED. EVERY SINGLE DAY OF
THE TRUTH. AND IMAGES NOW REAL
I. TO BUT I FINALLY. THE TRUTH.
THAT I WASN'T BORN IN THE WRONG
BODY IT WAS THAT I DIDN'T WANT
TO BE THE- THAT IS EVER SO MUCH
PAIN THERE. BUT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT I HAD REALIZE THE
TRANSITION WAS NOT BIOLOGICALLY
POSSIBLE. BETTER NEVER GOING TO
BE REAL THE THOUGHT OF BEING
FEMALE IS STILL TOO PAINFUL TO
FACE. BEEN MISTER MY DARKNESS
JESUS CHRIST RESCUED ME OUT OF
THE HELLO THEN. TURN IN MY LIFE
DâN AND I HAVE BEEN A
COMPLETELY SET FREE. TODAY'S
MOST PEOPLE WOULDN'T EVEN GET
THAT I WOULD EVER TRANSGENDER
NOT DEDICATED MY LIFE NOW. TO
TELLING OTHERS ABOUT THE TRUTH
IN THE HOPE THAT I HAVE FOUND.
SOME PLEASE YOU'RE SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN THROUGH THIS HELL
AND I'M FOR YOU TO VOTE NO ON
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. THANK
YOU I WANT TO OUR NEXT WHAT.
YEAH CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
BRIEFLY ABOUT MY CONCERNS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTEEN. HOPEFULLY YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO REVIEW MY LETTER
WHICH I SENT IN TO THE STATE TO
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL LET ME
INTRODUCE MYSELF I AM QUITE AND
LEAVE AND METER BOARD CERTIFIED
PEDIATRIC ENDOCRINOLOGIST
PRACTICE LAND TO GEORGIA. I'M
AN ADJUNCT ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR
OF PEDIATRICS AND BOB OF EMORY
UNIVERSITY AND MORE HOUSE TO
SCHOOL MET AS A MATTER OF
MEDICAL SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN
PRACTICING FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS
MY INDIFFERENT TRAINING WITH AT
JOHNS HOPKINS AT A TIME WHEN
PROFESSOR JOHN MONEYWITH
CLINICALLY EXPERIMENTING WITH
GENDER IDENTITY. I KNEW HIM
PERSONALLY AND WAS CONSTANTLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
ETHICS WITH HIS EXPERIMENTS ON
CHILDREN AND ADULTS. SHORTLY
AFTER I FINISH. FELLOWSHIP AT
PUBLISHED STUDIES SHOWED
CLEARLY THAT THE MENTAL WELL
BEING OF HIS GENDER ALTERED
PATIENTS WAS NOT APPROVED BY
HIS SOCIAL THAT ONE SURGICAL
AFFIRMATION STRATEGIES.
PROGRAMS WERE SHUT DOWN. FORTY
YEARS LATER A STUDY PUBLISHED
JUST LAST WEEK FROM FINLAND
SHOW THAT GENDER IN CONCRETE
CHILDREN. TREATED WITH PRODUCTS
ARMAND HAD SIGNIFICANT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES PRETREATMENT. AND
THESE ISSUES REMAIN DESPITE THE
HORMONE THERAPY. GENDER
CONGRESS KNOW BIOLOGIC BASIS AS
CLEARLY STATED IN THE
PUBLICATIONS BY THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION. IN
THEIR TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
HANDBOOK A DSM FIVE PUBLISHED
BY THE CONCERT YET RECURSOS
HAITIAN. THERE IS A SOCIAL
STRUCTURE TODAY'S WORLD THE
TERM SEX AND GENDER OR
INAPPROPRIATELY USED
INTERCHANGEABLY. ONE TAX IS
CONCRETE AND IMMUTABLE IT CAN
NEVER BE CHANGED. INDIFFERENCE
ASIDE EIGHT DOORS IS AN
AFFIRMATION OF IN CONCRETE
GENDER WITH THE PROGRAM A STEP
WISE SOCIAL. THAT MEDICAL AND
SURGICAL TREATMENT OF MINOR
CHILLED IN ESTABLISHED
GUIDELINES. WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME THIS. ORGAN AND PUBLISHED.
CONDEMNING THE USE OF STOP. AND
WOMEN BECAUSE A WELCOME AT
BIRTH. SIDE EFFECTS OF SUCH
TREATMENT. THE LEFT AND APPEARS
NOT TO KNOW WHAT THE. RIGHT
HAND IS DOING. DEVELOPING
CHILDREN THAT ARE OFTEN FACED
WITH AB EVENTS OF NO OF THEIR
OWN PAY REACTIVE EVENTS AND
ATTACK. THEM CREATING ANXIETY
DEPRESSION AND THEY COME. SIR
FOR A WAY. WHEN THE CHILDREN
SEE A PATH OF REALLY IS NATURE
THEM TO TAKE A CHANCE AND
EDUCATE TO WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS
A BETTER PLACE. THINK OF A
CAROUSEL IN A PARK BECKONING TO
A COUPLE CHILD WITH PROMISES OF
RIDES ON PONIES AND DOLPHINS.
THE COTTON CANDY OFFERED AT
EVERY TURN AS THE CHILD THEY
WANT TO GET ON THEY WILL SAY
YES ASKING AFTER ONE RIGHT IF
THEY WANT TO GET OFF AND TO
RETURN TO A PAINFUL PLACE. THEY
WILL SAY NO ASK THEM IF THEY'RE
HAPPY ON THE RIDE AND THEY WILL
SAY YES CALL THEM ON THE
CAROUSEL RIGHT FOR TEN YEARS IN
THERE BE A CHANGE IN THEIR
ANSWER. ILUSTRES WORN OFF THAT
THEY'RE SEEKING REAL ANSWERS AS
TO WHY THEY WERE TROUBLED IN
THE FIRST PLACE. MEDICAL
LITERATURE AND TESTIMONY THE
PLANTED ALL TO RETURN TO IT I'M
GOING TO GENDER AND SEX. THE
CAROUSEL IS IN THE END A
CIRCULAR HELL THOSE WHO WERE
LED TO BELIEVE THAT AFFIRMATION
IS THE ANSWER TO THEIR PRAYERS
WILL COME BACK THROUGH LEGAL
MEANS. AND HOLD OF ALL THOSE
WHO BUILT THE CAROUSEL WHO RAN
THE CAROUSEL AND FOUGHT NOW THE
SOFFIT TO POLISH THE BREATH
POLLS AND SIR COTTON CANDY IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE PEOPLE ON
BOARD. PLEASE RECONSIDER YOUR
PROPOSED TO FUND CAROUSEL PRICE.
L. Q. EIGHTY THREE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHER
WITNESS IN OFFICE MISTER
MODERATING MAY OPEN THE QUEUE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO JUST
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
ONLY PLEASE BOTH. THANKS AGAIN
ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO PUT
YOURS AND THE QUEUE WILL GO TO
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
TWO FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MICHELLE
NEW AND I'M IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. Q. ONE
ADELINE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN TO ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS MONICA DENVER.
YEAH MY BEING HEARD YES. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS MONICA STAMBERG
WITH AWAKE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
AM IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
THREE THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHECK YOUR LINE FOR SELF
NEW THREE THIRTY THREE. WILL
MOVE ALONG TO LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THREE ONE
THAT. HELLO YES SHOWING HIM HI
MY NAME IS ANGELICA CARRILLO ON
FROM THE TRUNK BUT THEN I
COALITION IN LOS ANGELES AND I
SUPPORT THERE THANK YOU OKAY
WERE MATHEMATICIAN CHANGE AT
THIS TIME. GO GO TO LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN THAT'S TWO
ONE EIGHT. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
AT WINNER- WITH REBUILD RENEW
RESTORE MINISTRY AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL THANK YOU.
YOU. WELL THE LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX THREE
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE THIRTY WE'RE HEARING
AUDIO WE HEAR YOU NOW. THANK
YOU I DO APOLOGIZE FOR CALLING
YOU'RE IN THE WRONG SECTION BUT
I AM CALLING MANY THE BOX THE
EMIR AND CALLING IN FROM
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO ONE
EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. OVER THE LINE TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX TWO EIGHT
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MONEY ON A LOT I AM A
TRANSGENDER WOMAN FIFTY YEAR
OLD LIVING IN CALIFORNIA AND
I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL. OKAY WE ARE BOOKING
ONLINE THIS IS OPPOSITION NOW
WE'VE HAD SUPPORT TESTIMONY SO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE THREE THREE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS TERRA MICHAEL GASPING
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YES. I AM
WITH YOU FORWARD AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TO ME TOO
EIGHTEEN- SORRY COULDN'T
CONNECT JOB EARLIER FOR THE
SUPPORT LINE BUT. WE'LL GO TO
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO. LINE IS OPEN HI MY NAME IS
JOY VIOLADAS I AM ON THAT
TAKING ON BEHALF OF THE ALL OF
THE MONEY A PROJECT I WASN'T
ABLE TO CALL INEARLIER BUT I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THAT THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY BODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. WE DON'T KNOW UNTIL
THEY ACTUALLY OPEN THEIR LINES
AND STARK AS BIG SUR. MY HOPE
PEOPLE LISTENING RECOGNIZE LINE
TO JUST REITERATE WE WE'VE
TAKEN POSITION WE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION SO IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE WAITING TO TESTIFY- THIS
FOR OPPOSITION ONLY THANK YOU.
AS OUR- IF YOU SHOULD FIND
YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE AND IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM THE QUEUE BY REPEATING THE
ONE AND ZERO COMMAND. LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
THREE FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME'S ARIANNA
PRICES. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES YES.
A I MY ANA PLACER FROM
CALIFORNIA AND PART OF THE
TRANSLATION I'M AND YOU SUPPORT
OF TWO TWO ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU.
AGAIN IF YOU'RE CURRENTLY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM THE QUEUE BY REPEATING THE
ONE IN ZERO COMMAND WILL GO TO
LINE THREE ZERO SIX THREE OO
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES GREG
BURKE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OKAY LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
THREE FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI YES. HI MY NAME IS
LYDIA MY RESIDENT FROM OAKLAND
I'M A NON BINARY PERSON AND BUT
AND I WAS TOLD BY THE OPERATOR
THAT I COULD STILL EIGHT BY
SUPPORT SO I AM. THEY GIVE IT.
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
THREE ONE THREE. HI HERE IN
ENGLAND CAPITAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE THREE ONE TWO. LINE
THREE ONE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
WE'RE HEARING AUDIO. WILL MOVE
ALONG TO LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE THREE FOUR NINE.
NINE THREE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN WE'RE HEARING AUDIO.
CLOSE THAT LINE WILL GO TO LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO
THREE FIVE TWO NINE AND OPEN.
HELLO THIRTIES WERE FOLKS THAT
WERE IN SUPPORT HELLO WE'LL GO
AHEAD TO THE NEXT ONE WHICH IS.
THREE FORTY THREE FOUR ZERO. HI
HI MY NAME IS EITHER ON A LIVE
CAMERA DISCO AND TO HAVE
PROBLEMS BUT I MEAN FOR THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWO ONE EIGHT. I THANK
YOU. I'LL GO TO LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE THREE
TWO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MA'AM. MY NAME IS CLARA
CAROUSEL CALLING FROM FULLER
CAN CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS THANK YOU.
YOU AND WE HAVE ONE MORE FROM
THE LINES THREE FIFTY FIVE
THREE FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YESTERDAY I WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO CONNECT- LAYER BUT MY
NAME'S NATHAN PUNCHER AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO NO MORE Q. AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEE NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER SANTIAGO-
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MUCH A LOVE TERRACE ALL THIS
BILL HAS NOT TO DO WITH CARE
CELLS. AND MUCH OF THE
OPPOSITION TO. I'M FOCUSING ON
THE SURGICAL- PRACTICE OF THIS
WHICH IS A VERY VERY MINOR
COMPONENT MOST OF IT WRAPPED
AROUND. WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
SERVICES- AND THAT IS VERY
NEEDFUL TO THE T. G. I.
COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU ARE HERE MOTION FOR THE
BILL. A MOTION BY MISTER
AGUILAR CURRY A SECOND BY MISS
WELL I'M SORRY BY MISS BURKE
I'M SORRY ABOUT AND THE SECOND
BY MISS KOREA. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN
MOTION IS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I WOULD I
MAYES. AGUILAR CURRY. I GET
CURRY I BIGELOW BONTA BONTA AYE
BURKE WHAT BURKE I TO RIO.
CORREO I FLORA LIMóN. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING. I NINE
KNOWS ZERO BILL IS OUT IT WAS
OUT WITH THE ROLE OF THE FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
MISTER SANTIAGO MISTER TEEN YOU
HAVE BILL AB. TWO ZERO SEVEN
SEVEN. YOUR FIRST LET ME JUST
THANK YOU FOR COMMITTEE ALL
WITH THEIR AMENDMENTS AND HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE TO
SUNSET THE BILL AFTER FIVE
YEARS. AB TWO ZERO SEVEN SEVEN
EXTENSION OF THE BILL I CARRIED
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN. FORTY THREE WHICH
FALLS PHARMACIES TO SELL
SYRINGES AND FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE
SYRINGES WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION.
THANK YOU- MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED STUDIES HAVE
CONSISTENTLY SHOWED IMPROVEMENT
ACCESS OR TO REDUCES THE RATE
OF SEVEN SHOWING AND DISEASE
TRANSMISSION. IN ADDITION WE
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCLUDED THAT THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE OF AN INCREASE IN
DRUG USE WAR CRIMES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO SEATED.
WITH AUTHORIZED FILL OF
SYRINGES AGAIN WE'VE SEEN THAT
THIS IS A SAFE PART OF THE TO
GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTICE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE BUT WE
ARE GLAD BOXES FOR THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE AS A WITNESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR LIKE TO OPEN THE LINE
FOR MR BACCHUS A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
KAREN COMMITTEE MANAGE ONE BACK
ON BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND A CO
SPONSOR. THE HEALTH OFFICER'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
FACT THIS BILL AID FOUNDATION.
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF. BASED ON
THIRTY YEARS OF RESEARCH THIS
BILL IS NOT CONTROVERSIAL
AMONGST PUBLIC HEALTH.
PROFESSIONAL THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA RETAILER
EXPLOITATION. AND NUMEROUS
HEALTH POLICY AND TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE. IT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
US CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION YOU AN EIGHT AND
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
MODERATING MAY OPEN THE QUEUE
FOR OTHERS IN SUPPORT JUST
THEIR NAME AND POSITION ONLY. I
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE LINES SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GEN FLORI ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE'RE GONNA LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE THREE
FIVE ONE. RIGHT VENTURE WITH
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BUT ONLINE THREE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN THREE ONE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN MARIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
IMPORT THANK YOU. GOOD LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
THREE FIVE ACRE LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AT
THE SHOW MUCH MORE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION I'M
HAPPY TO WAIT UNTIL I YOU'RE
TAKING A POST AT THE MONEY. IF
YOU LIKE. I THINK IF YOU. WELL
THE LINE THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN THREE ONE EIGHT.
CAPTION INITIAL GIVEN THAT THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE THE
CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GROWING
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE
THREE FIVE NINE. THIS IS LINDA
MARTIN ON THE UPDATES
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
SIX ZERO. YES THIS IS ROBERT
HERRICK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY THEY CAN MEDICINE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
LINE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR TWO SEVEN FOUR. FIVE
HUNDRED BONTA THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND THAT ENDS THE QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION WE
DO IT IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM IN THE- IN THE VIEWING
ROOM. SEE NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE. PLEASE OPEN THE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR- PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT HERE IN
OPPOSITION IT'S ONE NINE ZERO
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT THREE FIVE
EIGHT. BUT THEY'VE TAKEN CELLS
OUT OF THE QUEUE IT LOOKS LIKE.
AND NOW THEY'RE BACK. FIND
THREE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH MURKY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSING AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SEVEN- WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT BEING
TO ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU THREE MEN. WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENCOURAGING OR
AT LEAST THE FACILITATING TRACK
HERE. OVER THE YEARS AND
PROFESSIONALLY TO PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I THANK HER FOR
CONTROL SUBSTANCES ACTION HAVE
BEEN DRAMATICALLY WE USE. OUR
BY REMOVING THE POSSIBILITY OF
A FELONY CONVICTION PROMOTE
BACK THE THAT AS MUCH OF THE
MEETING ENCOURAGEMENT THAT BY
THE USER WHAT BUG BUT AT THE
RATED. AS MANY YOU ALREADY KNOW
MAKE HEALTH WE NEED. SHARKS IN
HOMELESS THAT GOING PUBLIC DRUG
USE AND KERR CRANE AND THANK
YOU DISORDERS. PATIENT ART GAIL
SO FORTY THREE WE ASK YOU TO
PLEASE WE- TELL AT THAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE THREE FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES THIS IS JAN AND
MARIA AND I OPPOSE. THANK YOU
VISIT. AND THAT IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WOULD
LIKE CLOSEST SORRY. THIS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I SEE A LOT OF GROUPS
FROM THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BUT I ALSO
DOES HAVE SOME CONCERNS WHEN IT
COMES TO JUST THE
ACCESSIBILITY. OVER GETTING
FOLKS TO CONTINUE- WITH
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL TO THEIR
LIVES WHILE AT THE SAME TIME.
REDUCING FUNDING THAT HELPS
PEOPLE GET OFF SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND HELPS WITH THEIR DRUG
ADDICTION SO I FEEL LIKE IT'S
THE IT'S A- IS THE LEGISLATION
THAT'S BOLD AND HAVE A LOT OF
INITIATIVE BEHIND IT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME. THE SAFETY NET FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED THAT
SUPPORT. IS ACTUALLY RECEIVING
LESS FUNDING. AND SO I'M I'M
JUST I'M AT A LOSS BECAUSE IN
IN THE CITY OF LA IN THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD
WITH. LAW ENFORCEMENT. THERE
HAVE BEEN MULTITUDE HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS WOULD SYRINGES ON
THE GROUND OFFICERS THAT HAVE
BEEN ATTACKED INSTEAD BY
INDIVIDUALS WITH SYRINGES.
FEMALE OFFICERS WHO HAVE HAD TO
HAVE HIV AIDS ANOTHER TEST
TESTING DONE BECAUSE THEY'VE
BEEN ATTACKED BECAUSE OF THE
EXCESSIVE SYRINGES. AND I'M
JUST NOT NECESSARY I DON'T
NECESSARILY FEEL COMFORTABLE
THAT THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AT THIS TIME.
AND SOME JUST CURIOUS- TO THE
AUTHOR LIKE WHAT HIS THOUGHTS
ARE ON HOW WE WOULD ADDRESS.
THE LACK OF SAFETY NET. OF
LAWMAKING SYRINGES MORE
ACCEPTABLE. QUESTION VERY
REASONABLE QUESTION SO
REGARDING THE STATE THAT I THE
SAME CONCERNS THAT YOU DO WE
ARE I PRESIDENT TIME REGARD OUR
BY THIS NOT THE BUDGET THAT WE
HAVE TO. HAVING WE ARE CAN
ABOUT THE BUDGETARY. ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AS WELL A HUMAN SERVICES
HAVING SAID THAT THAT IS NOW
WITH BILL IS IF YOU GO WITH THE
FIRST. THAT SOMEHOW GRAY ACCESS
TO SURRENDER SOMEHOW. INCREASE
RIGHT YOU INCREASE CRIED
THERE'S REALLY NO STAR THAT.
FIFTY WORKS. SO IF YOU ACTION.
ACCESS TO SURRENDER. WHAT YOU
HAVE IS. THE DRUG YOU. PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO DO THAT THEY WOULD
JUST DO SO THIRTY SO. OR WORSE
COMES WORST THING SHARESTHE
RICHNESS SO THAT IS HOW LIKE
HIV WAR. THAT IS DISEASE LIKE
THAT'S HOW THESE. SO AGAIN YOU
TALK TO EVERY SO JUST ABOUT
EVERY SINGLE PUBLIC HEALTH BUT
DOWN THE STATE. THEY WILL TELL
THAT THIS IS VERY MEDICALLY FOR
FROM HEALTH POINT OF VIEW AB
THE RIGHT THING TO. SINCE
FOURTEEN WHEN I CARRIED MY. WE
HAVE NOW CREATED THE MOST
EXTENSIVE TAKE BACK PROGRAM
WITH PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND
SYRINGES IS I THINK THERE'S
REALLY TWO YOUR THREE SEPARATE
THINGS MENTION IS WE NEED MAKE
SURE THAT OUT OF TO SPOIL OF
WHICH I COLLECT AGREE YOU MORE.
THAT'S WHY WE SB TWO ONE IS THE
COMPREHENSIVE WITH THE INDUSTRY
SUPPORT AND WITH THE BOOK
WORKING WITH INDUSTRY TO ENSURE.
THERE WAS SOME TO UPON THE MANY
TO NOT JUST AND SELL THE RIDGES
OF BUT THEY'VE WERE OUT OF JUST
OF ALSO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THT WE'RE GONNA FIGHTING FOR
SOCIAL SERVICES IN THE SERVICE
WITHIN BUDGET CONTACT. BUT IT.
IF YOU DON'T THE BILL WHAT IT
DOES IS IT WILL BE BE WITH
DECREASE TO CLEAN SERVE. ENABLE
ENCOURAGED TO SHOW THIRTY AND
TRANSMIT. TO SO THAT'S WITH THE
FOR THAT WERE WE'RE TRYING 2%
WITH THE. SEEING GREATER
SUCCESS WITH THE BILL BECAUSE
AGAIN OF THE REDUCTION IN
TRANSMISSION OF THESE DISEASES
AND THAT THAT'S THE POOL WITH
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OTHER QUESTIONS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. MISS
WALDRON. THANK YOU- SO THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
PHARMACIST TO ACTUALLY GIVE
INFORMATION TO THE PERSON.
DOESN'T IT AS FAR AS YOU KNOW
SAFE DISPOSAL- DISEASE
TRANSMISSION OR OTHER THINGS.
SO THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
THEY WOULDN'T GET OTHERWISE I
WAS JUST. YOU KNOW THE CONCERN
THAT. I GUESS IT'S THE SECOND
OF LEADING CAUSE OF HIV
TRANSMISSION. THROUGH A NEEDLE
SO JUST FIGURE ELABORATE ON
THAT NOR WILL WE THEN THE FACT
THAT MANY OF THE PHARMACIES
EVEN SINCE WE LAST PRODUCED A
BILL IN TWENTY FOURTEEN HAVE
ACTUALLY IS A TO TAKE BACK
PROGRAMS AND SO WHILE THEY'RE
SELLING SYRINGES THEY'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH. CLIENTELE TO TAKE
BACK THE SYRINGES SO IN MY CITY
IT'S VERY COMMON THAT IF YOU
BUY SYRINGES IN THE CITY
COUNCIL FRANCISCO YOU GET A
TAKE BACK DISPOSAL BUT GET THE
UC AND MOST HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES SO THAT YOU HAVE
SOMETHING TO PUT IT IN BECAUSE
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT IS COMMON IS
THAT A LOT OF WERE DISPOSED OF
SO THEY PUT IN THE TRASH. THEN
IT'S NOT VERY DANGEROUS TO FOR
ALL THE WASTE HAULERS BECAUSE
IT'S A COMPLETELY SEPARATE-
VOICESTREAM THAT THIS GOES ON.
YEAH I WE ARE THE WAY TOO MUCH
ABOUT SYRINGES NOW AFTER TO
WORKING ON THIS FOR THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS IS ALSO VERY FEW
PLACES WERE SYRINGES GO TO BE
DISPOSED OF ACTUALLY IN THIS
COUNTRY SO YOU CAN'T WHERE
WOULD IT WOULD HOSPITALS GET
SYRINGES IN A TAKE THEM
SOMEWHERE. THEY ACTUALLY DON'T
TAKE THEM TO THE DUMP LIKE WE
DO THE BEST WAY STATE THE ONLY
A FEW PLACES IN THE COUNTRY
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY GO TO BE
INCINERATED SO EFFECTUALLY. A
DIFFICULT TO VARIOUS OF. HOW
THEY COULD DISPOSE OF SO. AGAIN
REALLY REALLY DO A- THAT
QUESTION. IT IS AN UP. FOR
AGAIN. THE PHARMACY TO PROVIDE
GREAT EDUCATE ABOUT VARIOUS
RESOURCES. BOTH FOR HELP THIS
IS MY CALLING FROM LA PRADA BUT
ALSO. WE'RE TO DISPOSE OF THE
ITEMS WHICH IS ALSO AN ISSUE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. SEEING NO ONE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
TING I'LL JUST TAKE OUT MICHAEL
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MISTER SANTIAGO TO
HAVE A SECOND. SECOND BY MISS
BURKE. THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD ARE WOOD I
MADE. MAYES I ARGUE OUR CURRY I
GET VERY AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NO BONTA BONTA I'D EVER. BURKE
HI CARILLO. CORREO I FLORA.
LIMóN RT NAZARIAN RAMOS. RAMOS
NOT VOTING RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I'D WALDRON WALDRON
AYE. EIGHT I WON NO BILL PASSES
BILLS THAT WILL LEAVE THE ROLL
UP AND FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU MISTER TING. SEE NEXT
IS- PLEASE MR BONTA PRESENTING
FOR MISS WICKS- AB. TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND I
BELIEVE SOMETHING MEMBER
WICKS'S ON THE LINE SO SHE'S
HERE WITH US IN COULD HELP
ANSWER QUESTIONS IF NECESSARY
BEFORE THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE- FIRST OF ALL FOR
YOUR HELP WITH THE BILL. AND
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL FOR WE'RE TAKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. AND AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN EXTENDS THE
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION PERIOD FOR
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
FACILITIES. THAT PLAN TO
DOWNGRADE SERVICES CHANGE THEIR
SERVICES OR CLOSE A FACILITY
CURRENTLY THE NOTIFICATION
PERIODS ARE NOT ENOUGH FOR
COMMUNITIES TO VOICE THEIR
CONCERN TO EXPLORE THIS OTHER
SOLUTIONS. FACT ABOUT TO
IDENTIFY OTHER HEALTH CARE
OPTIONS. AND WE SEEN AND FELT
THE PANIC IN CONCERN FIRSTHAND
IN HOSPITAL I WOULD HOSPITALS
HAVE CLOSED IN THE EAST BAY IN
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA. THESE NEED MORE
NOTICE AND TIME WHEN HOSPITALS
CLOSE. AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOU I YOU'RE
MOMENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL. ARE WITH ME HERE TODAY
TESTIFYING. VIRTUALLY ARE
TAYLOR JACKSON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND SERRA FOX FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION. DO
YOU HAVE A NOTE THAT MS WEEKS
IS GOING TO SAY A FEW WORDS. IS
THAT CORRECT I'M SORRY I MISSED
HERE I DID HAVE A NOTE THAT MS
WEEKS WAS GOING TO SAY A FEW
WORDS OR IS SHE JUST ON THE
LINE FOR TECHNICAL SUPPORT-
SEVEN. WEEKS IS IT AVAILABLE
AYE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
SAY A FEW WORDS OF COURSE A
TURBULENT SHE IS WALKING TO SAY
WHATEVER HE LIKES- IF IT'S OKAY
WITH CHAIR. ARE YOU OUT OF.
MISTER MODERATOR YOU CAN OPEN
THE LINE. FOR SUPPORT AND- IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE THIS WICKS
WOULD LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING.
HAPPY TO TAKE. TAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY YEAH. HI HI MR HERE
CAN YOU HEAR ME OF COURSE. OKAY
GREAT THANK THANKS EVERYONE-
STRANGE TIMES WE'RE LIVING IN
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME DO
SOME ABOUT TESTIFYING HERE I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE IT SH- AS
MENTIONED WE WILL BE TAKING THE
COMMITTEE THEN AND- WE ALL ALL
KEEP THAT REMARKS BRIEF BUT YOU
KNOW CURRENTLY HOSPITALS THE-
PLAN BECAUSE YOU'RE DONE
READING SERVICES ARE ONLY
REQUIRED TO GIVE A NINETY DAY
NOTICE AND PLEASURE. YOU KNOW
WE FEEL THAT THREE MONTH IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME FOR COMMUNITIES TO
WAKE UP TURNS TO THE LOCAL
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ARE FINAL
TURNING OF LOCATIONS FOR
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE- IN A PLAN
TO COMPLETE. THEIR HEALTHCARE
NEEDS ARE HEALTH IN MY WITH THE
ON GOING DOWN THE- YOU KNOW
COVER NINE. CRISIS THE MORE
TIME TO ADVOCATE THEMSELVES
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL REALLY. TO
DO IT. GIVE IT A BIT MORE TIME
TO WE NEED SHE- TO ADDRESS.
CONCERN IN OUR COMMUNITY MY
DISTRICT- EIGHTY FIFTEEN WE
THOUGHT DOCTORS HOSPITAL CLOSE.
IN ANOTHER PART OF MY DISTRICT
AND LOCK COUPLE YEARS. YOU KNOW
ALL THE BASES FACING CLOSURES
AS WELL. YOU KNOW THESE HAVE
MASSIVE IMPACT ON OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ARE OVERLY
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW FAMILIES
WHO CANNOT- CAN YOU EASILY- TO
RECEIVE AN EMERGENCY CARE SO
THAT THE REALLY EXPAND. IT'S A
PRETTY SIMPLE DAHLE EXTEND THE
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION VERY
PROFITABLE HELP FACILITIES-
THAT PLAN TO DOWNGRADE- CHANGE
OUR SERVICE OR CLOSE THEIR
FACILITY- THAT. KATIE ALL
LEADING THE- TESTIFY REMOTELY
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK YOUR AYE THOSE. THANK YOU
MUCH SO WE DO HAVE A WITH IN
THE WITH. VIEW ROOM. IF YOU
WANT TO GO TO THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES FIRST ON THE PHONE.
WITH THIS IS A SUPPORT WITNESS
IN THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOMS
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY NEVER MIND
I'M SORRY. I'M A RECORD READ MY
OWN NOTES WRONG SO I'M SORRY
THESE ARE THESE ARE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE MY
APOLOGIES PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON A
FRIDAY AFTER TURN MEMBER. HI
DOCTOR WHAT CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY MISTER TURN MEMBER THANK
YOU CAN LOOK BACK THEN THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
OR THE FUNCTIONS OF THE BILL AB
FOURTEEN IT'S SIMPLY ASKING FOR
ADEQUATE NOTICE WHAT I HOPE
WILL DECIDE TO CLOSE OUR
ELIMINATED APARTMENT. AB
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WORK THAT THE
MEMBER BUDGET THAT GRIEF NOTED
TIME LINES UNDER THE BILL MEANS
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR YOUR CITY
AND MORE TIME FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THEY WILL RECEIVE
HEALTHCARE OR WHERE THEIR NEXT
JOB WILL BE. HOSPITALS ARE
UNIQUE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND
A VITAL PART OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST BOB MAYBE RUN BY
CORPORATIONS THEY ARE STILL IN
THE BUSINESS OF PUBLIC. AB ONE.
TO PATIENTS. IN OUR NEW LAN OF
THE NIGHT OF THE ONE. WE
PRESERVE A Q. KERR FOR. WHEN IT
ALL. THE BAND SIMILAR NOTE OVER.
A FIVE PART OF FROM SUPPORT THE
ASSEMBLY LAST YEAR AND NURSES
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THIS VITAL PUBLIC
HEALTH POLICIES. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
MIX. WITH WITNESS MISS FLOCKS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SERRA
FLOCKS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION- WE SUPPORTED
EIGHTY TEN FOURTEEN LAST YEAR
AND I WOULD SAY AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN. IT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT IN THAT THE CURRENT
CONTACT IT'S UNCLEAR THE IMPACT
THAT PANDA. AND THE ENSUING
ECONOMIC CRISIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN HOSPITALS WE EXPECT THAT
WE ARE GOING TO SEE
CONSOLIDATION DOWNGRADING OF
SERVICE. OR EVEN CLOSURES. AND
IN MANY CASES. THAT WILL
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF I TO YOU
WHEN HOSPITAL BEDS THAT WE
HAVE. AND IT URBAN AND IN RURAL
AREAS AND SO DEATH NOTIFICATION
TO THE PUBLIC IS EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT SO THAT COMMUNITIES
CAN HAVE THE TIME TO PREPARE.
THAT HEALTHCARE WORKERS CAN
HAVE THE TIME TO PREPARE WE
KNOW THAT HOSPITALS PLAN THESE
KIND OF CLOSURES. IF NOT YEARS
THAN MANY MONTHS IN ADVANCE AND
WE THINK THE PUBLIC SHOULD HAVE
AN EQUAL LEVEL OF NOTIFICATION
SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR OTHERS
IN SUPPORT JUST THEIR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE. AS IF
YOU'D LIKE TO VOICE YOUR
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME WE WILL GO TO
LINE THREE FORTY ONE THAT THREE
FOUR ONE. ABOUT WHICH A FROM AT
THE CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT UP.
TO THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND THAT WAS THE ONLY ONE
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU-
WE HAVE OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE
HAVE OPPOSITION IN THE- VIEWING
ROOM THE WITNESS VIEWING ROOM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS CAP AS HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
OF WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT-
BUT THEY REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT
THE LENGTH OF TIME IN THE
NOTIFICATION BILL REQUIRED-
UNFORTUNATELY. THE SUPPORTERS
ARE CORRECT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR HOSPITALS HEALTH
CARE- ENVIRONMENTS IN
PARTICULAR THERE FISCAL IMPACT-
DUE TO THE KOBE CRISIS BEFORE
THE CODE CRISIS ONE IN THREE
HOSPITALS WERE SHOWING SIGNS OF
FISCAL DISTRESS- WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT MORE WILL SHOW
THOSE SIGNS. ARE A POSITION IS
OPPOSING LESS AMENDED- WE ARE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE THIRTY
DATE NOTIFICATION MAY BE
DIFFICULT FOR COMMUNITIES SO
WE- OPPOSED TO BILL
RECOMMENDING THAT WE MAINTAIN
THE NINETY DAY NOTIFICATION.
FOR THE SUPPLEMENTAL SERVICES
BECAUSE WE TRYING TO BALANCE
THE FISCAL CRISIS OF THE
HOSPITAL WITH THE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS WERE CONCERNED
THAT SIX MONTHS MAYBE TOO LONG
TO BALANCE THAT. MAINTAINING
EMPLOYEES AND SAFETY LEVELS
FOR. THE PATIENT SAFETY LEVELS
AT THE SAME TIME IN ADDITION WE
ARE- PROPOSING THAT WE EXPAND
THE THIRTY DAY NOTIFICATION TO
SIXTY DAYS. I'M THIS WILL ALLOW
COMMUNITIES TO RESPOND BUT AT
THE SAME TIME ALLOW US TO
BALANCE AGAIN- THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE RELATED TO LOSING
EMPLOYEES DURING THIS TIME- AND
BALANCING PATIENTS. CONCERNS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE ANYONE ELSE IN OP. THIS
WOULD BE ON THE PHONE- MISTER
MODERATELY MAY OPEN THE LINE
FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION NAME
AND ORGANIZATION ONLY. IF YOU
DON'T HAVE OPPOSITION YOU WIS
TO VOICE SUITS ONE AND ZERO WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NEAR MARTIN WITH A
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
OF THE STATION AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN TWO ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE'S
THAT SHORT ON THE HAVE THE
ALLIANCE THE CATHOLIC
HEALTHCARE ADVENTIST HEALTH
LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY HEALTH
AND PEACH CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE
SAFETY NET HOSPITAL. I'M
OPPOSED PENDING REVIEW OF THE
AMENDMENT. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE SEVENTY FOUR THREE SEVEN
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MEGAN
LOW PER ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION HAVE
SIMILAR TO THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION HI THE
REMAIN OPPOSED NOTHING LIKE
THAT. THANK YOU. AMBER LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
THREE HUNDRED ON YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN BERKELEY DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF DISTRICT TALKED
LEADERSHIP FORUM WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE WHAT MINUTE POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE ONE MORE THAT JUST CUED UP
GIVE US ONE MOMENT OKAY. LINE
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THREE SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THEY'RE VERY HAPPY AT THE
VISION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
pYOU. AND NOT EXHAUST THE QUEUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE AUTHOR. SELECT THE
KALRA SEIZING THE COMMITTEE
FIRST EXCUSE ME QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S LIKE THE CLOTHES. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
WANNA SAY THAT I THINK THE
NORTH PERIODS PROPOSED IN THE
BILL ARE SIGNIFICANT AND
MEANINGFUL BUT NOT EXCESSIVE IN
THE STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. MOTION BY MISTAKE
YOUR CRUISE AT A SECOND PROMISE
FOR. OKAY EITHER WAY OKAY WELL
YOU GUYS ARE I KEEP YOU KIND OF
SUPERIMPOSED UPON EACH OTHER
OVER THERE IT'S HARD TO SEE SO
WE HAVE A MOTION WILL SAY WILL
GIVE THIS ONE A MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BY MISS
BURKE. THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN MOTION
USED TO PASS THIS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD FIVE WOULD
I'D MAYES. MAYES NOW OUR GEAR
CURRY. I GET CURRY II BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO BONTA BONTA I BURKE.
BURKE I RIO CARILLO ICE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING LIMóN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RAMOS. RAMOS NOT
VOTING RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON NOW.
SIX I THREE KNOWS BILL IS ON
CALL IT WILL BE THAT THE LONG
KERR WE'RE MOVING TO OUR FINAL
THREE BILLS AND WE WILL HAVE
THE VICE CHAIR TAKE OVER IN OUR
PRESENT FROM MY DESK HERE SO. I
THINK WE'LL START WITH- AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY SEVEN THAT'S
OKAY. THANK YOU RICH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY SEVEN
ENSURES THAT THE CALIFORNIA'S
SUBSIDIES WE PASSED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT CONTINUE TO
HELP LOWER PREMIUMS. AND GIVE
CAP COVER CALIFORNIA THE
FLEXIBILITY NEEDS TO DEVELOP
PROGRAM DESIGNED. TO MAXIMIZE
HELP TO INDIVIDUALS UNDER 6100%
OF THE FEDERAL FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. THIS MEANS THAT THOSE
WERE MAKING LESS THAN SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN
POTENTIALLY RECEIVE MORE
ASSISTANCE TO MAKE HEALTHCARE
PREMIUMS MORE AFFORDABLE. THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO CURRENTLY
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES THIS PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE CRITICAL NOW MORE
THAN EVER TELL PEOPLE FOR
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE DURING THE-
PANDEMIC. IN SUPPORT DIANE WAS
ON THE PHONE FROM HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA I RESPECT REQUEST
PLEASE RESPECT AND I WILL. THE
MOTION BY MISTER AGUILAR CURRY
AND A SECOND BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ AND WE WILL GO TO THE
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DIANA
DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACTED CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE
HEALTH CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION. THESE THE SPONSOR AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY SEVEN LITTLE
SAFEGUARD COVER CALIFORNIA
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES TO HELP KEEP
INSURANCE AFFORDABLE.
CALIFORNIA TOOK UNPRECEDENTED
ACTION IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABILITY ASSISTANCE NEARLY
ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS AND
ROLLED IN COVER CALIFORNIA.
THESE NEW STATE SEVENTY IS
AUGMENTED EXISTING FEDERAL
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES FOR AND WHAT
LEADS WITH INCOMES BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE AND FIFTY THOUSAND.
ALONG WITH FIRST IN THE NATION
PREMIUM ASSISTANCE FOR MIDDLE
CLASS CONSUMERS MAKING UP TO
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND. OVER
HALF A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
MAKING TWENTY FIVE TO FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR GOT
HELP FROM STATE OF THE IN
ADDITION TO THE FEDERAL. I KNOW
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND MAKING
FIFTY TO SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
GOTTEN AVERAGE OF FIVE HUNDRED
PER MONTH ASSISTANCE FROM THIS
FIRST NATION MIDDLE CLASS HELP.
THE PORTABILITY HEALTH LET MORE
PEOPLE BUY COVERAGE AT HAD A
HIGHER PREMIUM BUT LOWER
DEDUCTIBLES ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT NOW. FOR THOSE WHO
MIGHT UNEXPECTEDLY NEED CARE
BECAUSE OF CLOVER NINETEEN.
WELL THE NAY REVISED CONTINUES
LAST YEAR SUBSIDIES THEY ALSO
CUT ALMOST IN HALF THE TOTAL
AMOUNT INVESTED IN HEALTH CARE.
AFFORDABILITY SUBSIDIES.
BECAUSE YOU WERE RELEASED ON
OFF EXCHANGE PLANS WHICH TO
SUBSIDIZE PLANS ON THE EXCHANGE
THAN EXPECTED LET'S FUNDING WAS
NEEDED FOR THE SUBSIDIES THAN
WAS ORIGINALLY ESTIMATED. AND A
SIGNIFICANT. BACK THE MAYOR.
KATE BUT THE ADMIN. PLANS THREE
POINT TOTALING OVER TO OUR
FIFTY OVER TO YOUR PERIOD WHICH
IS OUR HAD. TO THE FOR. BACK
INTO THE GENERAL FUND. ALREADY
DOLLARS WERE TIGHT SO
COMMITMENT ME IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS TO ME THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT OF
PROVIDING THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF
HELP FOR THOSE BUYING COVERAGE
AND COVER CALIFORNIA. RIGHT NOW
WITH MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WAY TO LOSE THEIR EMPLOYER
BASED COVERAGE IN A TIME WHEN
WE'RE SILL IN THE MIDDLE OF A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC IN FACING
SUBSEQUENT WAVES OF ALMA. NOW
THE TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
GIVE PEOPLE MORE HELPS NOT
LAST. WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY SEVEN AND
ASK FOR YOUR I THOUGHT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
GREAT IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT. THIS
NOTE THAT SO WE'LL GO OR TO THE
TO ME TO USE ON THIS ITEM. ANY.
ANY ME TO USE OF SUPPORT ON
THIS ITEM. I GUESS WILL OPEN UP
THE LINE FOR PUBLIC. MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY. YES I
GUESS WE HAVE TO REMIND REMIND
YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT HERE
MISTER MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY. THAT WISHES TO ADD ON
IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO VOICE
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
THREE SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GEN FLORI ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON IN LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE'S OVERLYING THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN LINE
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. RIGHT
VENTURE WITH THE CALIFORNIA PUT
ADDED MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR TWO
SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE HUNDRED BOND THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND AT THE END OF THE
QUEUE. GREAT IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT WISHES TO REGISTER ANY ARE
THEY WILL ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS THIS ITEM.
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISHES TO
REGISTER ANY OPPOSITION MISTER
MODERATOR. YOU'RE ON THE AUDIO
LINES AND WISH TO VOICE
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THERE IS
NO ONE QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME.
GREAT I GUESS IS THERE ANY THE
INBETWEENERS ON THIS ONE. ALL
RIGHT NO IN BETWEEN IS ON THIS
ONE- I BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND. SEEING NONE-
DOCTOR WILL TALK TO CLOSE IF WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE ABOVE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB TWENTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD FIVE WOOD I MADE BY MAYES
AYE AGUILAR CURRY. A YEAR CURRY
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
BONTA. BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
RIO ICE FLORA FLORA I LIMóN.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RAMOS. RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON AYE. NINE I
ZERO KNOWS BILL PASSES. THE
BILL GOT UP WITH NINE- BUT I
NEEDED TO I DID MAKE A MISTAKE
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY GOT A NOTE
FROM THE SERGEANT THAT MARRIED
JUNE ALSO WANTED TO REGISTER
HER SUPPORT OF THIS. AS WELL
MOVING ON TO AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR. DOCTOR WOULD. IF
YOU MISTER- AND MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
FOUR IS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED
WE SHOULD ALL HAVE A MOCK UP OF
THE PROPOSED LANGUAGE THE ONUS
IS ILLNESS AND DEATH FROM KOBE
NINETEEN IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES IS APPALLING MORE
THAN ONE THIRD OF THE DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN IN THESE
FACILITIES A TRULY SOBERING
NUMBER REPRESENTING SOME OF OUR
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE. THIS
BILL DOES THREE THINGS REQUIRES
A DURING AN EMERGENCY
DECLARATION SUCH AS THE ONE WE
ARE CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY REPORT
EACH SUSPECTED COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE RELATED DEATH TO THE
COUNTY CORONER WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS. A REQUIRES A COUNTY
CORNER TO REPORT THE SUSPECTED
DISEASE RELATED DEATH TO THE
STATE REGISTRAR WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS OF BEING NOTIFIED OF
THE SUSPECTED DISEASE RELATED
TO. AND REQUIRES STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
MAKE THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
SUSPECTED DISEASE RELATED
DEATHS AVAILABLE ON ITS
INTERNAL ITS INTERNET SITE
WEBSITE ON A WEEKLY BASIS.
THERE ARE READY VARIOUS
REQUIREMENTS IN EXISTING LAW
FOR HOW AND WHEN A DEATH IS
REPORTED DEPENDING UPON THE
CIRCUMSTANCE. AND COVER
NINETEEN DEATHS ARE BEING
REPORTED BUT I'M CONCERNED
THEY'RE NOT BE REPORTED AS
TIMELY AS ACCURATELY AS THEY
SHOULD BE. THE BILL IS A
STARTING POINT FOR THE
CONVERSATION I WANT TO HAVE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES STAKEHOLDERS
AND THE ADMINISTRATION. WE NEED
ACCURATE TIMELY DATA TO
UNDERSTAND BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE HIGH NUMBERS OF DEATHS IN
THESE FACILITIES AND SAVE
LIVES. ONE DEATH IS TOO MANY
BUT MORE THAN A THIRD OF THE
DEATHS IS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THE
SECOND I BELIEVE THAT THE
MOTION IS A MISTER BIGELOW THE
SECOND WAS BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
I WILL GO TO ANY WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTERS ARE ANYBODY THAT.
ANY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
DOCTOR WOULD HAVE ANY TESTIMONY
SUPPORT ON THIS ONE NOW THEY
WILL GO TO OPEN IT UP BUT TO
THE PUBLIC AND- MISTER
MODERATOR IS OR ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO COMMENT- IN SUPPORT
IS THE ME TO USE JUST YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AS A
REMINDER TO QUEUE UP FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IT'S ONE
NINE ZERO. AND WE HAVE ONE THAT
JUST CUED UP ALLOW US A MOMENT.
OKAY I HAVE ONE THAT CAN QUEUE
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE THREE
SEVEN NINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT BLOOMBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES- WERE NOT WERE AT
IN- CONCERN POSITION IS THAT
RECENTLY AMENDED BILL WE SHARE
THE CONCERN OF DR WORD ABOUT
THE CO THE PANDEMIC.
DEVASTATING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF CONCERN ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE- BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE ISSUE I SHARE
THAT CONCERN SO AT THIS POINT
HAVE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
CONCERN AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING THAT OUT. AT THE.
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS GOES
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT DOES GO BACK
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS OR ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS- THIS
BILL ANY SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
WITHIN ITS BID IF THERE'S MISS
MODERATE THERE'S NOBODY THERE
THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE- TO A
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE THAT
WILL GO TO- THE PUBLIC A IS
THERE ANY. MEMBER THE PUBLIC
THAT WISHES. TO ADD ON IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. I
THINKWE HAD AN ICHIRO PROP.
YEAH. I THINK WE HAD AT ONE
KILLING UPS. WE DO HAVE SOME NO
ONE. NO NO SIR GREAT. I THINK
WE HAD AN IN BETWEEN- WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
FACILITIES WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. DOCTOR
WILL JUDGE CLOSE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT- WHILE THERE HAS BEEN
SOME AND SOME- GUIDANCE FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
RELATED TO COPE IT. THIS BILL
GOES BEYOND THAT THIS WOULD BE
ANY COMMUNICABLE DISEASE
OUTBREAKS- AND- THE STATE WAS
THAT IN IN IN STATUTE- GOING
FORWARD THAT- YOUR REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS OF A SUSPECTED
DEATH. WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THE MOTION
IN THE SACK. WITH THAT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR MOTION IS DO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WORD
BY WORD I MADE BY MAYES AYE A
DIRECTORY OF YOUR CURRY I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW I'D BONTA.
BURKE BURKE I RIO RIO AYE FLORA
FLORA I LIVE ALONE. PARTY
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS I READ
REGUS RODRIGUEZ ICE SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON AYE. TEN ICE
ZERO KNOWS BILL PASSES. THANK
YOU WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM TODAY
FOR THOSE MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE
THAT MIGHT NEED TO ADD ON IT
MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
HEAD BACK HERE- TO THE TO THE
CHAMBER- SO THAT WE CAN GO
THROUGH THAT BECAUSE IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY- THE
CHAIRMAN SAID THAT WE'RE GOING
TO GO THROUGH IT ONCE AND ONLY.
ONCE SO PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA
FOR YOU TO BEGIN TO COME TO
COME BACK ON THE EIGHTY TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY DOCTOR WOULD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND IF A MEMBER
OUT THERE WANTS TO TAX MISSILE
MON MISTER MCCARTY THAT BE
GREAT SO IT AND ONCE AGAIN OF
THIS WILL WE WILL MAKE ONE PASS
THROUGH THE- CENTER OF THE CALL
AND THEN ADD ONS AS- I'M
WORRIED DOES SAY THANK YOU TO
THIS TO THE- FORGET. ON A THANK
YOU TO MODERATOR YOU HAVE AN-
AND HELPING US GET THROUGH THIS.
PLEASE THANK YOU VERY. I WANT
TO GIVE YOU. PAUSE WE HAVE A
LOT OF BILL HERE AND I'M I'M
REALLY REALLY THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR YOU MADE OUR DAY A
LOT A LOT BETTER- WITH YOUR
FISH AND SEA AND
PROFESSIONALISM SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH THAT I. WANT TO.
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY. FIRST I
AM ACCEPTING MY AMENDMENTS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE IMAGE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IMAGINE THAT.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE PASSED AB
EIGHTEEN TEN OF A BUDGET
TRAILER FOR ASA PAD TO
DEVELOPING COMPLETE A HEALTH
CARE PAYMENTS DATABASE BY JULY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AB
EIGHTEEN TEN ALSO REQUIRED I
SPREAD TO ESTABLISH A REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS UPON THE INPUT
ON THE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS DATABASE. THIS BILL AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY WOULD
ESTABLISH THE SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE COMPLETION
OF A HEALTH CARE- PAYMENTS
DATABASE PROGRAM WITHIN OUR
SPENT. IT ALSO INCORPORATES
MANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THE REVIEW COMMITTEE BUT NOT
ALL TO ACHIEVE THE PURPOSE OF
THE DATABASE WE EXPANDED ON
SOME OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
WHILE BOUNCE IN THE NEED FOR
DATA CONFIDENTIALITY AND
PRIVACY OF INFORMATION. IS WHAT
CALLING FROM HEALTH PLANS
INSURERS DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES PROVIDERS AND
SUPPLIERS ALL NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE A MEANINGFUL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE COST
HEALTHCARE. SURE PLANTS ARE NOT
TAKE THE STATE AUTHORITY WOULD
ALSO BE ALLOWED TO SUBMIT DATA.
CONFIDENTIALITY PRIVACY ACCESS
AND SECURITY REQUIREMENTS HAVE
ALSO BEEN INCLUDED TO GOVERN
THE SUBMISSION ACCESS THE
RELEASE OF ANY DATA. HEALTHCARE
PRICES CONTINUE TO RISE. AND
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
SHOULD NOT JUST BE A GOAL OR
AMBITION FOR POLICY MAKERS.
ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR IS NOT
MOVING FORWARD TO ESTABLISHING
AN OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND HIS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET. ON THE
HEALTH PAYMENTS DATABASE WILL
BE ON THE FOUNDATION FOR THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THE PROGRAM THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES WILL BE THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT DATA
SOURCE TO THE CALIFORNIA CAN BE
A NEED TO MEASURE HEALTH CARE
COSTS. ANALYSTS TOTAL SECTOR
COST GROWTH RATES MONITOR
PERFORMANCE AND QUALITY
EVALUATE PRESCRIBING PATTERNS
TRACT CHRONIC DISEASES IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL HEALTH CARE THE BEANS
AND UNNECESSARY SPENDING IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY. AB TWENTY
THIRTY ESTABLISHES THE
FOUNDATION FOR ACHIEVING THE
TRIPLE AIM OF HEALTH CARE.
IMPROVING HEALTH CARE REDUCING
HEALTH CARE TO SPARE SIX
DISPARITIES WHILE CONTROLLING
COSTS. IS A COMPLEX BILL AND
I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS A COMMITTEE HOUSE.
JOINING US IN SUPPORT RON
COLEMAN WITH HELP HEALTH ACCESS
AND JOAN ALLEN WITH AS YOU ARE
YOU ARE HERE TO TESTIFY AND
BETH CAPELL WITH HEALTH ACCESS
IS ALSO ON THE LINE TO ASSIST
WITH TECHNICAL. QUESTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
WILL MOVE- TO. THE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT JUST AS A REMINDER
THAT'S LIMITED TO SIX MINUTES.
YOUR GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RONALD COLMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT BILLS HERE BEFORE YOU
TODAY HEALTH ACCESS ALONG WITH
OTHERS PARTICIPATED IN THE
REVIEW COMMITTEE PROCESS
SPARKED BY DOCTOR WOODS EFFORTS
CAN HEALTH CALL. AND IMPROVING
QUALITY WHILE ALSO REDUCING
DISPARITIES ARE THE GOALS AND
HEALTH CARE IT'S REFERRED TO AS
THE TROUBLING BECAUSE WE SHOULD
BE DOING ALL THREE AT THE SAME
TIME A HEALTH PAYMENTS DATABASE
WILL ALLOW POLICY MAKERS AND
RESEARCHERS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CALIFORNIA'S MAKING
PROGRESS ON THE TROUBLING OF
REDUCING COSTS IMPROVE QUALITY
WHILE ALSO REDUCING PROP
DISPARITIES IF WE HAD A HELP
PAYMENTS DATABASE TODAY. YOU
WOULD KNOW HOW MUCH CARE WAS
PROVIDED TO DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES YOU WOULD KNOW HOW
MUCH MONEY WAS PAID TO DOCTORS
AND HOSPITALS IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES FOR WHAT TYPES OF
CARE. THERE IS NO DISAGREEMENT
ON THE NEED FOR HELP PAYMENTS
DATABASE BUT THERE IS SOME
DISAGREEMENT ON THE SPECIFICS
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY PROPOSES
THAT WE COLLECT DATA DIRECTLY
FROM DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS WHY
THE US SUPREME COURT HAS
DETERMINED THAT BETTER LAW PRE
VINCE STATES FROM COLLECTING
DATA FROM THE FIVE TO SIX
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE IN
SELF INSURED EMPLOYER PLANS AND
ALSO LABOR TRUSTS. THAT AFFECTS
GROWTH STORE WORKERS OR THE
EMPLOYEES THAT GOOGLE OR ALSO
THE EMPLOYEES AT BANK OF
AMERICA. SO AB TWENTY THIRTY
PROPOSES TO GET DATA DIRECTLY
FROM HOSPITALS AND DOCTORS. THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED TODAY.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
CONCERNS FROM THE HOSPITALS AND
THE THREE YEAR DELAY GIVES TIME
TO WORK OUT SOME OF THE
OPERATIONAL ISSUES THAT CMA HAS
IDENTIFIED. YOU WILL HEAR
CONCERNS ABOUT PRIVACY BUT
WHERE REST ASSURED. WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT BOTH CMI AA AND
HIPPA AND THE DADDIES THE DATA
SECURITY REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THIS BILL AND OTHER
REQUIREMENTS ARE ENOUGH TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. AND THEIR
PRIVACY. AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
EXPRESSLY STATES THAT NO DATA
IS SUBJECT TO THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT. IT CREATES A
CRITERIA AND THE PROCESS FOR
RELEASING THE DATA ONLY TO
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS WHO CAN
MAINTAIN THE PRIVACY OF THE-
THIS IS NOT A SIMPLE PROCESS IN
THE HURDLES ARE GOING TO BE
REAL. THE REVIEW COMMITTEE
SPENT AN ENORMOUS TIME HASHING
OUT THESE ISSUES IN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW THIS WILL WORK
AND THE LANGUAGE ON THESE
PROVISIONS BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
LARGELY THAT DEVELOPED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND- THE WORK.
OF THE COMMITTEE. THE POINT OF
AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY IS TO
KNOW WHAT DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS
ARE GETTING PAID BY HEALTH
PLANS AND SELF INSURED PLANS.
AND TO KNOW WHAT HEALTHCARE IS
DELIVERED IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES ELIMINATING
REPORTING BY PROVIDING
ELIMINATING REPORTING BY
PROVIDERS WOULD MEAN THAT THERE
IS NO INFORMATION ON THE CARE
FOR THE FIVE TO SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIANS. IN THOSE PLANS
ELIMINATING CONTRACTED RATES
WOULD WE MEAN THAT WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW. HOW MUCH CARE
ACTUALLY COST THIS INFORMATION
IS ESSENTIAL IN CALIFORNIA
MEETING THE TRIPLE EIGHT ONE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO. WORK WITH YOU
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU PERFECT
GREAT. WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT. HELLO MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M DAVE VS HERE ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA AND
ARE SEVEN HUNDRED MEMBERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY WHICH WILL FINALLY
ESTABLISH AND OPERATIONALIZE
THAT HEALTHCARE DATABASE- SCA
YOU AND OTHER CONSUMER
ORGANIZATION ALONG WITH OUR
LABOR PARTNERS HAVE WORK ON
THIS ISSUE FOR ALMOST TWENTY
YEARS AND WE ARE EXCITED THAT-
THIS BILL WILL HELP TO ACTUALLY
ENACT AND ESTABLISH THE
DATABASE. WE ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL AS YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH US ON OUR MANY
POLICY SUGGESTIONS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS DATABASE IS A
SUCCESSFUL ONE I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO JOHN ALLEN FROM ONE
OF OUR LOCAL THROUGH HAVE BEEN
OUR REPRESENTATIVE ON THE OFF
SPENT REVIEW COMMITTEE TO TALK
MORE ABOUT THE POLICIES IS THAT
SPECIFICS. OF THE BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS JOAN
ALLEN WITH US YEAH YOU YOU H.
W. AS I MENTIONED THAT I SAY
YOU CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATED IN
THE UP OFFERED REVIEW
COMMITTEE. OF AND I JOIN
STAKEHOLDERS WERE CROSS THE
HEALTHCARE CONTINUING TO YOUR
LONG PROCESS TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND EXCITED TO
SEE SO MANY OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OF WHICH WERE
FORMED BY CONSENSUS THROUGH
THAT YOUR LONG PROCESS THAT
REALLY WAS- BROUGHT OUT THE
BEST OF THE COLLABORATION OF
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM- IT SEEMS
UNANIMOUS RECOMMENDATIONS
REPRESENTED IN THIS BILL. AS
REFLECTED IN THE INTENT
LANGUAGE THE HPT WILL GIVE
POLICYMAKERS A POWERFUL TOOL TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH REDUCE
DISPARITIES AND CARE AND
OUTCOMES. ADVANCE COVERAGE AND
CONTAIN RISING COSTS WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN AS POTENTIAL
REALIZED IN SEVERAL OTHER
STATES MANY OF WHICH HAVE
FUNCTIONING AP CD'S OR ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF CREATING. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO USING THE HPD
TO BRING DATA DRIVEN SOLUTIONS
TO HELP POLICY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH CHALLENGES IN CALIFORNIA.
I OF ANY PUBLIC AND ANY
PERSONAL INFORMATION COLLECTED
BUT STATE THE H. P. REQUIRES
EXTENSIVE PRIVACY AND SECURITY
PROTECTION. OFTEN HAS
EXPERIENCE WITH COLLECTING IN
SECURING SENSITIVE PERSONAL
HEALTH INFORMATION AND THE BILL
FOLLOWS ROBUST PRIVACY
PROTECTION AND DATA SECURITY
PROTOCOLS. THE SECURITY PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS CREATE A FRAMEWORK
IN WHICH OFFICE STATE AGENCIES
AND OUTSIDE RESEARCHERS. CAN
SAFELY AND RESPONSIBLY USE
AGGREGATED ANALYSES BILL FROM
THE DATA CONTAINED IN THE H. B.%
DATE. AND UNDER STRICT DATA
SECURITY PROTOCOLS ALLOW
QUALIFIED RESEARCHERS TO ACCESS
THE UNDERLYING DATA ITSELF.
THESE ANALYSES WILL OUT HER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW BEST TO
CREATE AND AFFORDABLE AND
ACCOUNTABLE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
THAT WORKS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHAT'S YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
BILL AND OFTEN FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT THEIR TEAMS ALREADY DONE
ON THE TECHNICAL SIDE TO
PREPARE FOR THE H. B. D. YOUR
CROSS WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. PERFECT JUST IN
TIME JUST IN TIME. LET'S NOT
MOVE- TO THE PUBLIC AND TO SEE
IF THERE. IS ANYBODY THAT
WISHES TO ADD ON THEIR SUPPORT
DISCERNING AIM IN ORGANIZATION.
AND YOUR SUPPORT. MISTER
MODERATOR AS A REMINDER TO PUT
YOURSELF INTO THAT Q. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE WILL START
WITH LINE NUMBER SIXTY THREE
SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHANCE LAURIE FOR WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. AND THEN YOU WILL GO
LINE THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE THREE SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BENJAMIN TRYING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA. GO AHEAD SO WE
CAN HEAR YOU NOW YEAH VETERAN
TRYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. NEXT IS LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE THREE
EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PARKER GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE KIND OF AN IN BETWEEN
POSITION A POSITION OF CONCERN.
WE ALWAYS LIKE THAT THANK
DOCTOR WOULD FOR HIS AMENDMENT
TO CHANGE THE TIMELINE THAT
WITH ONE OF OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN. IN WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF ON AMENDMENT TWO ON DATA
SUBMISSION WE HAVE FROM
TECHNICAL CONCERNS AROUND THAT.
BUT I FEEL CONFIDENT WE CAN
WORK THEM OUT THANK YOU. GREAT
I WAS JUST GONNA INTERRUPT YOU
THERE FOR A SECOND AND SALES
GOING TO GO INTO THE
INBETWEENERS BUT I THINK WE GOT
THAT COVERED TO ANYBODY ELSE
THAT WISHES TO. TO ADD ON A
WITH THEIR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THREE EIGHT ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SERRA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DAVID INVOLVED ABOUT HALF OF
AMERICA'S DISAPPEAR ALSO IN
SUPPORT MY THINK THE OXBRIDGE
LEADERSHIP. AND THAT ENDS THE
QUEUE. GRAYSON JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE IF THERE'S ANY OTHER FOLKS
THAT ARE IN BETWEEN IS OR
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WANTS TO
PROVIDE SORT OF A BRIEF
TESTIMONY THAT'S IN BETWEEN.
NOT HEARING ANYONE SAID AND WE
WILL GO TO- ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. THE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- NICK LOUISE
US ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS BILL-
WERE- SUPPORTED WITH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A PAYMENT
TRANSPARENCY DATABASE BUT- WE
MUST UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSE THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED. I DO
WANT TO CLARIFY AND WE'VE SEEN
THE OUTLINE OF AMENDMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS WE HAVEN'T SEEN
LANGUAGE IT MAY ADDRESS A ONE
OF OUR ISSUES- SO MY TESTIMONY
SHOULD BE TAKING IN THAT
CONTEXT- JUST BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND NUMBERS A BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS PARTICIPATED IN
THE HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS
DATABASE REVIEW COMMITTEE. OR
PRIZE BOSCH PAD- PURSUANT TO
EIGHTEEN TEN OF OUR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THIS COMMITTEE
INCLUDING REPRESENTATION FROM A
VERY DIVERSE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING PLANS
CONSUMERS LABORS IN PROVIDERS-
THIS COMMITTEE APPROVED A SET
OF CONSENSUS BASED
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WAS
DELIVERED TO THE LEGISLATURE
EARLIER THIS YEAR. I'M IN OVER
OUR OVERALL WE BELIEVE OUR
POSITION ON ANY LEGISLATION TO
ENACT THE DATABASE SHOULD BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THOSE CONSENSUS
BASED RECOMMENDATIONS-
REGRETTABLY- AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY ON AS IT IS IN PRINT
THAT VERGES FROM THAT-
CONSENSUS DOCUMENT IN. A COUPLE
OF KEY AREAS- NUMBER ONE- IT
REQUIRES PLANS IN CARE YEARS TO
FINANCE THE DATABASE AFTER THE
FUNDING HIS HIS. EXPANDED
WITHIN YOUR TO. I'M IN THE
REVIEW INSTEAD THOUGHTFULLY
RECOMMEND THAT OFF PURSUE YOU
OTHER SOURCE OF FUN INCLUDING
USER SCHEDULE AND OTHER
REVENUE- WHICH IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE WITH RESPECT TO THESE
TYPES OF DATABASES. SO WE
WOULD- RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THIS REQUIREMENT OF BE STRUCK
FROM THE BILL- IN THE MORNING
WHY NEED WE FEED ON REVIEW
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDATIONS- AB
TWENTY THIRTY ALSO REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS AND CARRIERS TO
SUBMIT CONTRACTED RATE STOSCH
HEAD WITHOUT- THE BENEFIT OF
CONFIDENTIALITY- FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND- THIS RECORD
WAS ALSO NOT A REVIEW COMMITTEE
RECOMMENDATION- AND OUR MEMBERS
CONSIDER CONTRACTED PAYMENTS TO
PROVIDERS AS PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION- AND THE- POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE OF THIS INFORMATION.
WILL HAVE A NEGATIVE- MARKET-
IMPLICATIONS AND COULD
POTENTIALLY INCREASE NOT LOWER
HEALTH CARE COSTS SO WE ASK
THAT THIS BE REMOVED AS WELL-
CAP IS SUPPORTIVE OF ANY
COMMONSENSE- IN REASONABLE
EFFORTS TO ACHIEVE
AFFORDABILITY IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. WE WANT TO APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR- HE'S OUT PURSUE THE
ISSUE OF AFFORDABILITY AND- HAS
ATTEMPTED TO IMPACT HEALTH CARE
COSTS. SINCE HE'S BEEN CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND WE HAVE
WORKED HARD WITH HIM I TO
SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS
NEVERTHELESS- AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED OUT WE DO YOU OPPOSE AB
TWENTY THIRTY. UNLESS AS
AMENDED THANK YOU SIR THIS IS
THERE ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION GOT THREE MINUTES
LEFT. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE BRANDED
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION- WE MUST
YEAH REGRETTABLY TAKEN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL- UNTIL IT IS AMENDED TO
BRING THE LANGUAGE I INTO
ALIGNMENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
HOSPITAL. HE'S REPORT. I AS MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER COLEMAN STATED
CMA SUPPORTS THE CREATION OF A
PAYMENTS DATABASE AND
UNDERSTANDS THE IMPORTANCE OF
IT. AS IT RELATES TO ADDRESSING
COSTS. CMA WASN'T ACTIVE IN
PARTICIPATING MEMBER OF THE
REVIEW COMMITTEE AND WAS
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROCESS AND
THOSE. RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE LANGUAGE
PREPARE WITH THE BILL PERTAIN
TO THE DEFINITION OF MANTA.
THERE'S PAYMENTS DATABASE RELY
ON CLAIMS AND COUNTER DATA
TRANSACTIONS BETWEEN PHYSICIANS
AND PAYERS. THEREFORE HEALTH
PLANS ALREADY HAVE THIS DATA
AVAILABLE FROM THE POSITIONS.
PLACING A DUPLICATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT ON PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES OF ALL SIZES AND
MODES OF PRACTICE RESTRICTS THE
AMOUNT OF TIME A PHYSICIAN CAN
SPEND DELIVERING CARE TO
PATIENTS IN NEED. THE SHEER
VOLUME OF DATA COLLECTION
POINTS FROM PROVIDERS WOULD
INUNDATE THE DATABASE AND
RENDER IT VIRTUALLY INEFFECTIVE.
IN THE TEN YEARS SINCE THE
SUCCESSFUL CREATION OF THE
MASSACHUSETTS AND COLORADO
DATABASES. THOSE STATES HAVE
NOT REQUIRED COLLECTION FROM
PHYSICIANS NOR HAVE THEY
EXPRESSED A NEED TO AS THE
STATE'S ARE REPORTING THAT MANY
OF THEIR SELF INSURED PLANS ARE
VOLUNTARILY REPORTING THIS
INFORMATION. ADDITIONALLY THE
INFORMATION COLLECTED IN THE
DATABASE CAN BE CONFIDENTIAL
AND PROPRIETARY AND THE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION SHOULD
ONLY BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
QUALIFIED ENTITIES AND USE FOR
APPROPRIATE PURPOSES. WITHOUT
PROPER PROTECTIONS IN PLACE THE
BILL AS IT IS WRITTEN REYES
THIS YEAR'S ANTI CRAFT CONCERNS.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR CONCERNS
AT THIS TIME. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS AS THE BILLS FOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I WILL GO
TO THE THOSE AT THE BY THE
PUBLIC AND TO MISTER MODERATOR
ARE THERE ANY ANYBODY ON THE
LINE WHO WISHES TO OPPOSE JUST
THIS JUST THE- THE ME TO USE
THE OUT ON. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AND HAVE YOUR VOICE
HEARD IN A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE IN THE QUEUE
CURRENTLY IT'S LINE THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX THREE
EIGHT SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
STEPHANIE WHAT CAN BE HAVE TO
BE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE.
COMPANIES ALSO WITH AND OPPOSE
UNDOCUMENTED ATTENTION GREAT
THANK YOU. NO FURTHER IN Q.
GREAT IF THERE'S NOTHING
FURTHER THAT WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SING NINE DOCTOR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF THINGS HERE- BRIEFLY-
RESPONSE WAS SAID THIS THIS
DATABASE COULD BE THIS THE MOST
SINGLE MOST SIGNIFICANT THING
I'VE EVER WORKED ON THE
LEGISLATURE. IF WE'RE TRULY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THE COSTS OF HEALTH CARE WE
NEED THIS DATA. SO I OBJECT TO
THE IDEA THAT WE DON'T WANT TO-
WE DON'T WANT TO REPORT
CONTRACTED RATES LOOK I
PRACTICED DENTISTRY FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS. I HAD A RATE AND
I HAD A CONTRACT AND- THE THERE
WERE DIFFERENT THAT CONTRACTED
RATE WAS ALWAYS LOWER THAN MY
WILL CALL UP THE RACK RATE- WE
NEED TO KNOW WHAT THAT
CONTRACTED RATE IS BECAUSE
THAT'S THE TRUE REFLECTION OF
EXPENDITURES. AND IS REALLY
CRITICAL THAT WE DO THAT- IF
WE- WE HAVE BILL TEN
CONFIDENTIALLY CONFIDENTIALITY
REQUIREMENTS ANY PRICING
INFORMATION THAT IS
CONFIDENTIAL- IT WOULD ALSO BE
EXEMPT FROM PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
TO ACT WE HAVE BEEN CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THIS I THINK THIS IS
THE FOUNDATIONAL- PIECE OF.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL HELP
US TO BE ABLE TO TRULY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE SPENDING
ON HEALTH CARE NOT ONLY WILL WE
BE ABLE TO USE THAT AS A WAY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WHAT WE'RE
SPENDING WILL BE ABLE TO USE
THAT TO DO A DATA DIVE TO
UNDERSTAND. ARE WE SPENDING
MONEY IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY
POSSIBLE OR ARE WE SPENDING
MONEY THAT ISN'T AFFECTED FOR
TREATMENT. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION HERE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. I AM
DISAPPOINTED THAT PHYSICIANS
THAT THAT THAT I'M HEARING FROM
CMA THAT THEY DON'T WANT
PHYSICIANS TO REPORT. THE LAST
I RECKON THE LAST I RECOGNIZE
WHEN I WENT TO THE DOCTOR I
PAID THE DOCTOR. SO YEAH YOU
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ET SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION THROUGH
THROUGH A HEALTH PLAN. BUT IF
YOU'RE A SELF INSURED PLAN-
LIKE A LOT OF OUR LABOR TRUSTS
THEY DON'T THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT MANDATED TO REPORT
THAT SO WE NEED THAT POSITION
DATA- UP FRONT. SO I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS- I
THINK IT'S FOUNDATIONAL TO OUR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO FIND A
WAY TO MAKE HEALTHCARE MORE
AFFORDABLE TO EVERYONE. WITH
THE GOAL THAT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
A- THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD. DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL-
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. I'M SORRY WE
ALREADY DID- SO I THINK IT'S
AUTUMN AND I'M SORRY MISS BURKE
A AND I GOT VERY. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND- MET HER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD. WOOD I.
MAYES AYE MAYES AYE A GEAR
CURRY. OUR GEAR CURRY I'D
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE I'D
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA
NOT VOTING LIMóN. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RAMOS RAMOS I
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WALDRON AYE. TEN I KNOW ZERO
KNOWS BILL PASSES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- SERVICE GOT
MEMBERS I THINK THE ONE MISSILE
MOMENTS MISSING. LET'S JUST
GIVE A SECOND HERE THEY JUST
OUT HERE. SO WE'RE MISSING
MISSILE AMOUNT. I'M SORRY I
DON'T. SEER BUT I HEAR OKAY
OKAY ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO
GO AHEAD THEN AND WE TO START
AT THE TOP WE CAN WORK THROUGH
THE WORK THROUGH. ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TWO FOUR SIX FOUR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LIMB ON. LIMóN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY II NAZARIAN.
NUMBER ONE AB TWO FOUR SIX FOUR
NAZARIAN I'D. BURKE BURKE I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D. FIFTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB THREE ZERO
EIGHT THREE ARAMBULA OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MCCARTY. MCCARTY II. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
THREE ONE ONE EIGHT BONTA
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES.
MAYES I BIGELOW. BIGELOW I.
MCCARTY I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D
WALDRON WALDRON AYE. FIFTEEN
ICE ZERO NOW ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB THREE THREE THREE SIX
CARILLO PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
BURKE. NOT VOTING. MCCARTY
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
AYE. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO BY.
EIGHT I THREE KNOWS BILL PASSES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWO TWO EIGHT
ZERO CHAO PLEASE LIST THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MAY.
MAYES NOT VOTING. BURKE BURKE I.
BURKE NOT VOTING. MCCARTY
MCCARTY II NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I'D. TEN
ICE KNOWS ZERO OKAY- THE
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE. BURKE I LIVE ON
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN ICE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I'D FIFTEEN EYES NO
ZERO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BURKE BURKE I. LIMóN
LIMóN I. FIFTY NINE ZERO NOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY FIFTEEN
EGGMAN PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BURKE.
BURKE. AB TWENTY FIFTEEN EGGMAN
BURKE I. ICE FIFTEEN KNOWS ZERO
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SIX FLORA PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE. BURKE I CARILLO.
HE HEATH BEST BILL EVER. CORREO
II. LIMóN LIMóN NINE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY MCCARTY. MCCARTY ALLY
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I'D FIFTEEN ICE. ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX MISTER GLORIA
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL AND CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS MAIN. MAYES
I BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. CORREO
AYE FLORA FLORA NOT VOTING LIVE
ON. LIMóN AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE SANTIAGO. AB
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX GLORIA.
I WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
THIRTEEN ICE ZERO NOW THANK YOU
NUMBER SIXTEEN EIGHTY TWO ONE
ONE EIGHT KALRA PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLLING CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARIEL. TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
KALRA. CORREO I'D LEAN ON
LIMóN I WALDRON. WALDRON NOW.
ELEVEN ICE FOR KNOWS THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER A SEVENTEEN AB
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT LOW
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA NOT
VOTING. MCCARTY MCCARTY I'D
KNOWS. WALL WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
ELEVEN ICE ZERO KNOWS THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWO
THREE SIX ZERO MAIENSCHEIN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS NAMES. MAYES
NOT VOTING. BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY MAIENSCHEIN. CORREO
CARILLO I LIVE ON LIMóN AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON NOT VOTING.
ITEM I'M SORRY ELEVEN ICE TO
NEW HOURS. ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
MISTER NAZARIAN AB TWO TWO ZERO
THREE PLEASE LIFT THE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARIEL. CORREO I MCCARTY MCCARTY
II. TWELVE ICE KNOWS IT ZERO
THANK YOU I BY THE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE IS THERE IN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BONTA. TWENTY ITEM
TWENTY ONE YEAH. BONTA I BURKE
BURKE I TO RIO. TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. IS THERE IN. I
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. FIFTEEN ICE
ZERO KNOWS THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE A. B. TWO
ONE ONE TWO MISTER RAMOS PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS NAME ON. LIMóN NINE
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE AYES
FIFTEEN ZERO NOW THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX EIGHTY THREE
TWO TWO FOUR RODRIGUEZ PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA. FLORA NOT VOTING
NAME ON. NAME ONE NINE MCCARTY
MCCARTY II. FOURTEEN EYES ZERO
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB TWO TWO
ONE EIGHT MISTER SANTIAGO
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS MAY MAYES I.
FLORA FLORA NO NAME ON. LIMóN
ONLINE MCCARTY. MCCARTY I'D
WALDRON. WALDRON NOT VOTING.
TWELVE I ONE NO THANK YOU- ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY NINE AB TWO ZERO
SEVEN SEVEN MISTER TEAM PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA. FLORA NO NAME ON.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RAMOS
RODRIGUEZ. ELEVEN ICE TO KNOWS
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
ONE AB TWO ZERO THREE SEVEN
WEEKS PLEASE LIFT THE CALL AND
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS NAME ON
LIMóN ONLINE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
SANTIAGO. TWO ZERO THREE SEVEN
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE. MISS
WICKS. SANTIAGO I'D. TEN ICE
THREE KNOWS. ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR AB TWO THREE FOUR SEVEN
WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA. BONTA
I'D LIMóN LIMóN NINE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
AYE SANTIAGO. AB TWO THREE FOUR
SEVEN WOULD. SANTIAGO I'D.
FOURTEEN I ZERO NOW ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE AB TWO SIX FOUR
FOUR WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BONTA
BONTA I'D LAME ON. NAME ONE
NINE MCCARTY MCCARTY I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN ICE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO-
BY FIFTY NINE ZERO NO AND
FINALLY ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX
EIGHTY TWO EIGHT THREE ZERO
WOULD- PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS NAME ON.
NAME ON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE.
THIRTEEN ICE ZERO NO THAT
CONCLUDES- THE VOTES- I BELIEVE
MR FLORA HAD A VOTE CHANGE HE
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER. THE SIX
THREE. OR FOUR. AB TWENTY
THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
RODRIGUEZ- FLOOR GOES FROM NOT
VOTING TO HIGH. THAT WAS ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX. VOTE CHANGE
RIGHT AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
FLORA FROM THAT VOTING TO BUY I.
FIFTEEN EYES ZERO NO THANK YOU
THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK OUR STAFF FOR EVERYTHING
THEY'VE DONE HERE TO MAKING
THIS WORK- THE FLOOR STAFF
EVERYBODY PUT THIS TOGETHER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANNA GETS
OUR MODERATOR WHO WAS AWESOME
TOO BY THE WAY AGAIN HOW SAY
THAT AGAIN. WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED.